welcome to this new full course on
search engine optimization by simply
learn in this course you will get the
complete SEO road map moving ahead we
will understand how to become SEO expert
starting with the SEO Concepts we will
first dive deep into the definition of
SEO how SEO works on page SEO off page
SEO and on page off page techniques this
course also proves a detailed guide for
keyword research for Google and YouTube
we will also see how to rank number one
on YouTube how to rank number one on
Google we will wrap up this cause by
putting a light on SEO jobs in the
industry and SEO interview questions so
if you are looking to grab a successful
career in digital marketing and learn
search engine optimization simply learn
has got you covered with a wide range of
topn digital marketing courses these
courses make you skill in SEO content
marketing PPC social media marketing and
much more with hands-on experience in
the tools like Google analytics Keyword
Planner Sim rush and there's a huge list
on the board however one year of
experience is preferred to enroll in
these courses find the course Link in
the description box before we begin
consider subscribing to Simply learn and
hit the Bell icon to never miss any
updates from us so without any further
delay over to our tutors in the ever
evolving landscape of the digital realm
where visibility is Paramount and
competition is FS Mastering the Art and
Science of search Eng and optimization
SEO has never been more crucial as we
set our sides on 2024 the world of SEO
is posed for remarkable Transformations
offering a spectrum of opportunities to
those who Dare To Tread its Dynamic path
imagine having the power to harness the
algorithms that decide which website
rise to the top of search engine results
Envision the ability to craft compelling
content that not only captures the
hearts and minds of your audience but
also climbs the digital ranks
effortlessly picture yourself as the
guiding force behind businesses striving
for online prominence in this SEO road
map for 2024 we will navigate through
the twist and turns of the SEO landscape
unveiling the strategies and insights
that will make you a true SE expert in
the year ahead from understanding the
latest trends and staying ahead of
algorithm updates to per expecting the
intricate dance of technical SEO and
content strategy this road map will be
your companion on the journey to SEO
Mastery so fasten your seat belts as you
embark on a thrilling Expedition into
the world of SEO in 2024 it's time to
unlock the secrets of search engines and
Propel yourself into the realm of
digital success so the number one is
user experience user experience is a top
priority in SE search engines now
consider factors like like page speed
mobile friendliness and user friendly
layouts as crucial for ranking well
positive user experience keeps visitors
on your site and reduces bounce rates
and the next is mobile optimization
mobile optimization remains a key
challenge with the increasing use of
smartphones ensuring that your website
is mobile friendly is vital for SEO
success this includes responsive design
fast loading times and mobile first
indexing and now moving to the next
Trend that is E8 expert
authoritativeness and trustworthiness
EAD is critical for SEO in 2023 search
engines aims to provide users with high
quality and trustworthy content
demonstrating expertise
authoritativeness and trustworthiness in
your content and across your site is
essential and the next trend is voice
search voice search continues to grow
optimizing for voice search involves
using natural language answering
specific questions and providing concise
informative content understand
understanding how users speak their
queries is key and now moving on to the
next Trend that is content quality and
relevance high quality relevant content
is essential creating content that
addresses user intent is up to date and
adds value to your audience is crucial
for SEO success and the next trend is
data analytics and AI data analytics and
AI tools are increasingly used for SEO
leveraging data driven insights and
Technology helps in making informed
decisions personalizing content and
improvising user experiences these
Trends and challenges highlight the
importance of adapting to the
challenging landscape of SEO to maintain
and improve your website search engine
rankings and visibility now we'll start
with the SEO expert road map for
2024 so the first step is mastering the
basics that is on page and off-page SEO
so we'll start with on page SEO and the
first keyword or the first features of
on page SEO is that is is keyword
research understand how to perform
keyword research to identify relevant
Search terms for your content and then
comes the content optimization learn how
to optimize your web pages with high
quality relevant content and
strategically place keywords within it
and then comes the metat Texs
familiarize yourself with optimizing
meta Texs including title tags meta
descriptions and header tags and then
comes the URL structure understand the
importance of a clean and SEO friendly
URL structure and then there is internal
linking know how to create an effective
internal linking structure to enhance
user experience and SEO and now coming
to op page SEO we'll see the features of
it number one is backlink building that
is learn how to build high quality
backlinks from authoritative websites in
your Niche understand the importance of
natural earned backlinks for off page SE
then comes the social signals comprehend
the role of social media in off page SEO
and how social signals can impact search
engine rankings and then comes the local
SEO for businesses targeting a local
audience Master local SEO strategies
including claiming your Google my
business listing and managing online
reviews and then comes the citation
building understand the significance of
nap name address phone number
consistency for local SEO and citation
building and the next is brand Mansions
know how unlink brand mentions can
contribute to off page SE and reputation
management by mastering these own page
and page SEO Basics you will build a
solid foundation for the journey to
become an SEO expert and now moving on
to the next step that is stay informed
on SEO Trends so continuously follow
industry blogs webinars and conferences
to keep up with SEO Trends and algorithm
updates so now you see the steps how you
can achieve this step so the number one
is subscribe to SEO blogs that is follow
reputable SEO blogs and websites like
like moose search engine land and search
engine journal to get the latest updates
and insights in the field the second is
join SEO communities participate in
online SEO communities and forums like
reddits SEO or SEO related groups on
LinkedIn to discuss Trends and learn
from others in the industry and now
moving on to the next that is webinars
and conferences attend SEO webinars and
conferences where industry experts
discuss new trends best practices and
algorithm updates keep an eye out for
both local and international events now
coming to the next that is SEO
newsletters subscribe to SEO newsletters
that provide regular updates on industry
news and Trends these newsletters often
curate valuable information now coming
to the next that is podcast listen to
SEO podcast where experts share their
knowledge and insights podcast are a
convenient way to stay informed on the
go so this was all about the Second Step
that is stay informed on SEO Trends now
moving on to the next step that is
technical SEO proficiency so now we'll
see the steps how we can master in this
technical SEO proficiency and the number
one is site speed optimization ensure
your website loads quickly to improve
user experience and search engine
rankings compress images Minify CSS and
JavaScript and leverage browser caching
and the next is mobile friendliness
optimize your site for mobile users as
Google prioritizes mobile first indexing
use responsive design Test Mobile
usability and create mobile friendly
content and the next is schema markup
Implement schema markup to provide
search engines with structured data
about your content this can enhance Rich
Snippets in search results and improve
click through rates and the next is
cability and indexability ensure that
search engines can easily CW and index
your websites user sitap robots. txe and
canonical tags to guide search Eng
effectively and the next is structure
data Implement structure data to help
search engines understand the content on
your site better now moving to the next
step that is step four that is content
strategy and now we'll see the features
or the steps to learn content strategy
number one is keyword research and
targeting start with Comprehensive
keyword research to identify relevant
keywords and phrases that your audience
is searching for the next is quality and
relevance Ure your content is of high
quality informative and relevant to your
target audience then comes the content
variety diversify your content types
including blog post videos infographics
and podcast then comes the topic
clusters and pillar content Implement a
topic cluster strategy where you create
pillar content that is comprehensive
guides or Cornerstone articles and
support it with related in-depth
articles and then comes the content
promotion develop a plan to promote your
content through social media email
marketing and Outreach so this was about
the fourth step now coming to the fifth
step that is eat and user experience so
eat that is expertise authoritativeness
and
trustworthiness so the first step to
learn all these is focus on
demonstrating expertise in your content
by showcasing your qualifications and
expertise in the subject matter
establish authoritativeness by earning
backlinks from reputable sources and
ensure your content is Trust worthy and
well referenced and the next is user
centering content craft content that
genuinely serves the users's need
offering valuable information and
solutions and then is transparent
attribution clearly attribute authors
and their credentials for the content
reinforcing trust and authority and then
is the mobile friendly user experience
ensure your website is mobile responsive
as Google values a positive mobile user
experience and then comes the user
engagement metrics monitor user
engagement metrics like click through
rates bounce rates and time on site now
moving on to the next step that is data
analysis and tools so now we'll see the
steps to learn data analysis and tools
that is the first step is Google
analytics Mastery learn how to set up
and effectively use Google analytics to
track website performance user behavior
and conversion metrics then comes the
Google search console proficiency that
is understand the insights and tools
available in Google search console to
monitor website visibility in search
results identify issues and optimize
content and then comes the keyword
research tools familiarize yourself with
keyword research tools such as seam rush
rush RFS and most to identify valuable
keywords andss keyword competition and
then comes the SEO auditing software
utilize SEO auditing tools like
screaming frog or side bulb to conduct
comprehensive website audits identify
technical Soo isues and optimize site
structure
and then comes the data visualization
skills develop the ability to create
visual reports and dashboards to
communicate SEO performance data
effectively to stakeholders or clients
and now moving on to the seventh step
that is link building strategies and now
we'll see the steps for this step that
is quality or quality that is focus on
acquiring high quality authoritative
back from reputable websites rather than
pursuing a large volume of low quality
links the next is natural link
acquisition and then comes the Outreach
and relationship building that is
actively reach out to relevant websites
bloggers and influencers to request
backlinks and then is the guest posting
that is contribute guest post to
authoritative websites in your Niche and
show that the content is valuable and
relevant and then comes the Monitor and
ISO regularly monitor your backlink
profile to identify and ISO any toxic or
spammy links that could harm your Su
efforts so this was all about the
seventh step now moving on to the next
step that is eighth algorithm changes so
now we will see the steps what the
algorithm changes include so the number
one is stay informed that is regularly
monitor SEO new sources and official
search engine announcements to stay up
to date of any upcoming algorithm
changes the next is adapt quickly when
algorithm updates occur be prepared to
adjust your SEO strategies promptly to
align with the new ranking criteria and
requirements M ments the next is analyze
impact and then comes the audit and
optimize that is conduct regular site
audits to identify and address any
issues that might affect your website's
ranking then comes the diversify
strategies avoid over Reliance on
specific SEO tactics now coming to the
ninth step that is structured SEO
strategy now moving to the steps that
include the structured SE strategy the
number one is keyword research and
targeting and then comes the content
planning that is create a Content
calendar that outlines when and what
type of content you will produce and
then comes the on page optimization that
is Implement on page SEO techniques
including optimizing metatags and then
comes the link building strategy that is
develop a strategy for acquiring high
quality backlinks and then comes the
performance monitoring that is regularly
track the performance of your Su efforts
using tools like Google analytics and
then comes the next step that is the
10th step that is certifications and
courses now we'll see the steps the
number one is choose reputable Su
certification programs op for well
recognized and reputable certification
programs such as Google analytics or
Google ad certification these
certifications demonstrate your
expertise in specific SEO areas and then
comes the advanced SEO courses consider
enrolling in advanced SEO courses
offered by trusted educational
institutions such as universities or
online learning platforms such as simply
learn that have postgraduate program for
digital marketing now moving on to the
third step that is specialized SE
certification look for specialized SEO
certification from organizations like Mo
or Hub Sport and then comes stay updated
the SEO field evolves rapidly so you
have to stay updated as this is crucial
for long-term success and then comes the
practical application seek out courses
that include Hands-On projects and
practical exercises
by investing in certifications and
courses that align with your career
goals and staying committed to
continuous learning you will be well on
your way to becoming a proficient Su
expert now moving to the next step that
is 11th step that is practice and
experiment and now we'll see the steps
in this step that is a testing that is
conduct a test to compare different
elements of your website such as
headlines images or calls to action to
determine what resonate best with your
audience and improves SEO results then
comes the keyword experimentation and
that is continuously test and refine
your keyword strategies explore new
keywords and then comes the content
iteration that is regularly update and
improve existing content based on user
feedback and analytics data and then
comes the link building strategies
experiment with various link building
techniques Outreach methods and content
promotion strategies to identify what
works best for Niche and audience and
then comes local SEO tactics experiment
with different local SEO techniques such
as optimizing Google my business
profiles soliciting reviews and running
localized ad campaigns to enhance your
local search visibility experimentation
is a critical aspect of su expertise as
it allows you to fine-tune your
strategies Based on data and feedback
ultimately driving better results and
now these are the steps to be owner Su
expert and for the SEO road map 2024 now
moving to the job roles within the field
of SEO
so there are various job roles within
the field of su each with its own set of
responsibilities and expertise here are
some common SE job roles and we'll start
with SEO specialist SEO Specialists are
experts in optimizing websites for
search engines they focus on on page and
off-page SE optimization keyword
research and implementing SE best
practices and the average base salary
for SE specialist in United States is
$150,000 per year and in India it is 11
LS perom and now coming to the next job
rooll that is content strategist content
strategist are responsible for planning
and creating content that aligns with
SEO goals they develop content
strategies conduct keyword research and
ensure content is optimized for search
engines and their average salary in
United States is
$145,000 perom and in India it is $13
lakhs per an and then comes the
technical Su manager that is focus on
the technical aspects of a website such
as site structure page speed and mobile
optimization they work to improve the
website's technical performance for
better search rankings and the average
salary for technical SEO manager in
United States is
$120,000 and in India it is 10 lakhs
perom and now moving to link building
specialist link building specialist
concentrate on acquiring high quality
backlinks from authoritative websites
they play a crucial role in improving a
website's domain Authority
and search engine rankings and the
average salary for link building
specialist in United States is
$156,000 perom and then in India it is 8
lakhs perom and then moving to the local
SEO specialist that is local SEO
specialist focus on optimizing a website
for local search results they help
businesses appear in local searches
particularly important for Brick and
Mortar businesses and the average salary
in United States for local s specialist
is $15,000 perom and in India that is 7
lakhs perom so these roles scatter to
various aspects of SEO from content
creation and Technical optimizations to
local search and data analysis depending
on your interest and expertise you can
choose the role that best aligns with
the career goals in the field of SEO so
there you have it the SEO road map for
2024 SEO is a dynamic field and staying
ahead of the curve is key to your online
success make sure to stay tuned for more
in-depth videos on each of these topics
in the upcoming weeks SEO and growth of
businesses are going hand in hand these
days anyone looking for good growth in
their business tries to grab the
attention of the audiences with the
similar interest on the web for which
SEO plays an important role SEO
techniques are equally impactful for a
Google website or an Instagram post more
your content reaches the Right audience
the more likely you are to get the leads
and make business out of it because of
this SEO experts are in high demand in
this video on how to become an SEO
expert we will share the best tips to
become an SEO expert in a very short
period of time but before we begin
consider subscribing to our Channel and
hit the Bell icon to never miss any
updates from Simply learn so here is a
question for you when was SEO first used
option one in 1980s option two in 1970s
option three in 1990s and option four in
2010s let us know your answer in the
comment section below and if your answer
is correct you will get a heart from
Simply learn so without any further Ado
let's start by understanding what Market
holds for professional SEO experts
nowadays it is very common to start a
business by having a website with the
increase of website there is always a
need of organic growth and there the SEO
comes into picture it is important to
have an SEO expert to have a well SEO
optimized website Market is flourished
with a ton of SEO jobs from SEO
executive to SEO manager all the SEO job
roles have high demand the salary for
various SE roles is estimated to reach
as high as
$100,000 giants like coin switch eBay
howlet packet in the industries are
ready to hire the candidates having SEO
expertise so without taking a minute
let's start with our Pro tips on how to
become an SEO expert number one is
understanding the basics of content
creation and content
optimization as it is said content is
the king to be an SEO expert you need to
be the best in content creation search
engines value high quality content and
promote it to be on the top of search
results creating high quality content
should be be the must have quality of an
SEO expert although this is not enough
once you create a good content it is
necessary for the content to be well
optimized you should have a great
content strategies to spread the content
among the Right audience let's move to
our tip number two understanding SEO
Basics it is really important to
understand the basics to make the right
decisions having technical knowledge of
SEO May prevent you from making mistakes
mes that may harm your business directly
or indirectly say having right knowledge
on how onpage optimization Works will
help you to optimize your content or web
pages more efficiently thereby allowing
your content or web pages to rank higher
in search result page moving towards our
next tiep which is how search engine
works search engines are responsible for
listing the user search queries due to
which it becomes comes easier for search
engines to identify the content and
display the relevant results search
engines work on three basic steps
crawling indexing and ranking crawling
also known as web crawling involves
search engine boards to crawl your web
content and pick up the hints or showing
what the web page is about with these
hints or here we can say important
keywords search engine boards indexes
your web content into the web index once
your page is indexed it gets easily
eligible to appear in the search results
if a user enters the query and your
content matches the query it appears in
the search results moreover if your
content is really unique then you never
know it can also rank on the first
position coming to a tip number four
understanding and implementation of
technical aspects of SEO before moving
into this domain one should be aware of
technical aspects of SEO you should have
a good understanding on how a website
should actually be is the website
structure easy to understand if not then
how one can make it easy website
structure plays an important role for
search engine Bots if search engine Bots
find that the website is not easily
cable they will leave your website and
thus you may face a heavy loss in
indexing your Pages it is considered to
be a good practice to submit site maps
to search engines some other technical
factors include having a less page load
speed meaningful page links having the
keyword with the page targets having no
dead or 44 pages and more let's Now
understand why one should have a good
knowledge of Google analytics and Google
search console tools to be an SEO expert
Google Analytics and search console
Google analytics is a web analytics
service offered by Google it was
launched by Google back in 2005 Google
analytics generates various type of
reports and helps track bounce rates
identify the best content for your
website record user Behavior flow on
your site and many other metrices
thereby allowing you to understand and
build your business strategies thereby
growing your business
now that we have understood why Google
analytics is essential let's understand
about Google search console search
console priorly known as Google web
master tool monitors the technicalities
of the website say suppose your website
is not visible in search results so
there is a possibility that search
engine crawlers are unable to crawl your
website thus it is not visible in search
results to make crawlers crawl your
website you need to optimize your
website using search console some other
technical aspects which makes search
console more important includes fixing
indexing problems sending the updated
content or Pages for reindexing
generating page error reports generating
alerts if there are any indexing or
other issues gets the list of sites
linking to your website keep a track of
mobile usability amp pages and more some
other tools helpful in SEO are screaming
frog which works similar to search
engine board sem Rush is used for
competitor analysis RFS is used for
backlink report generation and more so
let us know in the comment section below
out of the above tools which one you are
using for optimizing your content so
moving ahead with our next Pro tip which
is link building
link building helps in getting traffic
as well as trust in the eyes of search
engines getting backlink is one of the
important ranking factors thus getting
more and more backlinks helps the search
engines to understand that the quality
of your content is high and so other
websites are linking to your page which
also helps in getting more traffic and
high rankings having great link building
strategies will boost your career as an
SEO expert if you're not aware of
backlink building strategies watch
videos on how to build backlink by
simply learn you can find the link in
the description box below moving to the
tip number seven follow other SEO
experts for their strategies and stay
connected with SEO forum for recent
updates and
discussions search engines are
continuously changing so it is possible
that the things that are working now
won't be working for your web Pages the
next day thus it is important to stay
updated with what's new with search
engines following experts under the same
domain helps in growth of skills so the
question arises how or where can you
find these experts well look for the SEO
communities of Google you can join
various SEO Forums on LinkedIn groups on
Facebooks and other Q&A and social media
platforms this not only helps in growth
of skills but it also keeps you updated
with the industry now speaking about
another Pro tip for being an excellent
SE professional which is joining courses
to improve SEO skills there is a lot of
content developing each day on SEO and
so are the courses if you fail to
understand the SEO techniques or any
other SEO related topics by the research
there are lots of free and paid courses
available across the web certifications
in any domain is always a plus point for
the career SEO techniques may not be
that fruitful at the very first time all
you need to do is have patience observe
what works for your content and what
doesn't learn from your observations
find new ways to put the improved
strategies on the table so that you get
the best out of your SEO practices what
is search engine
optimization practice of getting traffic
organically through the search results
with the help of search engine is called
search engine
optimization although being one of the
most important components of digital
marketing SEO has had some mths floating
around it Su increases the popularity of
your brand product or Services among the
audience thereby increasing the chances
of conversion of lead to
customer
traffic obtained organically is more
consistent once you are aware of SEO
strategies and start gaining visibility
in search results your site will gain
constant traffic that will keep
increasing with
time with SEO one can reach a large
audience to promote products and
services businesses can acquire
audiences from both the national and
international
levels SEO builds trust among the
audience for instance if your web page
is available on Google search results
the audience finds it worthy of trust
because of its online
presence your competitors are doing it
then you should also do it this could be
a serious note if your competitors are
doing this to rank high and gain
visibility you must also do it or remain
back in the race let's understand it
with the help of an
analogy Susan started a business of
handmade toys she failed to gain enough
customers using traditional marketing
methods like newspaper advertisements
and Banners so she thought of putting
the business online thereby creating a
website the website was completely
optimized for search engines and was
soon visible on the search result Pages
the website started acquiring the
traffic which ultimately became her
customers the sales were boosted to an
unexpected level and the revenue has
increased
exponentially a good decision brought
huge success to Susan's business Susan
was thrilled with joy when a thought
struck across her mind how was search
engines able to find her
website so search engines can be Google
Bing yandu dug Duo Etc which work on
three basic
steps that are crawling indexing and
ranking first we will understand
crawling search engines are hungry for
content and so they send the Web spiders
also known as crawlers or robots or
search engine Bots to discover new
content or any updated content content
can be an image web page video or
anything else present on the web this
process is known as
crawling soon after the discovery of
content Web spiders start storing the
URL of the content into the search index
and this process is known as indexing
once the content is indexed it appears
in the search results for the relevant
searches when a user enters a search
query the most relevant search results
are taken from the index and displayed
from most relevant to least relevant on
the search result Pages this process is
known as ranking recite best practices
for onpage signals such as title tags
header tags URLs alt text and
others list and describe onpage SEO
tactics that you should avoid describe
how natural language process aims to
understand the meaning behind
text search engine optimization is very
very complex so when you're trying to
understand it for the first time I find
it's very easy and best to just break it
into general concepts that you already
have some understanding of so when I
look at the hundreds of con hundreds of
signals that go into SEO I break all of
them up into either relevancy and or
because sometimes it's both popularity
so relevancy popularity out of all these
signals they fit into one of the these
two things throughout the rest of this
chapter in this course we're going to
break all the signals we have into these
two areas so that you can rely on what
you already know about the concept of
relevancy and the concept of popularity
to have some kind of Anchor Point for
these new brand these new ideas in this
section we're going to talk about the on
page factors and I'll tell you right up
front that these are going to become
your favorite these are the ones that
you have the most impact on and that you
can make a small tweak and have a
gigantic impact on the amount of organic
traffic that you send start with one of
my favorites title tags title tags are
the sing sing Le most important on page
metric that we have access to this is
text that we get to express that we get
to write that shows the intent and the
purpose of that page on the internet
this is really really important because
search engines use this this text that
we get to provide in their search
results directly so we get to write what
becomes the headline of the search
result itself this uh in addition to uh
The Meta description as we'll cover next
are the two factors that we have a whole
lot of control over that influence both
click-through rates and people's first
impressions of our brand next up we have
metad descriptions now meta descriptions
are a little bit confusing because it is
text that we get to provide to search
engines but more often than not they
override what we provide and try to
choose something that is better in their
opinion now I go both ways with this
sometimes it really is better most of
the time though in my opinion it's not
um but the important thing here is that
we get to provide what would normally
we'd have to pay for with ad copy we get
to provide it for free customize it to
it however we want to entice to entice
clicks and the search engines are happy
to promote that and show that in the
search results
all right now we're getting to the good
nerdy stuff the header tags so this was
something that was built into HTML when
the web was first created uh the idea
here is that you're establishing a
hierarchy so you start with one H1 uh
saying what the main purpose of the page
is and you start to break it into
subcategories so you'll have multiple
H2S below that multiple h3s between all
of that now H1s used to be a very
important in primary SEO metric that we
got to use but because it got abused it
now has less of an importance than it
used to so it shows what information is
less or more important than other
information on the page but it is no
longer the strongest indicator of what
is the most important page on that and
right now that's still title tags next
up we have URLs uniform resource
locators now these are the addresses of
web documents online just like you have
a street address for your house on the
internet we have URLs for any given
document anywhere could be PDFs it could
be images it could be text it could be
your homepage all of these have URLs
these are extremely important for us
here for a variety of reasons the most
important though is your keyword usage
you want to make sure that the words
that you're trying to rank for are
included in your URLs the second part of
this ties in directly the first is you
want to keep these short so it's not
okay to just put a whole lot of words
you want to rank for in url you need to
remember that humans are the people are
the things that use the internet they
share URLs they try to say them over the
phone they do all these different things
where it becomes extremely important to
keep these short and succinct so that
people can easily share them and can
type them in their browser with without
any issues
now that we've talked about the
importance of URLs let's talk about URL
structure let's dive in a little bit
here we'll start with domain name so
You' probably heard of this concept
before in the example with the URL I
have here example.com would be the
domain name so this is the first thing
that people see with your online
business this is what's going to be in
all your advertisements it's going to be
in all your marketing norts it's this
name right here I like to think of it in
terms of an offline world so if you're
walking around buildings typically look
like something so a barber shop almost
always looks like a barber shop a fast
food restaurant almost always looks like
a fast food restaurant that same idea is
going to apply to domain names if you
have a very spammy looking domain name
or one that's hard to spell or one
that's confusing people are going to
make an initial impression off of that
so make sure that you have something
there that's going to make a great first
impression be something that's easy to
spell that one especially in this new
tech uh like Tech craziness that we live
in people do a terrible job of that but
something that's easy to spell and
something that's easy to pronounce and
easy to
share so how is this important to SEO
well keywords is are why it's important
to SEO this comes up all the time it's
important to have keywords in your
domain name as long as you're not taking
it too far now this is one of the things
I go back and forth with people all the
time how do you know if you've gone too
far uh I don't know I mean if it looks
like you bought the domain name simply
because it has the keywords in it that
you needed then you've probably gone too
far but is that the best way of
measuring it can I take out my
calculator and and actually calculate
that no you're just going to have to use
your gut you're going to have to look at
it from a human from a human perspective
so do not go overboard keep it as short
as possible make sure it's something
that you can easily share something
you're going be able to put on your
business cards and be proud of not
something that you bought because you're
doing it purely for SEO reasons and you
think you're going to succeed okay so
that is the domain name now what about
everything after that so in this case it
would be this blog post that I wrote
well that is called subdirectories and
you can actually have um in theory
unlimited
subdirectories but from an SEO
perspective you do not want to do that
and it's for all the reasons we've
talked about before if you have lots of
subdirectories it's going to be
confusing it's going to be hard to share
uh it's going to cause lots of problems
in older browsers so your best practice
here is to keep as few subdirectories as
possible this will be good for both
robots and for human beings with the
subdirectories as well as the files that
come after them you want to make sure
you include your keyword so again this
is one of those weird things where
there's not a Quantified metric for it
but don't put the keywords in there too
many times but put them in there just as
as many times as you think is absolutely
necessary so generally it says once or
maybe twice if it's already in the
domain name okay that's all the
information I have right now on URLs
feel free to uh Google this subject if
you if you want to know more about it
because trust me there's a whole lot of
technical knowledge that goes into this
but if you're at this point you already
understand all the most important parts
of it as you likely realize computers
cannot see images the same way that
humans can uh they do not have eyes and
they do not have the complex brains that
we use to get meaning out of pictures
out of pixels so because of that we've
had to come up with some other way of
expressing the meaning behind images
luckily the creators of the internet
were Forward Thinking and they provided
us with a factor called image alt text
alt text is the alternative text that is
shown when the image can't load this is
done on purpose so that people who are
blind are able to extract meaning from
something when they can't see it this
worked out really well for search
engines because well they're effectively
effectively blind and so that they can
also use that information put into the
image alt text to understand the meaning
behind
images internal links so we have an
entire section on links but what I want
to cover at this point is just internal
links an internal link is a link that
points from your website back to a
different section of your own website is
not pointing elsewhere and it's not
coming from elsewhere it's from your
website back to your own website this is
important from a relevance a relevancy
perspective you'll see internal links in
your main navigation when you'll have
one that likely says home one that might
say contact us or one that says about
what you're showing to search engines
and to humans is that this section that
if you click on this link will be about
our company or this will be a place
where you can find contact information
for us these links are not votes like
external links but they are relevancy
metrics that are extremely helpful
when a search engine crawls and
processes your website it doesn't simply
look for the instances of keywords it's
a lot more complex than that it's using
a technology called NLP natural language
processing what is trying to do is it's
using algorithms to try to understand
the meaning of text the same way humans
do when they listen to other people talk
or read read text instead of just
looking for specific phrases or like the
order of words it tries to extract
what's behind that what is what is
trying to be expressed here emotion
feeling food anything so when a search
engine goes to your website it may seek
keywords but it was looking for context
to that you may say just soccer but just
having the word soccer on your website
isn't going to help you rank
specifically for soccer what you need to
do and what is more common and actually
happens naturally is that you'll happen
to use words like goal in World Cup and
referee Google and the other search
engines are going to take these into
account and understand what that you
rank for soccer or the relevant for that
kind of keyword by the usage of other
synonyms and other common words that are
used within the context of a bigger
broader idea the next on-site signal
that we have is sitemaps now there's two
kinds of site Maps there's the kind that
are for humans and there's the kinds
that are for robots or crawlers or
spiders the ones that are for humans are
called HTML sitemaps and you've probably
seen these before they're generally in
the footer of a website click through it
and it shows you the major sections of a
website and usually provides some search
functionality those help you understand
as a human what the hierarchy of a
website is how does everything fit
together and how do I get to the to
something I'm looking for as quickly as
possible those are called HTML sit maps
and like I said they're generally for
humans there's also something that
exists on the back end called an XML
sitemap now this is something you can
actually look at but it's formatted for
computers so it's not going to be easy
to read an XML sit map uses a format
called XML as you can probably imagine
to show the hierarchy and the priority
of each of the URLs on your website uh
so that search engines can understand
that and figure out how everything is
interconnected so at this point we've
covered a lot of things that are
important and things that you should be
doing and optimizing now let's go the
different direction and cover the things
that you should not be doing so these
are the list of the most common mistakes
that I see uh that should not be done
for a well optimized page the first one
is keyword stuffing so back in the day
it used to be helpful and again this is
in the past it's not true anymore it
used to be helpful to put lots of
instances of the keyword that you were
trying to rank for on the page search
engines and humans for that matter are a
lot smarter about this now than they
used to be keyword stuffing does not
work you're not going to rank better for
uh any given phrase by including 100 P
100 times on the page so this is
something that doesn't work you should
not do it anymore next one is hidden
text unfortunately I still see this one
all over the web this is when you write
content that is solely for search engine
it's not for people uh and you'll put it
say white text and a white background so
a search engine can see this because
they're a crawler they're a machine uh
but humans cannot because they cannot
see the difference because there's no
contrast now that also used to work back
in the day but it does not and that is
not a useful thing to invest your time
in today uh search Eng can tell when
it's white text on a white background
that's actually very easy to tell from a
from a computer science point of view
it's uh there's other ways of trying to
hide things but when you hide text
modern search engines are most certainly
smart enough to be able to figure that
out probably better than humans to be to
be honest so don't bother trying to hide
text just for search AG they're going to
figure it out and it's going to work
against
you next one is repetitive anchor text
so we've all read these articles where
you get to a page and it just doesn't
feel like it was for people you're
reading a sentence and it's redundant
it's got lots of links in it that really
don't need to be links it's it confuses
the way the flow of of the information
on the page because you put links when
they're really they're not necessary
this also used to be a tactic that used
to work but is no longer helpful search
engines the uh natural language
processing algorithms they used have
advanced significantly so they can tell
when something is not readable when
something is probably intended for
machines and not for people so do not
waste your time on redundant links and
trying to trying to sculpt your page
rank or your your link Equity or the
value of your links anyway like that
because just today's world it does not
work the last thing that we have on here
is cloaking cloaking is the idea of
showing one thing to search engines and
something entirely different to humans
now this is also like everything else on
something that used to work but as I've
mentioned before search engines have
their algorithms have gotten much
smarter and much more clever and they
can almost always figure out the
difference between when you're doing
this if you're showing one thing to
search enges and something else to
humans with a with only a few exceptions
that know of which are in the process of
going out there's no reason to do this
so it is not something worth investing
your time
in now we've covered all the most
important onpage optimization factors
let's take a look at what the
theoretical perfectly optimized page
would look like on the internet now
there's a big asteris here in that well
no page would be perfectly optimized
because the internet's Dynamic and fluid
and things change all the time but if
there was one it would look very e
eerily similar to what we're about to
talk about let's start with the basics
you need to have a title tag the title
tag needs to have optimized keywords in
it preferably closer to the beginning of
it and it needs to be clear and enticing
for users to click remember this is what
we're going to actually see in search
results for most of the time for your
search for for the search result itself
is you're going to have this text here
so a clear and optimized TI tag the next
thing is an enticing metad description
now remember meta descriptions are not
used for ranking purposes but they are
tremendously important for
click-throughs uh so this is the this is
your chance to write copy that's going
to entice people to click through your
result rather than the other ones that
are going to be on the search result
page after that we have a short
optimized URL so the important here
thing here is that it needs to be short
so it's easily sharable so it's easy to
understand from a search engine
perspective but it also needs to contain
the keywords that you're trying to rank
for uh so keep it there keep it in plain
English use the phrases people are
actually using to get to your site uh
but keep it as concise as evenly
possible now let's talk about the page
itself uh what does this actually look
like how are things structured well the
first thing you want to do is you're
going to want to make sure that it is
structured in the same way that people
expect to see websites meaning there is
a title at the Top If it's appropriate
there's some kind of navigational
elements around the site uh there are
pictures to make this um worthy of me to
spend the 5 minutes of my internet time
uh grazing looking at your content and
you need to have text that is well
written and this all is very hard to
quantify but it's things that you're
going need to just take a look at and
and work with your team for things that
are interesting there's an attitude with
the page that has some kind of opinion
it's expressing information it's giving
me the anwers to whatever question I may
have I need to make sure this content at
the end of the day is written for humans
that's something that I would share with
my best friend because I think this is
the single best source on the Internet
for whatever my information need is at
that
moment after that it needs to be bot
accessible so I actually see this
problem all the time uh with some of the
major news Publications the world
they'll have a really outstanding
article or they'll have a really
beautiful uh photo gallery but they've
done it in a way where the search
engines can't see it which means that on
the Internet it's almost useless which
is which is a shame it's sad when this
happens what you need to do is you need
to make sure that you have the world's
best content which is hard enough but
you also have to make it accessible to
search engin so this is certainly very
doable just avoid Technologies like
flash and say silver light and use more
of these Open Standards like HTML 5
that'll get you all the way there the
next one is social it needs to be social
it needs to be sharable so I had
mentioned the my um when I'm trying to
create content that the bar that I tried
to rise to is that is sharable for my
best friend well you need to facilitate
that sharing you need to have some kind
of way for them to actually share it so
this could be a simple as adding uh the
social sharing buttons or could be
something as easy as enticing them and
giving them a call to action at the end
of the article to share it with their
friends or share it with people who are
important to them uh sharing on the
Internet is extremely important not just
for ethical reasons but for marketing
reasons for bottom line reasons uh so
make sure that you're facilitating that
the last one and is certainly not the
least important one uh is Multi-Device
ready so I don't care if you use
adaptive design I don't care if you use
responsive design just make sure that
this content that you've spent so much
time crafting is going to work and is
going to be consumable easily on my
tablet and on my phone and on my
gigantic TV and all these other devices
so that when it comes time when you
finally earned that person coming to
your website to consume your really
wonderful content that they're able to
see it on whatever device it may be
holding so this is a general overview of
what a perfectly optimized website would
look like now remember this this is
going to shift depending on context but
make sure if you cover to cover all
these bases so that the signals that
we've all talked about make sense and
you have a real lasting impact with
this the two broad categories of ranking
signals are popularity and
relevancy of the onpage factors title
tags are the most important individual
field header tags are important but less
so than they were in the past URL is
important and should be semantic alt
text is important for search engine as
well as for blind humans avoid keyword
stuffing and Link
sculpting you should always avoid
keyword stuffing hidden text repetitive
anchor text and
cloaking natural language processing is
a technology that aims to understand the
intent and semantic structure behind
text written by humans keywords are the
ideas or topics that clearly describe
what your content is about
say for example here the title of the
slide is what is keyword
research so this is the keyword which
suggests that this slide contains the
content about keyword
research so basically keyword research
is a process of identifying keywords or
popular Search terms that people tends
to search for when you identify relevant
keywords all you need to do is include
these keywords smartly into your content
and this will help your content to get
higher rankings and search results now
the question arises why does keyword
research has so much of importance in
search engine
optimization let's understand this
keyword research plays a major role in
driving traffic organically to you your
website or your content but how does
this exactly happens when you select the
most appropriate keyword for your
content there is an
opportunity where you can rank high in
search results by ranking higher there
are more chances that audience can
discover your content and reach to your
website thus you get more and more
consistent traffic growth for your
website thereby indirectly promoting
your products and
services now that you are aware of how
keyword research holds
importance let's now see some essential
types of keywords that is longtail
keywords and short tail keywords so
first we will start with longtail
keywords longtail keywords are the
keywords that are mostly used to get
more specific results longtail keywords
include keywords with three or more
words for example shoes for a black
dress now coming to short tail keywords
short tail keywords are the general
keywords or most specifically General
Search terms short tail keywords include
one or two words in the keyword for
example
shoes now let's see the difference
between both the long tail and short
tail keywords by demonstrating let's go
to
google.com so now we are here to check
the difference between long tail
keywords and short tail keywords so
first we will check for the short tail
keyword now suppose I am looking for the
shoes that should go perfectly with my
beautiful black dress so here I add
shoes
and see how the results are appearing
okay if you see the recommendations here
we get shoes for men shoes for women
shoes images shoes size chart shoes for
rainy season etc
etc and if I enter here on the shoes
what are the results here I get number
of results from the shopping
websites uh with the very number of
shoes with number of Brands and
somewhere locations of the
shops but none of the result is
relevant to what I am expecting that is
the shoes for my black dress okay so
now I'll just
change my search query I'll add a long
tail keyword here
and I will search here more specifically
for what I
wanted so here I'll add shoes
for
black dress
okay so here I am getting number of
ideas the image ideas in the search
result that what kind of shoes are going
to go best with my black dress and here
I'm getting several combinations which I
can wear with my black dress so 12 best
color shoes here again I'm getting If
You observe clearly then all these
results are completely aligned to what
exactly I am looking for
okay and if I again change this
query more specific like shoes for black
dress for
woman let's see what I get so here I'm
getting more specific
results in terms of
women's we will definitely understand
how to use longtail keywords or short
tail keywords during our research in the
upcoming part of this video Let's now
have a look on tools required for
carrying out keyword
research here I have got a small list of
tools that you will need to perform
effective keyword research so first we
will begin with Keyword
Planner Keyword Planner is a free
keyword research tool provided by Google
some of the important features of
Keyword Planner includes discovery of
new keywords estimate monthly searches
for a keyword
get the average cost of ads for the
keyword you're looking for and help to
organize keywords the next tool that we
have in our bucket is sem Rush some
important features ofm Rush
includes helps to get competitor
keywords data it helps to get competitor
backlinks data finds competitors top
performing content helps in getting
competitors campaign data Etc let me
bring it to your notice that sem Rush is
one of the best platforms that fulfill
all your SEO needs so do visit to
semrush.com you can find the link in the
description box below next tool that we
have in our bucket is RS the free
keyword generator tool by RS helps to
discovered keyword ideas helps in
identifying the search volume estimation
s identify easy keywords for which you
can possibly rank for helps you to get a
list of longtail
keywords and however it is not limited
to Google searches only Yes you heard it
right you can get keyword ideas for
Google Bing
YouTube Yahoo Etc now let's check
another tool which is Google
Trends Google Trend will come into
action during your keyword research when
you're looking for the top search
queries by users that is the most
trending query moreover you can check
these details of search queries for your
country for any other country or even
worldwide not only this but you can also
choose the type of search for this query
like web search email search YouTube
search
Etc the next tool that we have is answer
the public tool answer the public tool
has free as well as paid
versions this tool can prove a magic
wand for your business as it suggests
the questions that are asked by people
in your industry this can help you to
understand and create strategies for the
content that the users are searching
across the internet and the last tool in
our today's list is keywordtool.io
let's get started with keyword research
so basically what we want to do is
Center our keywords just like our
website we want to Center our keywords
around or our content around good
keywords so the videos on YouTube are no
different than the web pages on our
website so if we have somebody who
states YouTube is the world's second
most well well-known engine well it is
because it's right behind Google it's
not a search engine per se it's a video
platform but if it was a search engine
it probably be second right behind
Google so YouTube is pretty popular
majority people use YouTube search every
day to watch videos on a number of
different topics so they can find these
videos in Google but because YouTube's
so powerful and so popular people go
directly right into YouTube for their
searches and so the whole idea behind
YouTube being the second most well-known
search engine is centered around
keywords so if you have the right
keywords for your video then the chances
of you ranking higher increases on
YouTube so we're going to share with you
a few easy ways to do keyword research
this is the most important step in
getting your videos to rank on YouTube
just like for those of you who watched
any of the SEO videos we produced at at
simply learn you know that keyword
research is so essential to getting your
web pages to rank on Google so first
thing is search suggest so YouTube has a
feature called autocomplete so if you've
done any searches on Google it's very
similar if you're typing something into
YouTube search then YouTube is going to
suggest other related popular keywords
so let's take a look at that if we go
back to YouTube for a second and I just
type in machine learning YouTube is
going going to populate on the
autocomplete in the search bar some
other popular keywords that we can
potentially use or in this case if I
Choose You Know machine learning
tutorial I'm going to see a video about
machine learning tutorial so here you
can see simply learns rank number one
for machine learning tutorial but there
are other videos that show up in my
search result so we want to be able to
use the search suggestion box in the
search box field so when we're typing in
something you know YouTube just like on
Google is going to give us those
suggestions so if we're focusing uh a
video on machine learning then you know
we have some ideas of some other key
wordss that we could center around
because these are our popular key wordss
these are key wordss that people are
using to search on YouTube so that's one
suggestion looking at competitors is
another suggestion so we could search
for keywords used by our competitors in
their video title and description so let
me talk a little bit about that what you
want to do is is you want to go to that
particular channel of your competitor so
when you go to your particular
competitor's YouTube channel you want to
be able to click on the videos tab when
you click on the videos tab then you're
going to sort by most popular and then
what you could do is see a list of
videos and then when you look at a list
of videos you're going to choose a video
and then what you're going to do then is
take a look at the keywords used in the
title in description and then once you
do that you're going to have a list of
keywords that you can use yourself for
that video so for example let's go back
to YouTube so if I go to type in simply
learn here's her Channel page just by
clicking on simply learn I click on
videos ever wonder if there's so now I
can see all the videos ever wonder if
there's an easier way go back so here I
can see all the videos sort by most
popular once they do that then I can
choose a video this is the most popular
video right now for simply learn if I
click on that video it's automatically
going to start playing but what I could
do is simply just look at you know the
content description so just by clicking
show more I can see all the content that
align with this video that's one way to
do it is simply by looking at your
competitors now what you could also do
is look at the tags associated with the
particular video and so what you want to
do is you want to look at the HTML and
so that means looking at the page source
so just like web pages what YouTube does
is they look at metatags so if you're
call from SEO in order to get your pages
to rank you need to have a title tag and
a metatag description so videos are no
different what we're doing uh for
YouTube is aligning certain key words
with the video so if you take a look and
do a search for keywords by viewing the
page Source you're going to see all the
keywords
associated with a particular video so
for example if I go back to YouTube
YouTube and I look at the page source of
a video Let's just say this video here
Facebook's ad tutorial I'm going to pull
up the page source and all I need to do
isrl F and type in keywords and now for
that Facebook video I can see all the
keywords associated with the video so
you can see there's a lot of different
keywords we're aligning with this video
and so why do we want to do that because
we want you know our video to show up
for keywords that people may type in and
so if you use that YouTube autocomplete
it's going to give you those ideas there
most popular keywords so if they're
related align those keywords with the
video so here you can see Facebook
marketing Facebook ad strategy Facebook
ads for beginners so forth and so on so
there's a lot of keywords we've aligned
here with that particular video and
again all you need to do is look at the
page source so right clicking view page
Source do a control F for keywords and
you'll be able to see the keywords
aligned so you can you could do that for
your competitor's videos as well so you
could see what keywords your competitor
is using for a video that's most popular
for their Channel and is also ranking on
YouTube and on Google so using the
autocomplete gives you those keyword
ideas looking at your competitor's
videos also gives you some other ideas
for keywords that you can align with a
video that's relevant that you want to
rank for so let's look at uh some other
ideas here so you can install plugins
and there are plenty of plugins
available on the Chrome browser that
will help you see the video tags
associated with a particular video so a
couple of examples are vid IQ and
tubebuddy those are extensions that work
in Chrome and what they do is they give
you the exact tags that a particular
video is using so for example if I go
back here and I look at a video on
YouTube let's just say the machine
learning Basics video I have vid IQ
installed on my Chrome browser so just
by clicking on that vid IQ is going to
give me a lot of information about that
video they're just going to give me an
overview of their particular metrics
they're going to give me some other
information associated with Facebook
some engagement metrics really what I'm
interested in is those keywords so if I
scroll down a bit here I can see the
video tags associated with the machine
learning Basics video so vid IQ is
telling me is these keywords are
associated with this video and not only
does it show me what keywords are
associated I can also see where they
rank so for machine learning Basics this
particular video ranks number one if I
go down I can see what is machine
learning and how does it work I can see
it's rank number two here I can see
machine learning algorithms it's rank
number nine so I can get some ideas of
the types of keywords that are being
used as tags for that video further down
I can also see some Channel tags but
really this is the video tags or the
idea place I want to be able to look to
get an idea of the types of keywords
that are associated with the video that
are also ranking or not ranking so
that's another way for you to really get
an understanding of what key words to
use at the particular video so
autocomplete you can look at the page
source of a competitor's video or you
can use a Chrome extension in this case
I'm using vid IQ to give me some
information about the video tags for
particular video so according to an
industry study using keyword and video
tags will help you rank well on YouTube
so you have to use keywords and video
tags if you want your video to rank
there's been a lot of studies YouTube is
so popular and videos are so prominent
in today's world where if you have
videos and you're going to upload them
to YouTube then associate the right
keywords with those videos so some
important factors when we look at
keywords what we want to do is look at
search volume we want to look at
competition we want to look at relevancy
we want to look at the primary and
secondary keywords that we want to use
so well chosen keywords will help you
rank so we just gave you some ideas on
how to do some keyword research again
those ideas were really to use the
autocomplete on YouTube or Google
they're going to give you some popular
keywords you can look what your
competitors are doing by looking at the
page source and just looking at the
keywords that are aligned with that
video or you can use a third- party
extension in Chrome in my example I use
vid IQ that gave me the keywords
associated with that video so you have
ways to get the keywords so what we want
to do is we want to make sure we choose
keywords with high search volume they're
going to drive more traffic to your
video however we want to balance it out
with keywords that have low difficulty
and or easier to rank for so you don't
want to choose something very broad
that's just going to be very difficult
to rank for and of course we always want
to go with relevancy so if we're talking
about machine learning Basics then we
want to choose keywords associated with
that and that's where that auto complete
comes in handy because what Google's
going to do and YouTube's going to do is
give us keywords that are very closely
related to the video that we're trying
to optimize for and so we have a number
of different keywords at our disposal
that are relevant that we can look to
see if they have good volume and low
competition and so the whole idea is we
want to choose a keyword that defines
the nature of the content and then what
we want to do is support that with
secondary keywords so we want keywords
that are highly relevant to the primary
keyword so that's the way to go about
aligning your keywords you want keywords
that are high volume low competition are
relevant and you want to choose that one
keyword that is really what the
content's about and then those secondary
keywords that support the primary so if
you have a machine learning video you
can choose your primary keyword as in
this case the machine learning Basics
video so well chosen keywords help you
rank well on YouTube just like the
machine learning Basics so if I go back
to our video our machine learning Basics
video if I just type in machine learning
Basics I'll be able to pull it up and so
here it is if I click on it I'm going to
go to YouTube and so here I can see this
keyword we know humans learn from their
is well aligned because it's in the
title it's in the copy and it's aligned
as a keyword tagged with the video so we
know that that keyword has good volume
low competition is relevant because
that's what the video is about the
basics of machine learning it's an
introduction to machine learning so
instead of honing in on just
introduction to machine learning primary
keyword is machine learning Basics and
then we supported that video with those
secondary keywords what is machine
learning because somebody who doesn't
know what machine learning is probably
going to type in that keyword and then
introduction to machine learning is a
good secondary keyword because it's
explaining the basics of what machine
learning is all about so primary keyword
machine learning basic secondary
keywords what is machine learning and
introduction to machine learning so
that's the whole idea behind choosing
keywords you want that keyword that
really is going to define the content
and then support that with those
secondary keywords so remember when
you're performing your keyword research
choose keywords for your videos that
Google shows on the video results page
so what I mean by that is your video can
get more views if you rank on Google as
well so the whole idea is not
necessarily to be found on YouTube it's
also to be found on Google so if I go
back to Google and I just type in data
science for beginners and I type in
videos then you could see we're ranked
number one so even if you're not looking
at the videos clicking on the videos
link on Google search you can always
just when you do a search what Google's
going to do is also put in the videos
here on part as part of the search
results so what they're going to show
you is the top videos that are ranking
for that particular keyword and so we
may not rank overall for data science
for beginners but we're ranked number
one in the videos category and so
somebody's looking for a video that's
important and you can see here that
these first two are ads so what Google
is doing is they're saying heyy this is
so relevant this particular video for
the keyword query data science for
beginners that we're going to show it
above the organic listings even though
it's a video so the whole idea is to be
found on YouTube and Google because
you're increasing your visibility you're
increasing your chances of getting found
on both search platforms so according to
back Linko Google Ranks videos with
keywords like how to tutorials so you
know a lot of the videos that you find
on YouTube are going to be instructional
based and so what Google's doing is
they're saying hey if somebody types in
how to or tutorial or an introduction to
anything that's going to signal to
Google that it's instructional it's
going to help you rank so when you
search for machine learning tutorial or
how to become a machine learning
engineer you're going to get results
related to that because if you look at
these examples we have machine learning
tutorial in our title or how to become a
machine learning engineer so keep that
in mind if you're creating a video and
it's educational in nature you know use
those key terms like how to and
tutorials in the video title because
that will help you rank so let's move
over now to video title so we want to
use our Target keyword in the title of
the video and again we want to make sure
if it's educational to include that
keyword tutorial or how to so for every
video title YouTube has a limit of 100
characters so we really have to pick and
choose really wisely so if we look at
the video that we were focusing on a
couple of minutes ago so machine
learning Basics here we could see under
100 characters we have machine learning
Basics what is machine learning
introduction to machine learning and
then the brand name so that is the title
of this particular video so it takes
into count the primary keyword the
secondary keywords and the title and it
also includes that really that key term
that really Google and YouTube like and
that's what is machine learning so it's
helping us Rank by having our keywords
in the title with that key phrase what
is okay so that's a a good tidbit on
creating a good video title is to align
it with the right key wordss your
primary and your secondary and so we
want to use those catchy words and
numbers to gain High click through RS
just like you would on the title tag of
your web page we want to do the same
with our video title because the video
titles what's going to show up in search
so if I go back to you know search here
we could see you know data science
tutorial data science for beginners so
we want to make sure in this case you
can see data science in 5 minutes so
that was purposely done so that hey I
don't have time to watch a video I only
have a couple minutes data science and 5
minutes okay great I'm going to click on
the video and now I have an opportunity
to watch something and learn something
under 5 minutes so choosing the right
words in your video title is going to
help you get that clickthrough rate up
remember clickthrough rate is clicks
divided by Impressions and an impression
is how many times your video shows up in
the search results on YouTube or Google
so we want to keep our click the rate
high and in order to do that we want to
be able to write some really good title
tags for our video so use catchy words
like a number or how to or what is cuz
that's going to resonate with people
when they're searching now for the
description what we want to do is we
want to use the target word at the
beginning of the description the title
and the tags itself so if I go back to
my video here machine learning Basics we
know it's in the video title and right
off the bat if I look at the description
of the video here I can see this machine
learning Basics video will help you
understand what is machine learning so
our primary keyword is in the first
sentence right in the introductory of
the description and so that's going to
bode well for optimizing our video the
description length is 5,000 characters
so we have a lot of characters to work
with so if I go back to my video I click
show more we have a lot of characters to
really describe what the video is about
okay there's no shortage no shortage of
including key keywords into the content
so you have 5,000 characters go ahead
and see if you can work in naturally
your keywords but one of the key tips
here is just make sure that first
sentence starts out with that keyword
that's a good tip of course you always
want to make it sound natural as
possible you don't want to stuff it with
keywords at the same time work them in
naturally work in your keywords
naturally and then include hashtags in
your description to help the audience
find your video is easily so if I go
back here you know we want to be able to
include hashtags so hashtags it's like
anything else you would use on social
media it just signals to the end user
hey this is what the video is all about
and if I go ahead and type in that
keyword then it's our video has a better
chance cuz it's aligned with that
hashtag and then there's Target keywords
and LSI keywords latent semantic
indexing keywords we want to be able to
use those keywords as Target keywords
with our video so if you recall the
example I gave a few minutes ago we used
the Facebook ads tutorial as our example
here I can see all the target keywords
associated with that particular video so
don't be afraid to use those LSI related
keywords meaning keywords that are
related to the content use them as
Target keywords with the video so
between your LSI keywords Target
keywords and then using our primary
secondary keyword in the title tag using
our primary and secondary keyword in the
description and then using hashtags in
the description the combination of all
of that if we chose the right keyword
then we should find that our video will
eventually rank on YouTube so just doing
these small tidbits with our keywords
really help get our video to rank so at
the end of the day we want to be able to
use the tools available to us YouTube
Itself by looking at our competitors
those extensions like vid IQ the auto
complete to really find our good
keywords and then incorporating those
keywords into you know the title tag the
description as Target keywords hashtags
we should really be off and running with
our video on YouTube so if you are
looking to grab a successful career in
digital marketing and learn search Eng
and optimization simply learn has got
you covered with a wide range of topn
digital marketing courses these courses
make you skilled in SEO content
marketing PPC social media marketing and
much more with hands-on experience in
the tools like Google analytics Keyword
Planner Sim rush and there's a huge list
on the board however one year of
experien is preferred to enroll in these
courses find the course Link in the
description box so at simply learn if I
go to YouTube and I just type in machine
learning you could see we're right here
is the first organic video on YouTube
for machine learning if I jump over to
Google and I type in machine learning
Basics you can see where number we're
number one for machine learning Basics
under videos if I click on all we're
also ranked here as well under the video
section on organic search results
another example data science for
beginners we ranked number one for that
if I look at another keyword data
science interview questions okay we'll
rank number two for that so we're
ranking for a lot of video and why are
we ranking for a lot of different
content and videos on Google Search and
on YouTube well we put a lot of work in
behind the scenes of creating the video
and that's what we want to show you so
part of that has a lot to do with you
know how our audience engages and sees
our video so for example we're looking
at the machine learning Basics video
here and we could see that it has over
221,000 subscribers for this video
234,000 views we've had over 2,000
people like the video and we have had
over 270 plus comment on the video so
when we get our videos to rank then we
can see there's a lot of Engagement and
so that's the whole idea is when you do
a video and you want to show up on
YouTube you want people to enjoy it you
want people to share it you want people
to like it you want people to comment on
it and that's part of the whole
ecosystem of YouTube It's you know we're
going to show you behind the scenes of
what it takes to get your videos to rank
and then we're show you some of the
metrics involved with some of these
videos to help you stay ranking so
without further Ado let's go into how to
get your videos to rank on YouTube so
we're going to talk about keyword
research for YouTube we're going to talk
about some ways to create high quality
videos to the importance of user
engagement just as I showed you with the
machine learning Basics video all the
shares all the commenting all the views
and subscriptions then we're going to
get into how to promote your cont
content and then we're going to just
review a little checklist for you and
sum it all up so let's get started with
keyword research so basically what we
want to do is Center our keywords just
like our website we want to Center our
keywords around or our content around
good keywords so the videos on YouTube
are no different than the web pages on
our website so if we have somebody who
states YouTube is the world's second
most well well-known engine well it is
because it's right behind Google it's
not a search engine per se it's a video
platform but if it was a search engine
it'd probably be second right behind
Google so YouTube is pretty popular
majority people use YouTube search every
day to watch videos on a number
different topics so they can find these
videos in Google but because YouTube's
so powerful and so popular people go
directly right into YouTube for their
searches and so the whole idea behind
YouTube being the second most well-known
search engine is centered around
keywords so if you have the right
keywords for your video then the chances
of you ranking higher increases on
YouTube so we're going to share with you
a few easy ways to do keyword research
this is the most important step in
getting your videos to rank on YouTube
just like for those of you who watched
any of the SEO videos we produced at at
simply learn you know that keyword
research is so essential to to getting
your web pages to rank on Google well
it's no different keyword research and
choosing the right keywords is just as
important for your videos as is for your
web pages so we're going to go into a
few things to do here to find the right
keywords so we have the search
suggestion you can look at your
competitors we have different tools we
can use some other factors involved in
Google itself so let's start talking
about some of these ways to really hone
in and do some good research on your
keywords to align them with your videos
so first thing is search suggest so
YouTube has a feature called
autocomplete so if you've done any
searches on Google it's very similar if
you're typing something into YouTube
search then YouTube is going to suggest
other related popular keywords so let's
take a look at that if we go back to
YouTube for a second and I just type in
machine learning YouTube is going to
populate on the autocomplete in the
search bar some other popular keywords
that we can potentially use or in this
case if I Choose You Know machine
learning tutorial I'm going to see a
video about machine learning tutorial so
here you can see simply learns rank
number one for machine learning tutorial
but there are other videos that show up
in my search result so we want to be
able to use the search suggestion box in
the search box field so when we're
typing in something you know YouTube
just like on Google is going to give us
those suggestions so if we're focusing
uh a video on machine learning then you
know we have some ideas of some other
key words that we could center around
because these are our popular keywords
these are key wordss that people are
using to search on YouTube so that's one
suggestion looking at competitors is
another suggestion so we could search
for keyw used by our competitors in
their video title and description so let
me talk a little bit about that what you
want to do is you want to go to that
particular channel of your competitor so
when you go to your particular
competitor's YouTube channel you want to
be able to click on the videos tab when
you click on the videos tab then you're
going to sort by most popular and then
what you could do is see a list of
videos and then when you look at a list
of videos you're going to choose a video
and then what you're going to do then is
take a look at the keywords used in the
title and description and then once you
do that you're going to have a list of
keywords that you can use yourself for
that video so for example let's go back
to YouTube so if I go to type in simply
learn here's their Channel page just by
clicking on simply learn I click on
videos ever wonder if there's so now I
can see all the videos ever wonder if
there's an easier way go back so here I
can see all the videos sort by most
popular once they do that then I can
choose a video this is the most popular
video right now for simply learn if I
click on that video it's automatically
going to start playing but what I could
do is simply just look at you know the
content description so just by clicking
show more I can see all the content that
align with this video that's one way to
do it is simply by looking at your
competitors now what you could also do
is look at the tags associated with the
particular video and so what you want to
do is you want to look at the HTML and
so that means looking at the page source
so just like web pages what YouTube does
is they look at metatags so if you're
call from SEO in order to get your pages
to rank you need to have a title tag and
a metatag description so videos are no
different what we're doing uh for
YouTube is aligning certain keywords
with the video so if you take a look and
do a search for keywords by viewing the
page Source you're going to see all the
keywords associated with a particular
video so for example if I go back to
YouTube and I look at the page source of
a video Let's just say this video here
Facebook's ad tutorial I'm going to pull
up the page source and all I need to do
is control F and type in keywords and
now for that Facebook video I can see
all the keywords associated with the
video so you can see there's a lot of
different keywords we're aligning with
this video and so why do we want to do
that because we want you know our video
to show up for keywords that people may
type in and so if you use that YouTube
autocomplete it's it's going to give you
those ideas there most popular keywords
so if they're related align those
keywords with the video so here you can
see Facebook marketing Facebook ad
strategy Facebook ads for beginners so
forth and so on so there's a lot of key
words we've aligned here with that
particular video and again all you need
to do is look at the page source so
right clicking view page Source do a
contr f for keywords and you'll be able
to see the keywords aligned so you could
do that for your competitors videos as
well so you could see what keywords your
competitor is using for a video that's
most popular for their Channel and is
also ranking on YouTube and on Google so
using the autocomplete gives you those
keyword ideas looking at your
competitors videos also gives you some
other ideas for keywords that you can
align with a video that's relevant that
you want to rank for so let's look at uh
some other ideas here so you can install
plugins and there are plenty of plugins
available on the Chrome browser that
will help you see the video tags
associated with a particular video so a
couple of examples are vid IQ and
tubebuddy those are extensions that work
in Chrome and what they do is they give
you the exact tags that a particular
video is using so for example if I go
back here and I look at a video on
YouTube let's just say the machine
learning Basics video I have vid IQ
installed on my Chrome browser so just
by clicking on that vid IQ is going to
give me a lot of information about that
video they're just going to give me an
overview of their particular metrics
they're going to give me some other
information associated with Facebook
some engagement metrics really what I'm
interested in is those keywords so if I
scroll down a bit here I can see the
video tags associated with the machine
learning Basics video so vid IQ is
telling me is these keywords are
associated with this video and not only
does it show me what keywords are
associated I can also see where they
rank so for machine learning Basics this
particular video ranks number one if I
go down I can see what is machine
learning and how does it work I can see
it's rank number two here I could see
machine learning algorithms it's rank
number nine so I can get some ideas of
the types of keywords that are being
used as tags for that video further down
I can also see some Channel tags but
really this is the video tags or the
idea place I want to be able to look to
get an idea of the types of keywords
that are associated with the video that
are also ranking or not ranking so
that's another way for you to really get
an understanding of what key words to
use at the particular video so
autocomplete you can look at the page
source of a competitor's video or you
can use a Chrome extension in this case
I'm using vid IQ to give me some
information about the video tags for
particular video so according to an
industry study using keywords and video
tags will help you rank well on YouTube
so you have to use keywords and video
tags if you want your video to rank
there's been a lot of studies YouTube is
so popular and videos are so prominent
in today's world where if you have
videos and you're going to upload them
to YouTube then associate the right
keywords with those videos so some
important factors when we look at
keywords what we want to do is look at
search volume we want to look at
competition we want to look at relevancy
we want to look at the primary and
secondary keywords that we want to use
so well chosen keywords will help you
rank so we just gave you some ideas on
how to do some keyword research again
those ideas were really to use the
autocomplete on YouTube or Google
they're going to give you some popular
keywords you can look what your
competitors are doing by looking at the
page source source and just looking at
the keywords that are aligned with that
video or you can use a third party
extension in Chrome in my example I use
vid IQ that gave me the keywords
associated with that video so you have
ways to get the keywords so what we want
to do is we want to make sure we choose
keywords with high search volume they're
going to drive more traffic to your
video however we want to balance it out
with keywords that have low difficulty
and are easier to rank for so you don't
want to choose something very broad
that's just going to be very difficult
to rank for and of course we always want
to go with relevancy so for talking
about machine learning Basics then we
want to choose keywords associated with
that and that's where that autocomplete
comes in handy because what Google's
going to do and YouTube's going to do is
give us keywords that are very closely
related to the video that we're trying
to optimize for and so we have a number
of different keywords at our disposal
that are relevant that we can look to
see if they have good volume and low
competition and so the whole idea is we
want to choose a keyword that defines
the nature of the content and then what
we want to do is support that with
secondary keywords so we want keywords
that are highly relevant to the primary
keyword so that's the way to go about
aligning your keywords you want keywords
that are high volume low competition or
relevant and you want to choose that one
keyword that is really what the
content's about and then those secondary
keywords that support the primary so if
you have a machine learning video you
could choose your primary keyword as in
this case the machine learning Basics
video so well chosen keywords help you
rank well on YouTube just like the
machine learning Basics so if I go back
to our video our machine learning Basics
video if I just type in machine learning
Basics I'll be able to pull it up and so
here it is if I click on it I'm going to
go to YouTube and so here I can see this
keyword we know humans learn from their
is well aligned because it's in the
title it's in the copy and it's aligned
as a keyword taged with the video so we
know that that keyword has good volume
low competition is relevant because
that's what the video is about the
basics of machine learning it's an
introduction to machine learning so
instead of poning in on just
introduction to machine learning primary
keyword is machine learning Basics and
then we supported that video with those
secondary keywords what is machine
learning because somebody who doesn't
know what machine learning is probably
going to type in that keyword and then
introduction to machine learning is a
good secondary keyword because it's
explaining the basics of what machine
learning is all about so primary keyword
machine learning basic secondary keyword
what is machine learning an introduction
to machine learning so that's the whole
idea behind choosing keywords you want
that keyword that really is going to
define the content and then support that
with those secondary keywords so
remember remember when you're performing
your keyword research choose keywords
for your videos that Google shows on the
video results page so what I mean by
that is your video can get more views if
you rank on Google as well so the whole
idea is not necessarily to be found on
YouTube it's also to be found on Google
so if I go back to Google and I just
type in data science for beginners and I
type in videos then you could see we're
ranked number one so even if you're not
looking at the videos clicking on the
videos link on Google search you can
always just when you do a search what
Google's going to do is also put in the
videos here on part as part of the
search results so what they're going to
show you is the top videos that are
ranking for that particular keyword and
so we may not rank over all for data
science for beginners but we're ranked
number one in the videos category and so
if somebody's looking for a video that's
important and you can see here that
these first two are ads so what Google
is doing is they're saying hey this is
so relevant this particular video for
the keyword query data science for
beginners that we're going to show it
above the organic listings even though
it's a video so the whole idea is to be
found on YouTube and Google because
you're increasing your visibility you're
increasing your chances of getting found
on both search platforms so according to
backlinko google Ranks videos with
keywords like how to tutorials so you
know a lot of the videos that you find
on YouTube are going to be instructional
based and so what Google's doing is
they're saying hey if somebody types in
how to or tutorial or an introduction to
anything that's going to signal to
Google that it's instructional it's
going to help you rank so when you
search for machine learning tutorial or
how to become a machine learning
engineer you're going to get results
related to that because if you look at
these examples we have machine learning
tutorial in our title or how to become a
machine learning engineer so keep that
in mind if you're creating a video and
it's educational in nature you know use
those key terms like how to and
tutorials in the video title because
that will help you rank so let's move
over now to video title so we want to
use our Target keyword in the title of
the video and again we want to make sure
if it's educational to include that
keyword tutorial or how too so for every
video title YouTube has a limit of 100
characters so we really have to pick and
choose a really wisely so if we look at
the video that we were focusing on a
couple of minutes ago so machine
learning Basics here we could see under
100 characters we have machine learning
Basics what is machine learning
introduction to machine learning and
then the brand name so that is the title
of this particular video so it takes
into account the primary keyword the
secondary keywords and the title and it
also includes that really that key term
that really Google and YouTube like and
that's what is machine learning so it's
helping us Rank by having our key wordss
in the title with that key phrase what
is okay so that's a a good tidbit on
creating a good video title is to align
it with the right keywords your primary
and your secondary and so we want to use
those catchy words and numbers to gain
High click through just like you would
on the title tag of your web page we
want to do the same with our video title
because the video title is what's going
to show up in search so if I go back to
you know search here we could see you
know data science tutorial data science
for beginners so we want to make sure in
this case you can see data science in 5
minutes so that was purposely done so
that hey I don't have time to watch a
video I only have a couple minutes data
science and 5 minutes okay great I'm
going to click on the video and now I
have an opportunity to watch something
and learn something under 5 minutes so
choosing the right words in your video
titel is going to help you get that
clickthrough rate out remember click
theough rate is clicks divided by
Impressions and an impression is how
many times your video shows up in the
search results on YouTube or Google so
we want to keep our click theough rate
high and in order to do that we want to
be able to write some really good title
tags for our video so use catchy word
words like a number or how to or what is
cuz that's going to resonate with people
when they're searching now for the
description what we want to do is we
want to use the target word at the
beginning of the description the title
and the tags itself so if I go back to
my video here machine learning Basics we
know it's in the video title and right
off the bat if I look at the description
of the video here I can see this machine
learning Basics video will help you
understand what is machine learning so
so our primary keyword is in the first
sentence right in the introductory of
the description and so that's going to
bode well for optimizing our video the
description length is 5,000 characters
so we have a lot of characters to work
with so if I go back to my video I click
show more we have a lot of characters to
really describe what the video is about
okay there's no shortage no shortage of
including keywords into the content so
you have 5,000 characters go ahead and
see if you can work in naturally your
keywords but one of the key tips here is
just make sure that first sentence
starts out with that keyword that's a
good tip of course you always want to
make it sound natural as possible you
don't want to stuff it with keywords at
the same time work them in naturally
work in your keywords naturally and then
include hashtags in your description to
help the audience find your video is
easily so if I go back back here you
know we want to be able to include
hashtags so hashtags it's like anything
else you would use on social media it
just signals to the end user hey this is
what the video is all about and if I go
ahead and type in that keyword then it's
our video has a better chance cuz it's
aligned with that hashtag and then
there's Target keywords and LSI keywords
Laton semantic indexing keywords we want
to be able to use those keywords as
Target keywords with our video so if you
recall the example I gave a few minutes
ago we used the Facebook ads tutorial as
our example here I could see all the
target keywords associated with that
particular video so don't be afraid to
use those LSI related keywords meaning
keywords that are related to the content
use them as Target keywords with the
video so between your LSI keywords
Target keywords and then using our
primary and secondary keyword in the the
title tag using our primary and
secondary keyword in the description and
then using hashtags in the description
the combination of all of that if we
chose the right keyword then we should
find that our video will eventually rank
on YouTube so just doing these small
tidbits with our key wordss really help
get our video to rank so at the end of
the day we want to be able to use the
tools available to Us YouTube Itself by
looking at competitors those extensions
like vid IQ the autoc complete to really
find our good keywords and then
incorporating those keywords into you
know the title tag the description as
Target keywords hashtags we should
really be off and running with our video
on YouTube let's turn our attention to
creating high quality videos and some of
the best practices around that so along
with everything we mentioned about
choosing the right keywords we always
need to keep in mind that the videos we
create need to be of high quality so the
content itself in addition to the
keywords is a primary factor in ranking
so in order to have keywords we need to
have content and in order to rank we
need to have you know good content so
let's talk a little bit about creating
content and what's involved with that
and what we really mean by high quality
videos so if you have a video content
that is not informative or irrelevant to
the topic it won't rank so that's just
common sense so you need to create
content that's aligned with the topic
obviously and then that way you have
keywords that are align with the content
so but if you have content really isn't
align with the topic then you're not
going to rank no matter how much you've
optimized that video so just keep that
in mind so there's a couple of things we
want to look at here so high quality
content is determined by really two
metrics so we're not sure about how good
our content is and how good of high
quality video we created we want to look
at audience retention and user
engagement so audience retention is
simply the percentage length of your
video that the audience has watched It's
the percentage your audience has watched
so focusing on audience retention is
important for people who want their
videos to rank high so if you want to
rank you need to optimize for the key
words but got to keep in mind content so
content
is related to audience retention and
user engagement so audience retention
percentage length your video of your
video that the audience has watched and
for example it can be both absolute in
minutes or percentages so audience
retention can be the average view
duration or percentage of the audience
that watched then we have user
engagement so user engag with our
viewers who are engaged with your
content and so that means they're either
sharing it subscribing commenting or
liking so those are all forms of
Engagement so the percentage of users
who watched or how long they watched
versus engagement or in combination with
engagement are two factors for ranking
so let's talk about some tips for
creating high quality videos so we want
to publish longer videos and so what do
we mean behind longer videos so what's
the reason for longer videos let's just
suppose we have two videos one short
in length and when longer in length
first video is 15 minutes long the
second video is 7 minutes long so on
average if viewers watch about 40% of
both videos then video x which is 15
minutes long will have more than twice
the watch time of the video that's 7
minutes long so remember duration we
want you know people to watch our videos
longer so if the video is longer in
length if it's 40% then it's going to
have a longer audience engagement
audience retention so that's one of the
reasons you know from a metric
standpoint so even when viewers watch
you know both videos the time is going
to differ so we want to take into
account longer videos for primarily that
reason is because you know it gives an
an end user an opportunity to watch the
video longer and then it's going to help
us rank our videos longer so we talk
about watch time so if one video has
higher watch time than the other watch
time is just the number of views times
the average view duration so another tip
is we want to plan our video script so
we want to keep the content organized my
recommendation is you know create an
outline first and once you create an
outline of how the video is going to
flow then start populating with content
and so to me that's how you can keep the
flow organized okay is is really with an
outline starting out with an outline
it's no videos are no different than say
a presentation if you've done a
PowerPoint presentation you always want
to start out doing an outline and then
we want to upload high resolution videos
high resolution we don't want to create
videos that you know are small
resolution like say you know 400 by 400
resolution or something you know
something really small we want to create
something a very high res so according
to back or link Oak more than 50% of
videos on the first page of YouTube are
high definition so high definition
videos of higher quality are going to be
shown on the first page of YouTube more
often than not so high resolution videos
organizing the content publishing longer
videos are examples of creating high
quality videos we also want to make sure
that content is relevant to the title so
if we're talking about machine learning
Basics you know obviously the content is
going to be about you know intro to
machine learning or what is machine
learning and then the title should
reflect that content so aligning the
title sets the expectation for the end
user so when they see a title what is
machine learning then when they watch
the video and they're expecting to learn
about machine learning and what it is so
if it meets expectations then the
chances are that person who's watching
the video is going to watch it longer
and that means it's going to fulfill the
viewers requirements and when you align
everything accordingly keywords titles
content then at the end of the day the
view user is going to watch it and the
more they watch it the higher the
engagement the higher the engagement the
better chance you have to rank some
other tips that you could use to create
high quality videos so we want to be
able to you know use examples to clarify
our content so you know don't be afraid
to go into another screen like I am I
want to I'm talking about videos jump
into the machine learning Basics video
which I've done throughout this session
I can simp simply do that by keeping the
user engaged here this video is about
machine learning Basics well the title
is align with the video we made sure
that we have a nice description about
what the video is about and we're
aligning the expectations so not only
that I'm showing you example within the
video itself so we want to use examples
throughout your video to keep the user
engaged it will also help clarify what
you're trying to express in the video
itself so we want to make it VIs
visually appealing so visually appealing
means imagery or examples in the video
and then when we talk about imagery you
know you want to use good images in your
video so use public domain sites that
are available to you like shutter stock
or flat icon I mean there are plenty of
those sites out there so feel free to
use any one of those sites to use high
quality images in your video give more
information to your audience okay giving
maximum relevant information
can help gain more views and so when we
talk about more information again it
goes back to you know the examples you
use there's no should be no shortage of
examples here description use all 5,000
characters at your disposal imagery we
want to build up as much information as
you can in the video itself to keep the
end user the viewer engaged we also want
to create a original content so always
create original content you can
certainly get ideas from YouTube if you
want to create a video about machine
learning see what else has already been
done do searches on YouTube itself but
you know when you going to create a
video yeah you can create another video
about what is machine learning but just
make sure it has your own take on it
you're the subject matter expert when
creating the video create it with your
own original content have high audio
quality and video effects so just like
you see here on this video we have
effects in it and the audio is of high
quality meaning no background noise no
Distortion and we want to be able to
speak clearly in the video so you want
to speak clearly loudly concise just as
I'm trying to do now so that you can
understand what I'm trying to say or
what the viewer's trying to to
understand when they're watching the
video so watching and listening are two
of the components and you want to make
sure both of are high quality avoid
distractions we don't want to pause you
don't want to ramble on a particular
Point too long we want to keep users
engaged so you always want to move from
one point to the other intermix it with
examples those are ways to keep the
users engaged we want to include
transcripts or subtitles for your video
so transcripts is just more content
that's aligned with the video and the
search engin will be able to pick up
that content and help your video rank so
to me that's a key component to creating
a good video is having the necessary
content to go along with the video that
outline I referenced earlier in terms of
of organization you always want to have
a Content outline so what topics are you
going to cover in the video that's why
you need the outline to point that out
confirm that before you actually start
creating the video we focus on the
initial 15 seconds so that's key you
know somebody's going to click the play
button of your video and if you don't
catch them in the first 15 seconds then
they're likely going to pause the video
or just go ahead and close it out all
together so you want to be able to
capture somebody's attention right off
the bat and even before they click on
that play button you want to make sure
again you're exceeding expectations that
title is aligned with the content so in
your first 15 seconds it basically needs
to be catchy but also setting the
expectation of what the user is
expecting so in this example here we
want to pay close attention to the first
15 seconds that's when viewers are most
likely to drop off so we can look at
audience retention in YouTube so use the
options above the graph to view absolute
audience retention or relative audience
retention so audience retention is
basically how many views a video
received and the percentage of the total
number of video views and that includes
every moment of the video as a
percentage so we'll show you an example
of what that looks like so here if we go
to the machine learning Basics video we
can look at the audience retention
report and this is since it's been
uploaded the lifetime audience retention
so here we can see a nice graph the
percentage of people who viewed it and
how long they viewed it so in percentage
so here for example I can see you know
44% watch the video for at least 2
minutes here I can see
28.6% watched it for 6 minutes plus so
that's the audience retention it gives
us an idea in terms of percentage how
many people or percentage of people
watch the video at what length so that's
audience retention so we want to keep
that number high at the very initial
stage of the video and we want to keep
it high throughout and that's why you
always want to create high quality
content using those examples using
imagery making it organized content not
pausing you know going from one point to
the other those are all best practices
to keep the viewer engaged and then we
want to add resources from well-known
sites so throughout this video we've
used back linkco there are other sources
we've used so if you have a source go
ahead and put it in your video to add
credibility and then we want to use
cards to your videos so this cards is
basically a feature that recommends
relevant videos to your audience so in
addition to machine learning Basics
there could be other videos about
machine learning that we can recommend
or YouTube can recommend to the audience
to set up end screens you want to make
sure that with end screens you can use
relevant videos to your audience towards
the end of your video so you can
recommend relevant videos towards the
end of your video you can also create
playlist so this is a feature that keeps
your audience engaged with relevant
content by autop playing the next video
so if you enable this feature it's going
to go from one video to another pattern
interrupts keep the audience engaged so
basically it allows your audience to
stay within one video without having any
interruptions involved and so going back
to the did you know audience retention
report helps you analyze how well your
videos are engaged to the audience so
what do we mean by that well if I go
back again to my audience retention
report how engaging was it well I could
see 42% 43% watched it on average of 3
minutes and 21 seconds so to me that's
pretty good of course we always want
100% of the video the video is 7 minutes
long if almost half of our audience saw
over half of the video then I would say
that's pretty good people were engaged
so audience retention just is a good
report to start looking at to help you
understand how engaging is my video and
if your video is not engaging you know
you can always go back and edit it or
fix it or tweak it so remember the
average view duration for all videos and
top performing videos listed by all time
we can look at that information as well
in addition we can look at demographics
so we can get an overview of the age
gender and location and we can look at
playback locations report and with the
playback location report does is it
helps us determine the platforms where
our videos are being streamed from
within YouTube look at the traffic
sources where did the viewers come from
devices did they look on mobile or
tablet and so there's any doubts you
know if you have any questions please
drop a comment below but especially if
you have any doubts on the metrics so if
we go back into YouTube we can look at
analytics and if we're looking at
analytics we can see more and then this
is going to show us everything we need
to to see from device typee so if I
click on more I can see my playback
location so this will show me where the
video was watched it was on a watch page
or a channel page I could see the
traffic sources I could see the gender
and age so if I click on the viewer age
report I can see the percentage of views
by age so I can get a lot of information
about my video and how it's performed
who's watched it what they've done with
it where they come from all the
information they need to know so it's
all within YouTube analytics so again if
you have any questions about that you
know just drop a comment below
especially if you're new to YouTube you
may have some questions but just know
that every video you publish to YouTube
high quality align with your keywords
you're going to be able to view the
metrics by looking at YouTube analytics
so let's talk about the importance of
user engagement so engagement is as we
mentioned important because basically
we can't rank without engagement our
videos won't rank unless we have
engagement so that's why it's important
so engagement is somebody liking the
video commenting sharing it or
subscribing each one of these is
important to ranking so yes you need to
line keywords yes you need to have high
quality content so when you do both of
those and you upload your video then
it's up to the viewer and so the hard
work that you put out for the video is
hopefully going to pay dividends with
engagement so you want people to do one
of these four okay so let's talk about
what that means so how do I get
engagement so we already talked about
creating engaging content so there are a
lot of tips to creating engaging content
and so according to wordstream if your
content is entertaining then over three
quarters of the users are going to share
it so that's part of keeping uh uh users
engaged is keeping entertaining is part
of getting a high quality video so
remember on that high quality video when
we say entertaining the audio portion
has a lot to do with it examples has a
lot to do with it quality of the video
itself has a lot to do with it so a lot
of components so all those components on
a high quality video are going to lead
to engagement so parts of what you could
do in your videos is conduct a quiz so
meaning the quiz itself is a way to keep
people engaged in your video so that
also help you get some more comments so
according to back linku video comments
help in ranking your video higher so
just as I mentioned in the last segment
about you YouTube analytics and all the
different reports available on YouTube
hey if you have questions on those just
go ahead and add a comment so that's a
way to entice your users or your viewers
to add comments is if they have
questions because you know with videos
you're not going to be able to cover
every detail or every minute detail
about a particular topic you can only
cover in some cases the topic at a high
level so users are going to have
comments or questions naturally and so
the comment section is a good way to
remind viewers hey if you have a
question or comment go ahead and put it
in the comment section because that will
lend to engagement as well so we want to
add sources from high quality websites
that'll help with engagement okay use
humor in your video we want to be able
to basically you know make it human
based we don't want to be robots so we
want to be able to sound like you know
we know what we're talking about but at
the same time talk to the viewer not
necessarily at the viewer or looking the
other way and just going through the
motions so adding humor adding
personality never hurts at the end of
the day we are all human adding that
clear call to action at the end of the
video will also lead to engagement so if
we win the video with hey leave your
comments on this video or hey feel free
to share this video with colleagues who
are interested then that's a call to
action that's likely going to lead to
more engagement reply to your comments
as well so if you have comments we
always want to reply to them likely
those comments are going to be questions
because again as I mentioned even in
this video about how to rank your videos
on YouTube okay there's a lot of
information and a lot of information
sometimes doesn't get covered in its
entirety and so we want to make sure
that if we miss something because we're
only human that we're able to respond in
the form of an answer to a question that
somebody leaves in the comment section
so more comments also lead to higher
rankings because it's engagement so when
you're getting high engagement and your
video starts to rank well you you're
going to start feeling really good and
what is that going to do okay that
Feelgood is going to lead to confidence
which in turn is going to probably lead
to more videos and that's exactly what
we do it simply learn we're in the
education business but we're in it to
not only educate but making sure that
our videos are shown to as many people
as possible so that we can educate as
many people as possible so it's all it's
contagious so getting ranked feels good
and then once you get ranked then you
know you probably have good engagement
let's talk about how to promote your
content so once you've done all the hard
work getting your video done high
quality content optim with keywords and
then published to YouTube we want to let
everybody in the world know about it
right so we want to promote it've done
all the work we want to promote it now
so is it necessary to promote it I would
say yes because once your video is
published you want to reach out you want
to reach out to your audience not
necessarily on YouTube but on different
platforms so if you're active on
Facebook or Twitter that's an
opportunity for you to post or tweet
something about the new video so when we
say different platforms I am talking
about you know social media platforms so
it depends on what you're active on so
if you're active on Facebook yeah go
ahead and post something you're active
on Twitter go ahead and tweet something
it could be you know on LinkedIn group
if you're part of a LinkedIn group about
you know machine learning then go ahead
and post something to that group to
promote the video so that's going to
help Drive traffic to the video and then
help with engagement so we want to
engage with our audience on those social
media sites so it really depends depend
on what you're active on so if you have
a large following on Twitter then go
ahead and you know share that YouTube
video link on Twitter with the Tweet
that's going to drive traffic from
Twitter to YouTube Remember You know
you're going to be able to see audience
engagement or retention by getting
people to watch the video so you're
going to be able to see right away by
promoting the video and driving traffic
to the video how engaging it is remember
the more people you have watch the video
the more engaging it becomes the better
it's going to rank so it's an ecosystem
and promoting your content is part of
that ecosystem so it all starts with
social media if you're active on
whatever platform that is go ahead and
promote it so you can also look at you
know content based social media sites or
social media content based platforms
like Reddit or flicker for example so
you can participate in a form discussion
on Reddit so in this example examp Le
here it's about machine learning so we
want to be able to post something about
machine learning with the link to our
video so we can also go to content based
sites that are Q&A uh related like Kora
for example Kora is a really good site
where you know if you go there post
information about machine learning or
the basics of machine learning with the
link back to the video it's going to
help because not only is it going to
drive traffic but it's going to signal
to Google hey you a lot of traffic
coming from Kora this this is going to
bode well for this video in terms of
ranking so here's an example you know if
you find a question that you can post on
core then you're going to get people to
click on your video and respond
accordingly on Kora or you can act as
the person responding to a question
that's already there so somebody already
asked a question about what is machine
learning you can respond with your video
as the answer so you can just simply
embed your video URL as part of your
answer that'll help Drive traffic so you
can also create your your own blog and
embed your videoos so in the case of
machine learning here we have an example
machine learning what is it why it
matters so this goes nicely with the
video so here you can see the person the
author of this blog went ahead and
embedded the relevant video in the blog
post so they play off one another nicely
you can also opt in for influencer
marking meaning hey you can reach out to
somebody in this example here you know
ktie nuggets post posted information
about machine learning so in this case
why choose machine learning as a career
well they get information and then what
do they do they went ahead and embedded
the video about machine learning Basics
and so working with you know influencers
in a particular category or topic will
help Drive traffic to the video you can
also create a YouTube playlist so
playlists tend to rank high in YouTube
searches so if you find yourself doing a
lot of videos we go ahead and you know
go to your channnel and simply in your
channel you can go ahead and create
playlist so when you create playlist
basically what you're doing is you're
organizing the content into different
playlists no different than say the
music you have set up on your you know
your iPhone or iPad or or iPod whatever
it is you're using so you're just
creating different videos in a
particular category and it YouTube likes
it it's organized it's going to help you
get your videos found quick ER and
easier on YouTube Itself by putting your
videos in a playlist so here you could
see we have entire playlist on machine
learning trending Technologies cloud
computing Big Data digital marketing
project management so a lot of different
playlists very organized if somebody
goes to the channel they going to be
able to go to the playlist that's
interesting to them and see all the
videos there so it allows not only the
end user to find what they're looking
for but it's good for YouTube because
YouTube likes those playlists so we want
to engage our Audience by posting your
video link on a community page so you
could do that within YouTube and you can
prefer to link your YouTube channel in
your email so you can also do that so
for example if I go back to YouTube and
I'm looking at a YouTube video you know
I can always Click Share so here I'm
going to get a particular URL that's
associated with the video and I can just
embed that so I can embed the whole
thing in my email I can embed it on a
web page or a blog post so just by
clicking share I can also immediately
share it onto the social media platforms
that we mentioned Facebook LinkedIn
Reddit okay Tumblr so there's a lot of
ways to embed the video not just in a
blog post or influencer blog post but in
our email and on social media as well so
here's an example of what we can do with
a YouTube discussion so you can also
bookmark the video on a popular
bookmarking site you know like stumbled
upon or read it or you know there's lots
of other ones out there so there's
plenty of sites that you'll be able to
go to and bookmark that content so that
people can find it and you can always
opt for backlinks so that means that hey
if there's a blogger out there that
blogs about machine learning you can
always you know ask that blogger to
create a link back to the video and you
could reciprocate do the same thing so
that helps increase the authority of the
video so there's a lot of things you
could do to promote your video so let's
do a a quick review on everything we
talked about in terms of ranking your
video on YouTube it all starts with the
keywords so we want to identify a list
of keywords that are relevant to the
video so we can use tools to choose our
keywords but remember we want to choose
keywords that have high volume and low
competition and so where can we go to
choose those keywords well we can use
the autocomplete on YouTube we could
check out our own competitors videos or
you know we could use BD IQ or Tu budy
or any of these extensions in Chrome to
help us look at the keywords that are
tagged with a particular video so
remember we want to have a primary
keyword that's aligned with the content
then we want to choose LSI keywords as
our secondary keyword or keywords that
are related to the primary keyword so we
want to create high retention videos
meaning that first 15 seconds are the
most important but throughout the video
we want to use examples we want to keep
it interacting by adding quizzes imagery
good audio good video quality so we want
to focus on the user experience and we
also want to optimize our video content
what do that mean well those keywords
that we chose we want to use them in the
title we want to use them in the
description we want to use them as
hashtags we want to use them and tag
them with the video that El so we can
add keywords to our metatag okay we
don't want to overdo it but we want to
add a handful of keywords that are
associated with the video so we want to
be able to write I catchy video titled
and description so remember use some of
those key phrases like a number or a
question like what is machine learning
so we want to use relevant meta tags for
the videos and we want to use popular
YouTube tags so we want to be able to
tag our videos appropriately so watch
the length of your meta tags so there
are lengths involved remember keywords
at the beginning of the title Target
keywords in the title description and
tags we want to use interesting
thumbnails to increase our click theough
rate ensure that thumbnails are relevant
meaning when I say thumbnails I mean the
actual title tag itself or The Meta
description we want to use highres
videos we want to create you know videos
with good high audio quality don't be
afraid to put in video effects like some
animation don't be afraid to use
examples and then you know obviously
look at the draft of the video before
you publish it so does your video follow
an outline is it organized so these are
all the things to take into account and
there's there's plenty more you can do
you know you remember once you create
and optimize that video you want to
promote it you want to make sure that
you're sharing it on social media you
create a complimentary blog you know
generate backlinks from say other blog
posts so there lots of things you you
can do to promote your video so before
you promote it you want to organize the
content create good quality content
align it with keywords once you publish
it you know keep organizing it by
creating this playlist and then reach
out on social reach out on different
communities related to the topic and all
those things combined will help you to
get your YouTube video ranked so again
some key takeaways here use the keyword
research Available to You on YouTube you
want to basically you know watch your
descriptions you want to be able to
align your keyw with your title and
metat tag description you want to be
able to promote your content on social
media on social bookmarking so and I
can't stress enough great high quality
video first 15 seconds are important but
you're going to know if you have good
quality video because every video has
analytics associated with it so we want
to keep in mind the engagement so just
by looking at the video itself so here I
can see this blockchain in 7 minutes it
was just posted just yesterday the 27th
so basically already 42 likes 33
comments 378 views so these are all
engagement related metrics so you'll be
able to just look at the front of any
video and see how well it's performing
from an engagement standpoint so the
better the engagement the better you of
a chance you have to rank in the section
on onpage optimization we talked about
factors that's centered on relevancy in
this section we're going to go in a
different direction and we're going to
talk about the signals that focus on
popularity so what does popularity mean
in this context well it's actually quite
simple popularity always relates to
links to hyperlinks on the web so you
have seen these when you see the
typically blue text that is underlined
what this is is a um tool it's a ah ref
technically in HTML that is pointing
from one web document to a different one
uh this is a pretty simple concept I
imagine you already know this so so what
does this mean from an SEO perspective
well it turns out that this gigantic
group of signals the ones related to
hyperlinks are and are and historically
have been the line share of signals that
the search engines process when trying
to rank Pages now there's one big
problem with these from an SEO
perspective um is that they are
historically and today very difficult to
influence U this is because they do not
take place on your website they take
place elsewhere it's other people who
are linking to you generally speaking
and this makes them very very difficult
to have an influence on so this is a
good thing and a bad thing it's a good
thing because it it turns out to be a
great metric for ranking web documents
it's a bad thing because it's hard for
us to make an impact on day-to-day level
hands down the most time-consuming and
difficult part of SEO is link building
now there's a lot of reasons for this um
primarily because it's constantly
changing and because of all the elements
that are involved with this but the big
the bigger takeaway here is that there's
no one siiz fits-all solution for link
building you have to take the context of
your business of your website and you
have to apply general principles to that
so in this video we're going to cover
these general principles so you can
figure out how to apply those to your
business these principles are and I
think these are the most clever and the
most important ones are creating link
worthy content proactively participating
in off-site engagement and utilizing
offline relationships the tried andrue
method for building links is creating
content that's optimized for humans so
let me explain what this means the
currency of the internet if you will is
the content itself that's why people go
on they want to read the newest article
or they want to see the newest video
whatever it may be that is what has been
true since the beginning and I have no
doubt will be true going forward so as
an SEO or as an online marketer in
general you can use this to your
advantage creating the content that
people are going to want to share with
their friends whether they're going to
want a site in any kind of paper or
whatever they're working on that is a
tried andrue way of getting links this
is what we call the power of content you
can do all kinds of bells and whistles
you can go do these newest tactics you
can try all these different things out
but at the end of the day what's really
important is the content itself so this
is what I focus on this is where 80% of
my time goes on when I'm working on link
building it's on the content itself can
I create something that is just truly
that is so truly great that someone
essentially has to link to it this is
what I focus on trying to answer and
while there is no simple answer to that
going asking that question always sets
you in the right direction the next
strategy that I want to talk about is
actually very counterintuitive so if
you're trying to build links to your own
website I found one of the most
effective ways and this is consistently
true is to engage off your own site uh
now this doesn't make any sense right
why would you work on other people's
websites if you're trying to promote
your yourself well think about human
beings human beings are much more likely
to link and give back to people to human
beings that they know well so a lot of
the time I spend when I'm doing link
building is spend offsite engaging with
others so sometimes this is through
social media so I'll use whatever the
latest social network is and I'll chat
with people there who have similar
interests or have similar interests to
what I'm trying to promote be it a
different topic or be it a new industry
all altogether I'll spend a lot of time
promoting others and a lot of times
chatting with other people building up
genuine real relationships with human
beings so that when comes time for them
to write an article or when it's when
they're ready to link out to other
people I'm the first person they think
to and they link back to my website one
of the reasons that link building is so
hard is because the internet moves so
fast what worked yesterday might not
work tomorrow so one of the most clever
and easy ways to avoid this problem is
to just simply go offline utilize some
of the relationships that you have off
of the internet in order to benefit on
the internet this is something I try to
do all the time because it consistently
works by far the easiest favors to cash
in on are the ones that you already owed
so these might be from your friends who
you work with these might be from
friends who from childhood these are
people who you actually know in the real
world who are much more likely to help
you when you're trying to promote new
content online so when I'm trying to do
link building one of the things I focus
on is people that I know in the real
world so this can be lots of things this
can be personal friends who happen to
have websites and blogs this can be
friendly competition you have or
friendly allies you have in your space
just saying hey we're looking for these
kind of things can you help us out and
we maybe I'll help you out somewhere
else it's utilizing these relationships
that Exist Elsewhere so that you can
start gaining these links yourself uh if
that doesn't work if maybe you don't
have any friends in these Arenas you can
always go to local businesses and uh
local agencies so sometimes this is um
like government owned things sometimes
this is just third parties all together
there's lots of things that they need
help with that you as a business owner
or you as uh trying to promote some
client may be able to help them with and
if you can help them offline they're
more much more likely to help you online
when link building it's very important
to understand that not all links are are
created equally a link coming from the
homepage of CNN is going to provide a
lot of what we call link Equity it's
going to have a lot of popularity
metrics tied to it and so it's going to
be more valuable to you and help you
rank higher whereas a link also coming
from the homepage but let's say Joe Mo's
spam blog that is not going to be
particularly helpful for you and it
actually in some cases could hurt you so
when you're going out and doing link
building make sure that you can stand
behind the source of of the link that is
coming at you this could be in a good
example from like a government website
where it's trusted in a bad example this
could be from a website that you would
not normally go to even on your own in
addition to that there's different kinds
of links depending on the direction that
they're going so if a link is coming
towards you towards your website that's
called an inbound link these are the
ones that are very helpful for
popularity metrics that we've talked
about there's also outbound links these
are links that you linking to other
people now generally there's a big
misconception about this that you would
think you would not want to link out to
other people but if you just follow the
natural chain of events and you look at
people who are writing blogs without SEO
in mind you'll see that they are linking
out naturally and it's these natural
patterns that the search engines are
looking for so there's absolutely no
problem in linking out just as long as
it's to sources that you actually do
trust so there's inbound links there's
outbound links there's links that have a
lot of popularity value so like from a
established Government website or from
something popular like CNN there's also
links that are inbound that are not
going to have as much value for you that
you probably don't want to to spend your
time building now regardless of where
your links are coming from it's
important to look out for one particular
attribute it's called real no follow r
no follow was a tool that was originally
developed to combat comment spam like on
blogs you'd have lots of people who are
leaving um completely irrelevant
comments so that they could link back to
their own website and get credit for
that way that does not work at all today
uh one of the primary reasons for that
is the search engine introduced
something called real no follow where
that said here's a link that's going out
for my website but I do not stand behind
it and it does not pass any credit
a lot of times when you're doing link
building you'll get a link which you're
very proud of coming from somewhere very
popular but then realize that it has
this attribute attached to it no follow
uh and which means you will not get any
credit for it so make sure that when
you're doing your link building that the
link coming at you that you've earned
does not have this attribute associated
with it otherwise you will get no credit
for it now that you understand what no
follow is let's let's talk about the
biggest use case for this social media
most of the links that we see in social
media are valueless uh this is is
because they're either uh hidden from
search engines entirely this mostly
happens on Facebook or they're visible
to search engines but they use this Ro
this real no follow attribute which
means that they're useless so while
social media does have many many
benefits uh SEO and particularly link
value from SEO is not one of the direct
benefits of participating in social
media now that we've covered some of the
link building dos let's talk about some
of the link building don'ts so these are
things that you should not do U because
you'll be wasting your time and possibly
more importantly money the first one is
Spam so we have all seen this online
when you go somewhere and you see just a
bunch of spammy links links that are
clearly written only for uh machines
only for search engines a lot of times
these will have the name of
pharmaceutical drugs on them a lot of
times they'll have um just be completely
irrelevant to the content while these
have worked in some instances they are
certainly not a best practice and they
are certainly not a long-term strategy
so I never recommend trying to invest in
spammy links this way because it's not
going to ultimately help help you in
fact in many ways it'll probably hurt
you so do not go out of your way to try
to get spamming links the next one is
buying links this is these are to
closely tied together now buying links
is when you go out and try to buy
sometimes relevant sometimes irrelevant
links and again this is something that
had worked sometimes historically not
always my biggest problem with this is
not so much the ethical problem although
there is one there U the search engin
have clearly said not to ever do this um
my biggest problem with it is that you
could not calculate an accurate Roi on
this so you spend a dollar on this you
don't know if you're going to make a
dollar or $2 doar back you have no idea
there's no way to accurately measure
this so you have no idea if this if this
is valueable to you or not where as
opposed to if you're creating valuable
content you can measure that and you can
directly tie it to Sales so you're your
money dollar for dollar spent much much
more effectively on content than it is
on buying links so I highly recommend do
not spend your time or your money buying
links the last one is acquiring
reciprocal links so reciprocal links as
you can imagine are link links that go
in a circle you link to somebody and
they link directly back to you now in
the natural web when no marketing is
taken place into this there's no kind of
manipulation trying to go on that
happens that happens all the time so
don't go out of your way and be afraid
of this happening so one news site will
very regularly link to another news
article and that article might link back
to them somewhere else that happens so
don't stress about this too much but
don't go out of your way to try to build
all of your links in a reciprocal way
we're overthinking this by trying to
link to somebody else who links to a
third party that third party links to
you don't waste your time this is just
not factor that you should worry about
reciprocal links are not generally as
good as oneway links but it happens so
often that is not is not worthy of your
time or any kind of investment trying to
avoid this so if you are looking to grab
a successful career in digital marketing
and learn search engine optimization
simply learn has got you covered with a
wide range of topn digital marketing
courses these courses make you skilled
in SEO content marketing PPC social
media marketing and much more with
hands-on experience in the tools like
Google analytics Keyword Planner Sim
rush and there's a huge list on the
board however one year of experience is
preferred to enroll in these courses
find the course Link in the description
box the concept of linking is
foundational to good rankings and
understanding the internet at large it
starts with the premise that good
content will be cited by others
recommending it to other people how we
site and recommend information online is
by linking to it we link to information
that we find
valuable based on that the search
engines assess content by how websites
link to one another so we are going to
cover the definition and purpose of
links and the different functions that
links serve we'll also look at how links
mirror human
judgment we'll look at how search
engines evaluate links by mirroring
human judgment
and how that affects what's called Block
Level
analysis and how where the location of
different links and how they are used
will greatly affect their
relevance we're going to look at how
visitors from different link sources
will behave differently based on where
they came from and also how you can
measure the effectiveness of links and
finally we're going to look at both good
and bad linking practices now links
serve serve a number of
purposes from a functional standpoint
they usually are our primary means of
navigation online we click on links we
go to different pages and from those
pages we find links to other Pages links
are also a method of citing other
content when we quote somebody when we
use information that we have found
somewhere else we site that information
to give credit to the original author
typically on online we do that with a
link so that if someone wants to see the
original Source document it's available
to them that also helps to provide
credibility to you credibility to the
author of the original source as well as
assigning importance to the knowledge
that came from that original source and
the authority of the original
Source links also provide us with a
clear structure of how our websites are
built how the pages relate to one
another and how organized the
information can
be so let's break down the functional
part of a link this is important if
you're going to be developing anchor
text and linking to understand the
structure the
ahre equals is the start of the link tag
what you are doing is developing the
reference of where the document is
contained that's the h ref reference is
what it is short
for what comes next within the quotes is
the location of the document now this
can be a full URL or you may just be
linking to a document that's on the main
root level of your
server this is the full location where
you can access the document and so
you're putting the name of the document
the extension so that it will be
linked the next part is what I have in
caps you'll notice off to the left I
have something in all blue text and
underlined which most people will
recognize as a link you see when it is
in between the document location and the
closing of the link tag the text you
have in there is what's called anchor
text you see instead of publishing the
document location and the full URL of
the document we can put the link within
text and create anchor text so all
someone has to do is click on the link
and the document loads for them this
anchor text is vitally important to
understanding how we can add additional
relevance to linking
content then we see the closure of the
link
tag this is what makes the internet the
internet is millions of pages connected
together by Links
so when we look at the functional side
of links and we look at this example
here as you can see the title of this
article is not the URL address of the
article it's a title and the title is
the link that is the anchor text of the
link and so from a search engine
standpoint search engines look to see
what words are being used in the link
and how relevant those words are to the
document that is being
linked it also looks to see where is the
link is it in the editorial information
in the article is it part of the
navigation is it in a sidebar or is it
an
ad and then also search engines are
looking to see if this is a text link or
an image
link how long has that link been there
what type of link is it does it go
somewhere within your website does it go
to another website or is it a reciprocal
link which I will explain more later
they also look to see the text in the
link and the context to the page with
the link directs you
too we utilize links a little
differently you see from a human
standpoint whenever we refer information
to another person when we provide
reference material to another person or
even if someone asks us for a
recommendation we provide this
information you see offline we mirror
the same behavior as we do online when
we link people ask us for information
and we provide it we just mirror that
online by making a link offline we
recommend we refer we provide
information to each other in much the
same way the way I want you to think
about it from a human standpoint is that
if you asked another person for advice
or directions or a referral are there
certain people that you would trust more
than
others I'm sure the answer to that is
yes and maybe you have some people in
mind that you are thinking about you see
we run across the same issue with search
the search engines know that there are
some websites that are much more
trustworthy than
others just it's like if you were to ask
someone for information I'm sure you
would ask the right person for the
information you would ask the most
knowledgeable trustworthy person you
knew who had Authority in that subject
area the search engines are trying to do
the same thing with the links that we
publish on our websites they're trying
to determine who is the most trustworthy
and relevant based on the
recommendations referrals and citations
of other websites to other websites who
are the websites that are trusted that
are authorities the search engines are
trying to do from a technical
algorithmic standpoint what we do
naturally from a human
standpoint now from The Human Side as I
had said before we need to think of
links as information that we receive
from other people Word of Mouth advice
information directions recommendations
this is where we need to think about
links not from the standpoint of
building false relevance for a search
engine but being a helpful resource for
our readers how can we help them how can
we provide information and how can we be
a credible source of
information how can we develop our
Authority within the industry and so
that people who have questions about
this content will see our websites as
authoritative and credible
resources the best way to develop links
as you'll see is good content when
people like what they read when they
like what they see when they are willing
to recommend it to others it it's
because you have created something of
value and they'll link to you when they
feel that you are credible and that you
are authoritative
with this information only then will
they share it with other people because
you have earned that right for them to
share it with others by providing
content that is informative educational
entertaining and you've provided that
service only then will people then want
to recommend it to others by linking to
it now links serve a number of benefits
When I look at some of the incoming
links to my site one of the things I
notice is that if I get a link in
certain places that can drive a lot of
brand exposure I can have thousands of
people coming to the site looking to see
an article and that provides a lot of
exposure to a lot of
people however also getting a link from
a certain website especially if it's a
high relevant authoritative website I
can see my rankings increase because of
of that but then also a good link is
going to drive people that will convert
and drive sales or leads those who
become
customers so those are the three aspects
of a good link a good link will drive
traffic to your site a good link will
assist your rankings and a good link
will bring in business if you can get a
link to do all three of those at the
same time that's what I call the golden
link because it has all three
benefits usually however you're going to
find that different links will provide
different types of benefits one of these
three or maybe two out of these three
one of the things I'm usually very
focused on is the link that drives sales
or generates leads that's getting links
in the right place that will benefit me
tangibly rather than just getting
thousands of people to see
it why it benefits benefits me
financially if I can get a link in the
right
place so from here let's break down the
different types of links we have
navigational links we see these in our
navigation our primary navigation maybe
the footer of our web pages where we
have links to typical information such
as about us or contact us we also have
sidebar links this might be related
information or offers or calls to
action and then also I would break it
down into outbound or inbound type of
navigation outbound are links going to
other websites inbound links are links
that come from other websites and that
also I might send to other pages on my
own
site now I've used the term editorial an
editorial link is a link that is found
within the content of the website and by
that I mean through an article so if I
am writing an article and I link to
someone else and cite them or reference
them that is what's called an editorial
link it means that it's part of the
content a great example of this is that
the navigation on your web pages is not
part of the content it serves a function
as
navigation but it doesn't have anything
to do with supporting information with
citing an Authority so information and
links that you put within the content
and presented content of your site are
considered
editorial now there's also call to
action links where you're bringing
someone to a landing page or a
registration page or a sale
page then also we have Social Links now
these can provide a variety of means but
typically a social link will go to a
profile maybe it's a username that takes
you somewhere else or a comment or maybe
just an image or something that goes to
a social site or that you have placed on
your own site as
well either way it's all contained
within that social network even though
the links are going on and off your site
they tend to be controlled in that
social
environment now I've used the term
reciprocal link now this
is something very specific a reciprocal
link is one where you would go to
somebody else and you would make a trade
such as if you link to me I'll link to
you and maybe you put those links on the
homepage or maybe you create a page just
for that link you see sometimes it just
doesn't make sense and so the search
engines will see that you've linked to
each other but if there's no contextual
relevance if there's no contextual
relevance
most likely you won't get any benefit
because you've agreed to link to each
other for the primary purpose of
boosting rankings now this is not to say
that two websites can't link to each
other because there is some relevance
we'll look at some examples of that
later on in this
module also then we have advertising
links these can be ads banners anything
on the page that is an advertising link
that if you were to click on it you
would go to that advertiser's page those
links are typically through an ad server
and they take place in entirely
different
ecosystem but they are links and we need
to know what kind of links are
advertising and which kind of links are
functional to our
websites now when I broke down the
different types of links so we have our
navigation links we have links in our
sidebar and in our footer what Block
Level analysis does is that the search
engines look at the code of the page
they break down the page because it's
very easy to figure out which part of
the code has to do with your navigation
which part of the code has to do with
your sidebar and your footer and which
part of the code is calling ads from an
ad server what this leaves is the
editorial content your article and the
ability of search engines then to break
down your page into these different
elements the reason why they do it is
that the links contain
in the editorial space are considered to
be more relevant in terms of linking to
other websites than any of the other
types of links on your web page search
engines don't consider all parts of the
page to be equally relevant which is
okay because neither do humans we look
at the navigation as utilization pure
utility because it's just helping me
navigate among the different pages of
your website I'm not expecting to learn
anything I'm using it as a functional
means of navigating your site now your
sidebar might have some calls to action
it might have links to other pages but
it's not an article it's what you've
developed and so it might be a little
more important than your navigation but
it's not as important as what you may
have written within content your footer
navigation is basically the same you
control that it's the same on every page
and so what the search engines are
looking for are the unique content the
unique article or information that
you've published and if there is a link
within that editorial content that is
highly relevant because it has to do
with content it has to do with
information that you are sharing and so
the links there are going to be more
highly relevant and are going to be more
important for the search engines to see
you see it's the same way with humans
we're not going to look at navigation to
learn something it's functional the same
thing with the footer and as humans
we're reading the content that you have
in your article and if you link to
another source well you've provided us
with utility but it's contextual utility
because you're citing where you found
information or you're citing an
additional Source or you are linking to
an example and it enables me as a human
to see that understand it and if I need
that additional information I can click
on it and go to it so I'm going to look
at the information on the page in that
article very differently than I'm going
to look at the headings the navigation
the sidebars or the footer because the
article is what is informing me and so
the links in the article I'm going to
look at very differently and hold them
in a higher level of
relevance now over time search engines
have had to refine the algorithm about
links you see in the early days of
search engine algorithms they used to
Simply count the amount of links then if
one site had more links than another
that made it more credible however once
people started to figure that out people
started accumulating links by really any
means necessary and they were just
looking for the sheer volume of links
because they knew if they got the most
amount of links it would affect their
rankings and so over the years the
search engines have had to change and
adjust and add more relevance to their
algorithm refine it in order to look at
different aspects of links in order to
properly determine relevance so over
time it wasn't just having a link it was
then also looking at how many people
site this site as an authority so
looking at the source of the link and
the types of pages then also looking at
the text of the link and matching it
with the text of the page does it match
is it contextual and then looking at the
type of Link doing the Block Level
analysis and then also the context the
relevancy of your site compared to the
linking site compared to the link and
the information that's being shared
there also some of the ways that they
can look at it are the age of the link
how long has that link been there humans
do the same thing when we look to see
how long someone has been in business
we're looking at
credibility and then of course of course
there are many many other ongoing
refinements that are going into the
search engines evaluations of links
sometimes the age of the link isn't as
relevant especially when you're looking
for something that has happened very
recently an Old Link could mean that
it's old news or that something has
changed since then so search engines are
in a constant battle to ensure that
people are not gaming the system by
falsely creating relevance
through
linking the link relevancy and the
algorithm is all about trying to
determine who is the most relevant and
credible within this area and that is
the focus of most search engine
algorithm refinements over the past few
years and it will be into the
future now this is where I'm going to
start bringing in some screenshots from
a link Management
program as a search engine Optimizer a
link Management program is probably
going to be one of your best friends as
you move along in this
industry in this example this program
linkex that I'm using will track the
incoming links to my website and it'll
also provide a breakdown as to what type
of website those links are coming from
so I can see how many links I have from
blogs how many links I have from news
sites how many links from wikis how many
links from director forums social media
public relations sites articles or
additional
resources then I can also add my
competitors and I can compare where I
stand in terms of the amount of links
from each source and where my
competitors stand in this way I can be
sure that we all have a similar link
profile you see if my linking profile
looks vastly different than all my
competitors the search engines are going
to see that as well and know that
something might be different with me
good or bad and that's going to raise a
red flag so I want to look at the
linking profile because every industry
and almost every business's linking
profile is going to be a little
different but especially among
Industries we see that linking profiles
that is the amount of links from
different sources it's going to be
slightly different for every different
type of industry or business so this
helps me understand where my links are
coming from which is vitally important
because from a business standpoint one
thing that I've tracked consistently in
analytics is that people will act
differently and also I can predict which
source is going to send me the best
customers you see just because someone
comes from a link doesn't mean they're
going to buy or become a customer or
really become a lead many times they're
going to come look at your information
and leave and based on how they come to
your site whether it's through a Blog a
directory a forum or a news site has a
lot to do with how they view your
website and it's all about the
context you see this is what I've
learned over the years is that people
will behave differently based on how
they find the
website what I found is that people from
blogs news sites and articles they tend
to stay longer do more and have a higher
chance of conversion of becoming a
customer or a lead the main reason is
because blogs and articles they have a
lot of context it's an article someone
has taken the time to write some
information out and then link to my site
which means there is a highly contextual
reason for someone to click that
link also what it means is that there's
a lot less competition for that link
when my link is in that
article compare that with social news or
any type of social site you see when
you're on a social site and you're
looking at your social stream of
information there's a lot of different
people competing for your attention a
lot of different things and it's not
just in one subject area it's usually
from multiple subject areas and so the
context is very low because there's a
lot of different types of information
and the competition for your attention
is very high because of that people from
social sites or applications tend to
visit more often but they only tend to
view one page and leave immediately
because they're looking to see what was
interesting and then they move on to the
next
subject that's the difference between
how people react based on where they
come from and so when I'm measuring
links I'm looking to see which links do
I have what's the source and then how do
those sources behave differently from
one another and why you see if I find
that I'm getting links from sources that
people are staying longer doing more and
converting at a higher rate then I'm
going to continue to focus on building
links in those areas because it directly
affects how I monetize my
website so here's a strategy in building
links one of the things I'm looking at
is the source of links like I said if I
can find a link Source that's providing
visitors that will stay look at my
content engage with the content and
eventually convert and convert at a
higher rate than other sources of
content or
visitors then I'm going to focus on that
source and so I'm going to look at some
high Authority websites whether they're
industry Publications news sites
education sites those are what are
considered high Authority blogs articles
news
sites that's what I'm looking to do I
want to find the most authoritative
website and sometimes it happens
naturally if people that work at those
websites or manage those sites if they
find you and they like your content
they'll link to it and that way you can
get more credit credibility more
relevancy certain people certain
organizations certain websites have more
Authority and influence than others it
goes back to the question that I asked
you early in this module that how do you
know if someone is more authoritative
than somebody
else we also have mid Authority websites
which you can get some links on and low
Authority websites which are very easy
to get links but here's what I've
learned when it comes to link building
one link from one high quality website
can be worth hundreds or thousands of
mid to low quality links ultimately it's
about quality not
quantity one of the things that I will
do utilizing my link software is look at
the context of the link I want to see
how relevant this is so as I said if I
want to find a high relevant website
what I'm looking looking for in terms of
this is I want to see the influence of
the domain as well as the relevance of
the domain those are two factors that
we're going to look at when we're
evaluating the quality of a domain now
as I'm looking at this report here what
influence means is that it is a high
quality website that within the linking
algorithm these sites have a lot of
authority
however they may not be relevant so for
example they may have a lot of sites
attributing authority to them but they
may not be relevant to my industry which
is why we have the next column of
keyword relevance you see when I'm
evaluating my links I'm looking for the
sources that are both influential and
relevant that means that I've got a link
from a site that fits the two standards
of high Authority it's authoritative and
relevant now it's good to have links
from authoritative sites that might not
be relevant it's still
authoritative however to get the full
benefit I want it to be influential and
relevant but not to say that I'm not
looking for links from these other
sources this is just a means of
measuring what you have as well as
compar comparing it to your competitors
and other
websites now here's some best practices
when I'm optimizing anchor text I want
to maintain contextual relevance so I
want to use text in the text link and I
want to explain to people what they're
linking to what they're going to find
when they click on that link if I use an
image as a link I'm going to use an ALT
attribute because of that image doesn't
show up that Al tribute is necessary to
let people know where to go but also I
do get a little tiny bit of benefit by
using that alt attribute within the
image
link I also want to look at the
relevance of the source page that I'm
linking to and make sure contextually
the link the link text and the content
of the page is contextually relevant to
the destination
page I also want to be sure that I don't
over use the keywords that I don't make
multiple links to the same destination
that I don't use the same anchor text
over and over I can be downgraded or
even penalized by the search engine
algorithm if that is found on my
pages so as an example instead of using
click here for a how-to article I might
use the exact phrase of how to fix
whatever it is and use use that as the
link to the page that has the
content that's a simple way of looking
at anchor text am I directing someone to
additional information if I am then how
can I present it to them so they know
exactly what they're going to find and
Link it
appropriately I look at as developing
the next step for your readers where do
you want them to go what do you want
them to do what resources do you have
available to them how can you structure
them so that they're easily understood
and you're explaining the Final
Destination like I said if you overuse
anchor text you can be downgraded or
penalized by the search engines so what
I will tell you to do is number one
avoid overstuffing anchor content that
means needlessly repeating keywords in
the anchor text don't do that avoid
being redundant meaning don't have four
or five or six links with the same
anchor text going to the same page
that's a clear way of letting search
engines know that you're going
overboard don't just randomly Place
links throughout your text just to get
the link ask yourself are you really
helping the reader find the information
they need and do it once and then also
avoid extremely overly promotional words
within the link text such as best expert
cheap number one those types of things
so a couple examples we can say for
travel advice click here but I would say
here is my travel advice and Link travel
advice rewrite it be
creative if it were easy everyone would
be doing it but this is where you can
write things in a better way to get the
attention of the reader and position it
as a
resource also utilizing your url as the
link or as the anchor text as well for
the link in order to get that click as
I've got it here I would not recommend
that you use that I would recommend that
you avoid
that also the third line to check out
the best website for iPhones and iPhone
accessories utilizing overly promotional
words is one of those ways that you can
easily get caught by the search
engines now for future considerations
when it comes to Links realize that the
majority of algorithm changes are link
based evaluation refinements because
people are constantly attempting to fool
the search engines and develop a false
link
profile you should work to to create
high quality links with high quality
content I wouldn't chase after Poor or
lowquality
links now as I've mentioned before there
are a number of tools available for you
to manage and measure your back links
tools such as link deck MZ Raven
Advanced Link manager Majestic SEO and
then also you can use your Google
analytics as well
however Google analytics only shows you
the visitors that have come from links
and what they've done the basic
functions of Link management software
and there are many other types other
than what are listed here but the first
thing that it does is just provide a
catalog of incoming links from other
domains to your site and your competitor
sites they offer tools for comparison to
see which domains are linking to you
what type type of link it is and on
which Pages those links are listed
they'll also report newly acquired links
in the past 30 60 90 days or something
similar to that the purpose of Link
management software is to help you
assess high quality domains versus
lowquality domains in terms of
importance and
relevance like I said the first job of a
link management tool is to collect all
of your back links you add your domain
and the tools will usually spider the
domain they'll go out into search
engines and go out into many other
formats in order to find and retrace who
is linking to you what page that link is
contained sometimes what text is on that
page and what text is being used in the
link they will catalog all of your
incoming links organize them format them
and report back to you most of these
link programs provide additional filters
and management tools so that you can get
more insights about who is linking to
you how they are linking to you and the
type of
site personally I use Link decks in
order to Monitor and report on my
backlinking so the first report here
that I'm showing out of linkex is that I
see the total amount of incoming links
to my domain this says I have over 2,000
links and those 2,000 links are on about
1,000
domains on average it looks like I have
about two links from every domain that
is linking to me so this is one way that
you start to look at your links number
one the total amount of domains that are
linking to you and then the total amount
of links available this way you can
isolate domains that are linking to you
consistently and also find those that
may not be the best domains or that are
sending a lot of links that are just not
relevant
the next thing I do in analyzing My
Links is to look at the type of Link
meaning the type of site that it's
coming from this report breaks down the
amount of links coming from blogs news
sites directories forums social sites
articles or resources now it doesn't
usually get all of those links but it
does get enough to give you an idea of
how well you're doing in each channel
one of the things that I do like about
this report is it also has a timeline so
I can look and see when new links have
been acquired and maybe when some links
have been just disappeared that's called
churn and it's normal it's normal
because many times a link is published
on social media and it kind of just goes
away or it's not tracked anymore by your
link management software it can't find
it anymore and so linking is always
Dynamic you are always is gaining new
links and losing old links there's going
to be a normal amount of
churn the next report shows me all of
the domains that are linking to me it
also shows me in the next column how
many of those domains are also linking
to at least one competitor and it will
list as many competitors of I have
listed in here if they list to multiple
competitors it will let me know the
influence of that site or the Authority
that site is seen because of the amount
of websites and credibility that
Authority has for that domain it'll also
let me know the keyword relevance how
relevant that website is overall
contextually to my domain and the
content that I have it will also let me
know how many pages on that domain have
links to my website so I can also go
through and I can filter this list by
the type of site I can filter by those
domains that are using anchor text to
see how much anchor text is being used
and what type of anchor text there are
many different ways that you can filter
through all of the domains that are
linking to you in order to get an idea
of what's happening on your domain what
are competitors doing and also the
relevance of those links to your
site now when I say that I can add
competitors this is another type of
report very similar to the one I showed
earlier where I look at my own standing
in the different types of sources of
links such as blogs directories forums
and so on I can also when I add my
competitors look to see how they are
performing in those different areas as
well and so I can compare my link
profile to my competitors different
Industries are going to have different
backlink profiles they might be more
heavily weighted towards blogs or they
might be more heavily weighted towards
forums or social sites in this way I can
look to see if my competitors are
actively link building and how they're
going about it I can see where maybe
they are excelling in one area that the
rest of the competitors are not so I can
compare different strategies I can also
compare different timelines to see if I
am acquiring Links at a faster rate than
my competitors this is very important if
you are a newer business or a newer
website trying to
compete now specifically what I can do
is look at an individual domain in this
case this domain has three pages linking
to me and that domain also links to two
of my competitors I can look at the
specific pages and what I'm looking at
here are Snippets this should be
familiar to you because what it's
showing is the URL of the page that's
linking to my page it shows me the page
title of that page p and then in this
report it lets me know if there are any
keywords being used in the link in the
anchor text as well as the number of
links from that page now what this tells
me is that this is most likely a
directory something that is listing all
the different places that where you can
buy products because it's most likely
linking to the domain name seeing that
there are no keywords being used in
Anchor text and also that there are 16
outb links from that page that means
that it must be a list of some sort and
they are linking not only to me but most
likely to competitors as well so I can
track my Links at the Domain level and
at the page level I can look to see
which Pages might have more influence or
relevance to my content I can also see
the link URL the page title if any
keywords are being used in the anchor
text and and also within the context of
how many additional links are leaving
from that page if there are a high
amount of outgoing links on that page
then a link from that page might not be
as valuable since there are so many
links the less links there are coming
out from that page the more it will
benefit my site because I'm getting more
benefit from less
links now also what I'm going to do is
compare the link reports to my Analytics
I'm going to go to my analytics because
linking software does not show traffic
it doesn't show how many people are
clicking on the link it only shows who's
linking to you but it does not show
visitor activity analytics will show you
visitor activity to see which domains
are most effective in sending visitors
to your site if you'll go back to the
primary benefits of linking visitors
branding and business and analytics show
me visitors and business it shows me
which domains are sending me visitors
and which of those visitors are becoming
customers so what I can do is go to
Google analytics look at all the domains
that are referring traffic to my site I
can also click on the domain and see the
destination page that they are linking
to I can see how many visitors are
coming either monthly or annually how
often they're coming back whether
they're new users or repeat users how
long they stay how many pages they View
and how many conversions as a result of
those visits this is a great way to get
a 360° view of your linking because not
only do you want links that will help
you rank better you also want links that
will send business and customers to you
as
well building links can take many forms
ideally it is through Network Works
relationships and marketing that other
websites and users learn about you like
you and recommend you to others
unfortunately there is a lot of bad
outdated and untrustworthy advice to be
found about building links to your
website in this section I'll present the
best practices as accepted by the omcp
standard the objectives for this module
that you'll be able to develop a link
building strategy that you'll understand
the value of different link types
finally you'll be able to find inbound
link
opportunities the first step in building
links is to evaluate what you have now
there are many tools available that you
can utilize to do this for you there are
automated tools that you can get that
will catalog all of the incoming links
to your website
some of them are link deck MZ Raven or
Advanced Link manager there are many
that can do that you may also want to
utilize your analytics as well in order
to find websites that link to you the
first step is evaluating where you are
right now your incoming links have a
significant impact on your rankings and
you can do a lot of on pay optimization
and see some
results however a lot of Google's
algorithm takes into account links from
other high quality
websites now when you evaluate what you
have in this example I'm showing you a
screenshot from
linkex linkex cataloges the incoming
links to my website and it groups them
into different areas the first way it
groups them is by high value or high
influence
domains those are websites that link to
me that have a lot of influence not
necessarily in my industry but High
influence based on the amount of people
that link to them as an authority on
many different subjects the next way
that it groups that is based on
relevance now this is when it looks at
the match of my content versus the
content of the other website in the
first example we can see the National
Library of Medicine it is a high
influence website because it is a
government website with a lot of
information that is cited frequently
because of the amount of other websites
linking to that site it has a high
amount of
influence now based on the website that
I am measuring there is a lot of keyword
relevance meaning that that National
Library of Medicine site with the
government has a lot of content that's
very similar to my site a lot of the
same keywords are being used so not only
is this website of high influence it
also has a lot of relevance and that's
key when evaluating my
backlinks I want to look at which
websites are also referring traffic so
while I may have a link from the
National Library of Medicine I went to
look at my analytics and look to see is
it also providing visitors are visitors
following that link to my site and I
also want to look at the quality of
traffic that it produces do these
visitors stay longer than average do
they convert more than average I want to
look at the quality of traffic based on
the
source next I want to look at the
incoming links from those other websites
number one I want to make sure that the
incoming link from the other site is
both accurate and relevant meaning the
text that is used in the link is it
accurate to the content that will appear
on the page when the visitor clicks that
link is the content relevant this is
especially relevant if I have updated my
website changed the content or moved
things around
I want to be sure that that incoming
link sends visitors to the appropriate
page and the appropriate
information I also want to ensure that
that link is worded correctly that it
uses the right words that is sending
visitors and setting expectations of the
content that they will
see I may need to contact the website
manager or owner and maybe ask for a
better link text or a more accurate page
destination now this requires some
interaction with the owner or manager of
another website and you always want to
be respectful of their time and not
demanding that they make any changes in
some cases the organization may be so
big you may never find the right person
in order to optimize the text or the
destination of that link you always want
to look for accuracy in cases where your
company or website name is utilized in
the link but also if there is any
contact information such as address
phone number a description of your
business and any content make sure it's
accurate and it all points to the right
place another way to look for links is
to Simply go to a search engine and
start doing searches search for your
company your business your company name
and look four websites that may mention
you but do not have a live link to your
website many times your company will be
mentioned or cited but there will not be
a live link you can only find these
through doing searches and seeing which
websites mention you without linking to
you now this could be an opportunity to
get an Easy Link especially if you can
find some contact information and
finding the right person that could add
a link to your company
information again you'll need to be
polite ask for their help and it will
help it if you can develop the link
along with the link text and send that
over giving them just a quick and easy
edit to be able to add the information
so make it as easy as
possible as an example I've provided a
sample request format
again you want to be polite you want to
be inviting and respectful of their time
and their
management sometimes like I said you may
find the right person that can help you
however the larger the company the more
difficult it will be to make this happen
this just requires your
patience and again being polite and not
expecting the company to do what you are
asking
many times this is just a formality and
sometimes companies will act on it so be
sure to approach this with the right
expectations the next thing I want to
look at are business listings these are
the easy ways to establish links and
ensure that links are where they should
be and also
opportunities look for business
directories especially if your company
has a local presence
you can utilize Chamber of Commerce
lists Association lists or local
listings if they are on websites see if
they offer links that can go to your
website rather than just the list of
businesses that are in the area even on
a larger level you can look for
associations directories or listings
where you can add your business or
double check if your business is there
and oh always ensure that your business
name address phone number and URL are
correct complete and consistent with
other
listings the next level will require
some active marketing and that's where
you search for
opportunities you can go out and look
for other resource lists within your
industry or directories of businesses
within your industry and you can get a
link many times through membership for
submitting your business as a
resource however you may want to step up
your marketing you can do that by
interviewing your clients seeing if they
might be willing to provide a
testimonial and a link to your website
you may also want to go out and find
other communities online maybe some
social communities that are relevant to
your
industry get involved with those
communities fill out a profile and get
involved by contributing information by
sharing information you'll find that
people like getting information and
they'll respond by linking to your
site another option is to utilize the
tool that you had for indexing your
links from the first step you can also
add your competitors and you can look at
their back links you can look and see
which websites and which domains are
linking to your competitors but you
always need to go and see why what are
those other sites linking to and what is
the nature of that link sometimes it may
exclude you from being able to approach
competitors back links and ask them for
links however if they're being linked to
by companies that are simply stating
here are vendors in this space and they
are linking your competitors and you're
not there then it might make a lot of
sense for you to approach and ask if you
can be listed as well however be sure
that the links to your competitors are
not from a consumer or customer
relationship in that case it might be
out of line for you to ask for a link
make sure if you approach anyone who's
linking to a competitor and asking for a
link to your site make sure the context
is right and that it makes sense for
them and that's the ultimate judge of
value
does it benefit somebody else to link to
your site we all know that it will
benefit you but when you present your
link request you need to offer value and
a benefit for others to link to you so
be sure that you present it in a way
that is beneficial and good for those
people that will be adding the link
they're the ones that have to take the
work to do it and they're also the ones
that are adding a recommendation for you
and your business so as always you need
to be considerate and
patient now the best way to build links
is by creating something that people
like and sharing it you see the best way
to build links is by creating value
through content or information or
entertainment you see when people like
things they link to it if they find a
study or a white paper or research that
you performed they link to it if you
post a infographic that explains
something and it's attractive people
link to it you see that's what's most
amazing about linking I find that when
we put most of our effort into creating
content that people like that's what
builds s the most valuable and the most
relevant links and so what type of
content well you can create infographics
videos top 10 lists or articles articles
with advice or analysis of Market data
or even
research that type of content people
love it and so when you publish it out
you utilize social media to extend the
reach and the visibility of that type of
content and when someone likes it
they'll link to it and recommend it to
others now people also like depending
upon your industry or your business they
also like some personality maybe some
humor people always like expert
information they like the cute this is
why pictures of cats tend to be liked
and linked to more than almost anything
else and also the
unexpected if you can inject any of that
into your content that just makes it
more valuable more personable and again
more sharable by other people and every
time someone shares it it builds a link
to your
site you see the best linking is when
people like something when you create
something that people like and share you
might be surprised at the many
opportunities there are to get links
based on your content I've seen many
many blogs based on on cooking fashion
Arts Sports music and when people
specialize within a specific topic they
always find an audience and so anything
they publish builds links even on
certain social media sites such as
Pinterest people upload pictures on
articles and
infographics especially about
landscaping flowers food cars you name
it there is a special interest for
anything and you can develop links from
those social sites to your site and it
can generate
traffic even with a Blog developing
articles that talk about upcoming events
new music Sports whatever it is when you
create content that people
like it takes the longest amount of time
to build content for building links when
you develop your own content that's the
biggest investment you'll make in time
and research and writing and
presentation however the result is that
when you develop that content you will
receive the best and highest quality
links and the most valuable links are
going to be to that content as I
mentioned before one highquality link
can be worth more than hundreds or
thousands of lowquality links so my best
advice is to create content that people
like that they link to and that will be
high value links that you'll generate to
your site optimizing technical elements
of a website such that search engines
can easily crawl and index the web pages
is known as technical
SEO some technical optimizations include
reducing the page loading speed of a web
page to a
minimum submitting site maps to search
engines have organized website structure
as it informs search engines about the
essential pages of the
website adding redirections for the
deleted URLs or temporarily moving
URLs identify duplicate content and
replace it with unique content hello
everyone welcome to this new video by
simply learn
have you ever wondered what will happen
if the pages of your website are not
visible in the search
engines definitely this can be the most
scary thought you ever
had but due to lack of technical
knowledge this is happening in the real
world with the new bees in the SEO
industry well for these beginners this
video is the opportunity and the
solution to your problems
to get your Pages search and appear in
Google search results it is important
that these pages are index in
Google and to get the web pages index
Google search console or search console
is the One-Stop solution Google search
console forly known as Google web master
tool is a web service provided by Google
Developers
Google search console is mainly
responsible for optimizing a website for
its
visibility indexing website detecting
crawl errors
Etc after understanding what is Google
search
console now we need to focus on why
search console is an important part of
search engine
optimization a website's technicalities
are directly or indirectly related to
search
console consider you have created a
website for your
business but from past few weeks your
website is not visible in search result
Pages here search console comes into
action there is a possibility that
search engine crawlers are not able to
crawl your website thus it is not VIs
ible in the search result
pages to make crawlers crawl your
website you will need to optimize your
website using search
console some other technical aspects of
search console
includes fixing indexing problems
sending the updated content or Pages for
indexing generating search traffic
reports generating alerts if there are
any issues related to indexing or any
other issue gets the list of sites
linking to your website keep the track
of mobile
usability amp pages and
more so now it is right time to
understand how search console works but
before we begin this topic have a look
at the range of courses of digital
marketings and search engine
optimization from skill up by simply
learn you can get the link in the
description box below so now I have a
question for you what will you do at
first if your web page fails to appear
in search result Pages well let me know
your thoughts in the comment section
below stay tuned with this video Even
though if you don't have the answer
right now by the end of this video you
will surely able to answer this question
so let's get started by knowing how
search console Works to understand the
working of search console it is
necessary to have a detailed knowledge
about how search engine works search
engines mainly Works in three steps
crawling indexing and ranking let's have
a look at each step one by one so first
let's start with crawling search engines
are hungry for content and so so they
send Web spiders or web crawlers also
known as robots or search engine Bots to
discover new content or any updated
content content can be an image a web
page a video or anything else present on
the web this process is known as
crawling now let's know about
indexing as soon as the crawler discover
the update dated content or new content
these web crawlers start storing the
URLs of the content into the search
index or web Index this process is known
as indexing once the content is index it
starts appearing in the search result
pages when a user enters a search query
the most relevant results are taken from
the
index and displayed in the form of most
relevant to least relevant in the search
result Pages this process is known as
ranking now that we have gained
knowledge about how search engine works
here I have a question for you choose
the correct option with respect to
working of search engines you need to
choose the option for all the steps of
how search engines work option A
indexing crawling ranking op option b
ranking indexing crawling option C
crawling indexing ranking and option D
crawling ranking and
indexing let us know your answer in the
comment section
below now let's get started by learning
how search console actually
works search console is a primary source
of information that helps search engine
BS to crawl index and rank the pages of
your
website thereby allowing the website
owners to monitor the health of your
website all you need to do is integrate
search console with your website and get
the
ownership allow the search engine boards
to crawl your website and index the
pages also don't forget to submit your
your website sit map to search engines
submitting sit Maps helps the crawler to
discover more pages of your
website thereby understanding your
site's
architecture we will know how it is done
in the upcoming part of the video also
you need to keep an eye on the errors
suggested by search console and solve
them else it may harm the ranking of
your website now let me remind you that
all the reports that are generated in
search console are based on the activity
of the web Crawlers on your website now
let's understand various parameters and
terminologies from search
console to get a complete understanding
of this web master
tool so without any further delay let's
start understanding the basic
terminologies of Google search console
and how they work
and improve your website's
Health the first one we have is
performance
reports Google search console provides
two types of performance report search
reports and discover
reports let's first understand about
search
reports search reports help to analyze
the search performance of your
website search performance reports
include metrics and
dimensions so let's first focus on
metrics here there are four types of
metrics as you can see in this image the
metrics include the total clicks or I
must say clicks Impressions average CTR
and average
position Impressions provides the data
on how many times your websites appears
in the search results and as you can see
here the graph shows the number of times
this website has appeared in the search
results the next metric we have is
clicks clicks provide the data on the
total number of times users clicked from
the search results and reached your
website the graph below shows the number
of times the users have clicked from
search results and they have arrived on
the any page of my website so suppose if
here is a number 200 so we can
definitely get an idea for very number
of dates number of dates provided on the
x axis which shows that how many times
the user has clicked and arrived on the
website and the number varies uh varies
from between like 200 200 uh 250 300 and
in between 250 to 300 and the next
metric we have is average CTR average
CTR or click through rate is the
percentage of Impressions that results
in Clicks in the same manner the graph
below shows uh the average CTR for
various different
dates the next metric we have is average
position the average position represents
the data about the average position of
the sites in the search results
uh it is possible that your website is
ranking today at number one position so
it may rank tomorrow at 3 some other day
at 4 some other day at 9 or 10 and again
it may rank to the one so this data
actually provides the detail about the
average position uh which your website
uh frequently uh ranks at so that is if
it is ranking at 1 two and three in
between 1 two and three positions so the
average position may be two
now understanding about the dimensions
dimensions are the data attribute that
defines who did something on your site
or from
where here is the list of dimensions on
which the dimension performance reports
are generated that is the countries
Pages queries devices search appearance
and
dates the dimension country suggests the
country from which the search came as
you can see here from the um left column
you can get the list of number of
countries from the right side you can
get the idea about the clicks
Impressions CTR and position that is all
the metrics related to that query uh uh
from which the search came from or from
that location or whatever the activity
has happened from that location next we
have is the dimensions Pages pages just
show the pages clicked by user or a page
that is viewed on a search so this this
actually you get the reports from the
search console in the form of the links
where you get the link which is the
exact page that is viewed on the search
if there exist duplicate pages on the
site then only one canonical page or
canonical link will be displayed by the
search engines out of the number of
duplicate pages so basically canonical
links are those links uh like if there
are suppose there is a one original page
and there are two three duplicate page
of the same page so what happens uh uh
the original page gains the canonical
link and uh this page has more value
than the uh duplicate pages so whenever
the search engine will crawl your
website all the duplicate pages may be
ignored and all its link juice or link
equity or anything will be uh completely
taken for the original
page uh moving ahead to
queries queries provide the query string
that users search on the Google search
console so Suppose there is a website
say suppose uh let's talk about the
simply learn website so suppose a user
may add as Java course and simply learn
websites appears at second or third
position so this query uh say suppose
user clicks on the website and reaches
the website this query Java course on
simply learn or Java course will add in
the search console uh showing that the
user has reached to your website using
this query Java course and again all the
list of the queries appears towards the
left and all the matrixes for that query
like clicks Impressions CTR and its
average uh position is appeared towards
the right in the search console now
talking about about the search
appearance search appearance helps in
grouping the data as per the search
result type or by the feature so you can
get here the number of search appearance
and again the same metric is uh with
respect to the search appearance
criteria next let's move towards the
dates dates groups the data as per the
dates according to the public time zones
now let's have a look over the Discover
performance report now here you must be
thinking about how the search is
different from discover yes search and
discover follow different approaches
users enter a query to find a required
information with
search whereas discover shows the
content based on what result will be
best matched for your query as per the
Google's automated system now coming to
the Discover performance report report
as per Google's guidelines discover
performance reports are visible only if
your website has a minimum threshold of
impressions in discover now moving to
another important parameter of search
console which is URL
inspection URL inspection is an
interesting tool in the search console
this tool allows you to inspect whether
the URL is in indexable or
not some main functions of this tool
includes checking the current status of
the URL inspecting live URLs requesting
indexing for a
URL viewing Pages rendered version
viewing crawled Pages viewing tested
Pages
Etc in order to check the index status
of URL open the U URL inspection
tool and add the complete
URL for which we need to know its
indexing status now to understand the
results check the present status if it
shows that URL is on Google as you can
see in the screen this means that URL
qualifies Google's criteria and is
eligible to appear in search results if
it shows URL is not on Google then the
URL does not qualify the Google's
criteria and is not eligible to appear
in search
results you can check more details like
URL Discovery crawl and indexing
information from the page availability
tab click on the craw page to see the
information about the HTTP request and
response if you find that the link is
disabled just hover over the page to
check the reason now coming to the live
URL
test it is helpful to test the live URL
and check if it is capable of being
indexed it proves helpful when you
update your page and want to compare it
with its latest indexed version just to
bring it to your notice a life test will
only confirm whether the Google Chrome
ER can access your page for indexing but
it doesn't assure that your page will be
included in the Google index Al together
with the help of index coverage report
one can find the list of URLs which
includes the URLs Google has found on
your website the URLs that have been
indexed and identify if any indexing
problem have occurred next we move ahead
to understand understand about the site
Maps a s map is the file that contains
all the information of pages on your
website this helps search engine
crawlers to crawl your website and
understand your website
structure and helps them to index the
pages more
efficiently more the crawler indexes
your pages higher the chances for the
pages of your website to appear in the
search results
with the help of site maps you can
provide information about various
contents like Pages videos images Etc as
you can understand a Sit map plays an
important role in indexing process you
must be curious to know how we can
create and submit a Sit map to search
engines before we understand this
process make sure that all pages of your
website are linked in in an appropriate
manner with each other thereby
maintaining a healthy site structure a
site map can be created in XML format
RSS format or in text format it can be
autogenerated or created manually as
well most commonly used sit map is
XML following is an example of an XML
site map this is the simplest version of
the site map that we are representing
here you can submit a site map to the
sitemap reports in the search
console however sitemaps can also be
submitted through robots.txt file let's
understand about robots.txt
file so let's understand the robots.txt
file in
short robots.txt file notifies the web
Crawlers about the URLs that they can
access on the website as there are lots
of search engines there exist different
web crawlers thus there is a possibility
that some web crawlers may not obey the
instructions from the robots.txt file it
is necessary to know how to use the
proper syntax as different crawlers
understand syntax
differently thus there are chances that
some web ERS might fail to understand
the instructions from the robots.txt
file a page can be index even if it is
disallowed from the robots.txt file if
it is linked to other
site next let's know what enhancement
reports are all the rich results status
reports are displayed under the
enhancement tab so let's know more about
rich results these type of results are
known as Rich results in serbs so
basically Rich results can be any search
results other than the traditional Blue
Links for example image results carouses
Etc you can check whether the pages from
your website support Rich results or not
using the rich result test tool provided
by Google Developers
now understanding the rich result status
report the enhancement tab contains
separate reports for Rich result type
some rich result report types are listed
below that are
breadcrumbs education Q&A event FAQ fact
check guided recipe how to image
license job
posting learning video reviews Snippets
Etc Rich result status reports consist
of summary page and Details page the
summary page mainly consists of Errors
useful items found on your website
warnings Etc The Details page consists
of the information about the issues when
it was detected item type when was the
page last scrolled Etc before we
understand how to fix error in search
console it is important to understand
the status of each page as reported by
search
console each page has any of the
following status error warning excluded
and valid if the status of the page is
valid it means the page has successfully
indexed the status of the page page
appears to be excluded if one
purposefully wants the page not to be
indexed or a page is blocked by
robots.txt file for example setting the
metatag to no index warnings majorly
appears when the page of your website is
indexed but there are some issues with
the page which need your attention and
have to be resolved as soon as possible
if the pages status is error then there
is a need to pay a detailed attention
over the issues in the page as these
issues prevent the page from getting
indexed let's discuss about the errors
in detail and how we can fix
them some popular errors from the search
console are listed
below that is the redirect error server
error submitted URLs blocked by
robots.txt URL marked as no index
submitted URL is a soft 44 44 or page
not found error so let's first know
about the redirect error some redirect
error that search console shows up are
the redirect chain that was too long
redirect R redirect you URL that exits
maximum URL length and bad or empty URL
in the redirect chain so all these error
means that the redirections are not
working properly and so there is a need
to fix them so suppose for example you
have added too many redirects from one
page to another so in this scenario
search engine Bots find it a waste of
time to crawl again and again again to
the same redirections and at that time
the search engine crawlers or search
engine boards ignore those URLs or
redirections so in such cases you need
to fix those redirection to a single
URL the next we have is server error the
server returns 5xx error when it fails
to fulfill a valid request this error
mainly conveys that something is wrong
with your website server all you need to
do is reach out to your hosting services
and inform them about the issue and make
sure it gets resolved as soon as
possible the next one we have is
submitted URL blocked by robots.txt to
resolve this issue you need to remove
the line of code from the robot.txt file
that restricts Google from crawling the
respective page the next we have is URL
marked as no
index when the URL is marked as no index
it sends the signal to crawlers that
this page is not meant to be crawled or
this page is not meant to be indexed if
you want this page to be indexed check
the metadata and remove the no index
attribute to allow the Crawlers to crawl
the URL now let's understand about the
error submitted URL is a soft
44 and 44 or page not found error
whenever a web page load server return
returns a 200000 signal showing the
success status code soft 404 is a
condition in which server returns 2000
success status code and the page not
exist errors
simultaneously this is considered to be
a bad user
experience
this error can be solved simply by
redirecting this page to any relevant
URL or the homepage of the
website talking about 4 not4 or page
notb error this error mainly
occurs when you delete the page from
your website but the URL of the page
still exists in the site
map this error can be solved by simply
removing the URL or removing the 44 URL
from the site map or redirecting the URL
to a new
page this will help to avoid the further
errors in near
future we will have a detail look at
other 4 XX errors in the upcoming videos
now that we are aware of the basics of
search console let's dive deeper to know
some stats regarding the search console
in the SEO
industry when you're thinking of adding
a business online your website should
fulfill all the technical SEO needs
which can be achieved by Google search
console thus there is a huge demand in
SE industry for the candidates having
strong knowledge of Google search
console the average salary of an SEO
expert with the Google search console
skills in US is
$53,000 to
$78,000 per anom and that in India is 2
lakh 76,000
perom some biggies in the ASU industry
looking for this skill sets include
Accenture Amazon people group Eon
Etc so let me know your dream company to
work as an SEO expert in the comment
section below the search engines have
put massive resources into developing
the visibility of local and Regional
businesses in the search results in
addition the massive increase in
prevalence of smartphones over the past
few years have made location-based
searches and expected everyday
occurrence people expect to find results
based on where they are immediately
here's the basic idea behind local now
for a long time in the past search
engines wanted to be able to provide
results based on where you were in the
world in a very precise way they were
able to use this somewhat by using the
IP address and they could approximate
where you were but it wasn't always that
accurate what they really wanted to know
is where you exactly were within feet or
meters now this technology has evolved
considerably and in a very short amount
of time using location technology like
GPS and Wifi
in addition the prevalence of searching
on smartphones accounts for more than
60% of searches every day these factors
now enable search engines to know your
location and provide incredibly accurate
and thorough options for your
search so what's at the core of this
well it's the acronym
na it stands for name address and phone
number this is the most critical factor
for any business not just in local SEO
but for local it is critically
important all you need to do is on your
website specify one name for your
business one address and one phone
number and then when you put that into
different directories like Yelp or
Yellow Pages or whatever you may be
using you need to make sure that you
have exactly letter for letter the same
name and the same address and the same
phone number unfortunately this gets
convoluted because the search engine
spiders index and classify information
business information can be classified
separately all because of the slightest
variation in business name or address
making it look like a separate
business now a human would easily be
able to identify the difference and
classify the variations as a single
business search engines can't do that
yet start on your own website specify
one name for your business one address
format and one phone number and then use
that same identical name and format when
you set up your accounts at different
websites and directories like Yelp or
Yellow Pages you need to make sure you
have exactly letter forl letter the same
name the same address and the same phone
number unfortunately this can be
difficult there are a lot of different
formats for phone numbers certainly for
ad addresses and even for names any
inconsistency will cause problems again
a human might be able to figure this out
easily but using the examples a search
engine would consider this two separate
businesses at the same address or
because the address format is different
it may even be considered two different
businesses at two different addresses do
you see how that works so search engines
do not usually know that they're the
same business business and this causes
all kinds of
problems so let's pretend that your
address is 123 Happy Street sweet 3
there's a lot of different ways you
could write this you could spell out
sweet you could use just the
abbreviation for it and there's actually
two abbreviations for sweet you could
also use unit instead of sweet but sweet
numbers and abbreviations are where
people lose their
consistency even with Road Street
Parkway or Avenue you need to pick just
one version spell It And format it
exactly the same and use it consistently
then find all the instances of different
variations you have online and go fix
them the last part of this is
directories so directories for a while
now has been a bit of a bad word it used
to be a great way of doing SEO until it
got
abused in fact it got abused and over
overused and abuse was that people would
charge a lot of money so that you could
be listed in a directory and now in
modern days directories are not like
they used to be and they're not that
useful getting links that way and doing
link building through directories is not
going to be greatly helpful however the
big exception to this is with local SEO
there are important IPS internet Yellow
Pages there are also things like Yelp or
Urban spoon where people go and submit
their local
businesses real human beings pick up
their phone and they go to the Yelp app
and look for businesses and because real
human beings are using these unlike the
directories of the past this means that
you want to have your business there so
in some ways directories at least in the
local space have returned a great
example of this are local or even
National Business
associations Chambers of Commerce
business assoc associations industry
associations and other directories can
be good places now after all that let's
move on to some other local
signals so the first most important
signal is This Acronym again naap name
address and phone number the key here is
that
consistency the next thing is keywords
and titles this is extremely convenient
because it's something you should be
doing for SEO anyway this is particular
for title tags which is something we've
covered in the other
videos the next one is domain Authority
so if you have an important domain an
important business Google is going to
use this as a signal when they're doing
a traditional local
search so when someone's on their mobile
and they're looking for a good
restaurant if you are an important
restaurant in the city you're going to
be more popular in both local search and
traditional search that's domain
Authority the next one is inbound link
signals this again might sound familiar
the things that help you for traditional
SEO do the same for local the first one
is Anchor text so this is one of the
most important if you're a great
restaurant hopefully you're going to
have lots of bloggers lots of magazines
and local online entities that are
writing about you and linking to you
they're naturally going to use your name
and the name of your business in the
review about you these are the kinds of
things that Google is looking for
because these are what is effective
online the last one is reviews and
citations but in this context these have
very specific definitions it's not just
reviews in general like the ones I've
talked about it's reviews on specific
local directories or business
listings and it's both the quality of
them are you getting five stars and the
quantity of them do you have 100 reviews
do 100 people care enough about your
business to review you now the next one
is a bit more complex as it does
requires some programming on your
website this is called schema Micro Data
or structured data schema is an agreed
upon programming standard by search
engines browsers and device
manufacturers that directs the markup
and display of specific
content it's typically content that is
repetitive by nature and therefore if
it's displayed in a consistent manner
for all devices browsers and operating
systems to know the content then they
can display it properly you'll find it
in addresses contact cards dates
e-commerce products reviews people
places creative works and more what
we're most concerned with here is the
address and phone number by using schema
when you add your address or phone
number to your website it enables the
visitor to use the click to call
function on their phone when there's a
phone number on the website in addition
using the address schema can open up a
map when someone clicks on it to show
the location utilizing this schema
provides clear data to the search engine
that can be republished across a variety
of channels now specifically for
Google's business listings they give a
very wide range of content for
businesses to list so fill out as many
areas of the business listing as you can
business hours payment types accepted
phone numbers descriptions reviews from
Google and maybe even from your own
website you can link your social
profiles in any events or promotions you
have one of the biggest signals that
we've seen grow in importance are the
amount of pictures that you load into
your business listings in fact Google
provides a report as to how many times
the photos are viewed by Searchers many
times businesses that have many photos
will show up with more prominence than
those that have little or no photos so
take advantage of the listing
opportunities that Google provides
finally the same behavioral signals that
are used in search are also used in the
local search results and this is because
the search engines especially Google can
see how Searchers interact with your
local listing because it is in their
system the behavioral signals start with
how many people search for your business
this is directly related to your local
visibility and loyalty so don't forget
about your local offline marketing next
they measure how long someone views your
listing they count how many times the
phone number is clicked for someone to
call or when someone clicks to find
directions in addition there's a button
there for directions to be sent to a
searcher's phone if they're using a PC
or laptop all of these engagement
factors and buttons on a business
listing are counted as engagement and
task completion which increases the
behavioral signals for your business as
people save the listing check in or even
visit these all send important
behavioral signals of popularity and
loyalty which contributes to your
business's visibility in local search so
thank you for joining and let's get
started before I tell you how to bring
traffic to your website let me tell you
why this is so important okay why do we
want to bring users to our website I
mean it has to be on equal ground as web
development and design is somebody who
goes to your site and then does
something when they get to your site so
you have users and when those users get
to your site they're generating page
views and traffic and you want to turn
that traffic into engagement okay so
each Page's traffic is configured
independently of all their pages so when
you go when somebody goes to your
website they look at a page that's a
page view and certain pages on your
website you want to turn that page view
into a conversion okay whether that be
you know looking at a video or
purchasing something so think of these
pages on your website as salespeople
they're trying to convert visitors who
come to your website but first we need
to get the visitors to your website so
when you get visitors to your website
again you can generate sales which means
revenue or you can increase brand
awareness or you can earn Revenue
through sponsored post and advertis M so
if you have for example a lot of content
on your website you can turn that into
to revenue by hosting ads on your
website so when somebody clicks on that
ad you're going to earn a percentage of
that click okay what that click is worth
so having a website means a lot of good
things for you but first you got to get
the traffic there and so what we're
going to do is we're going to tell you
how to drive traffic to your website so
there's lots of different ways in which
you can bring traffic traffic to your
website well the first is paid
advertising so paying to advertise your
products services with ads is one of the
easiest ways to drive traffic to your
website so some of the options available
are search ads social media ads or
display ads so search ads are ads that
are displayed in the search engine
results so when a user types in a
keyword query you want your ad to show
up based on that keyword query okay so
an example is digital marketing course
somebody types in digital marketing
course and simply learn is the first ad
that shows up how do we know it's an ad
because you could see the word add next
to the domain so when somebody clicks on
that link simply learn is going to pay
Google so that's how search advertising
works okay the next is social so social
media marketing involves increasing
traffic or engagement or brand awareness
a lots of different strategies but
you're instead of doing doing this on
search you're doing it on a social media
platform okay so for example you can
advertise on any particular platform and
the way you advertise could be with an
image it could be with a video so in
this case you could see Cobo is doing a
sponsored ad here how to succeed with
Google ads and then another form of
advertising is display so display means
creating ads that are placed on specific
websites so with display unlike search
you have a choice in the ad format with
search you only have text ads but with
display you have text ads image ads rich
media ads video ads so you have lots of
different options in which you can
advertise on other websites so the idea
here is to get your ad in front of the
Right audience when they could see your
display Banner your banner ad then it's
going to be more visual more appealing
generate some brand interest
and hopefully you can get somebody to
click on that ad and over to your
website so that's paid advertising again
through search through social through
display but you can also promote your
site on social media so once your
content is gone live you could take
advantage of different social media
platforms I mean it really depends on
what you're trying to promote because
what you're trying to promote needs to
align with the appropriate social media
platform so Facebook is best suited for
Industries like food and Beverages and
news and media and if you're selling a
product so you fall under one of those
categories and Facebook could be the
right platform for you if you're
involved in again beauty or food and
beverage or e-commerce then you can also
leverage Instagram which is part of
Facebook's ecosystem so if you advertise
on Facebook you can also advertise on
Instagram Andor Instagram so it doesn't
have to be and Facebook and Instagram it
could be Facebook or Instagram you also
have LinkedIn as a platform LinkedIn is
great for B2B so if you're trying to
promote industry news or or tips and
best practices or job postings then
LinkedIn is the place for you it's a B2B
platform it's great for targeting
specific Industries targeting specific
job levels or job descriptions okay so
LinkedIn is great if you're into B2B
focusing on the business side of it so
you also have YouTube now YouTube is
part of Google's ecosystem YouTube is a
video platform okay so it's great if
you're trying to promote gaming or
entertainment if you're a vlogger okay
so YouTube's a great way to promote your
site uh by getting your product out
there in the form of a video then you
have Twitter Twitter to me encompasses a
lot of different Industries Beauty and
fitness news and media entertainment
okay you have limited number of
characters
but a lot of people are active on
Twitter and it's a great way to generate
some awareness and get some clicks over
to your website so these are just some
of the most popular social media
platforms of course there are plenty
more out there the third way in which
you can drive traffic to your site as
guest post blogging so most of you
already know what blogging is all about
well if you're blogging for your own
site you can jump on somebody else's
site and blog on their behalf so having
the opportunity guest post on another
website can be very helpful because one
that other blog could have lots of
traffic and have a a well-known brand so
if you're blogging on another blog it's
going to build your brand awareness and
potentially increase traffic to your
blog or website so it exposes to you to
targeted traffic so if you're going to
guest blog guest blog on a site that's
very relevant to your business or
industry that way you're targeting the
Right audience okay you can EXP and your
personal Network so getting yourself out
there getting your brand out there in
front of a different audience and then
obviously for serves CU it generates a
backlink so SE search engine ranking
Pages means that hey if you want to rank
organically you're going to have to
generate some backlinks so guest
blogging is an a way to generate some
backlinks to your site and in effect
that's going to help you get your pages
ranked higher because Google's going to
recognize the relationship
from one blog to your blog and build up
your relevancy so some other benefits
here to guest blogging is you can grow
your social media PL following because
you can then promote that on social
media that you're guest blogging okay
again you can improve your online
Authority okay because when you're guest
blogging and you have recognition on
that guest blog if it's a popular blog
then that's going to help your domain
and Page Authority for SEO and then the
end result is improve your back blink
score so there a lot of benefits to
guest blogging to me at the end of the
day it's just about reaching out to your
audience using another platform to do
that in the form of a Blog and the
results of that is going to mean more
brand awareness for you in turning that
traffic from that other blog into
qualified leads so you can also
interview industry thought leaders so
that's another way an interesting way to
generate traffic to your sites so
reaching out to thought leaders for
interviews okay could generate some
credibility for you and the other person
so it's reciprocal so it means that
you're active in the industry that
you're in and it allows you to engage
with other leaders in the industry and
the indirect net result of that could be
increased traffic because if you do the
interview and you record it or if it's
via video then you can obviously post it
on other platforms and that could in
turn Drive traffic to your website
obviously just like guest blogging it's
going to increase your reach so getting
yourself out there if nobody knows who
your brand is and they know who the
thought leaders are and they see you're
interviewing the thought leaders then
that's going to put you in front of
these people and so it's going to
increase your reach another way to drive
traffic to your website is just to make
sure your website's responsive and what
do we mean by responsive well we mean
does it work on multiple devices
specifically mobile so depending on the
device your website hides shows shrinks
enlarges or moves content so that it
conforms to the browser that that
person's looking at on your for your
website so if somebody's looking on
mobile at your website you want to make
sure that your website adjust
accordingly so you want to be able to
you know test and make sure it's
responsive and so is content arranged
based on importance okay does it work
across different browsers on different
devices and do the images text and
everything else align just like it does
on desktop so there are plenty of tools
out there on the web all you need to do
is just do a search for you know check
my website for responsiveness you know
so you you can use plenty of tools to
check to see if your website is
responsive towards multiple devices why
is that important because if somebody
goes to your website Via Mobile and your
site doesn't align properly or the
content's all stretched out and somebody
has to maneu move their browser just to
see your website then chances are
they're not going to come back chances
are they're not even going to convert
okay so you want to be able to revise
your device browser combinations you
want to make sure that everything works
accordingly you want to be able to test
those fonts make sure they look good and
then you also want to make sure that
people can navigate so if they're on
mobile are they going to navigate just
as easy as they can on desktop and if
you have any popups you want to probably
make sure they're removed so that way
when somebody's looking at your website
they're not getting interfered with on
mobile and then of course you want to
make sure that these Pages load okay so
they load just as quick on desktop as
they should on mobile and vice versa so
they should not take a long time to load
so moving on from responsiveness on
mobile to building a brand community so
brand community refers to a group of
people who identify your brand and use
your brand as a platform to exchange
ideas and contribute content some
advantages of having a brand Community
are promoting brand evangelism and
loyalty it could be a source of feedback
loyalty and ideas so build a community
build a brand Community who you know
identify with you okay so continue to
you know treat these people as loyal
customers okay maybe give them a
promotion uh to use specifically just
for them that they can use on your
website or talk directly to them because
you know that they're followers they're
repeat customers they purchase for you
multiple times so talk to them
differently as well you know who these
people are and that's what building a
Brand's all about it's about identifying
your brand with other people okay and
identify people who identify with your
brand and messaging and talking to them
as if they're part of your own Community
your own family so you you can use user
generated content that provides future
marketing strategies so the feedback you
get from your own Community could be in
turn used to promote or used in future
marketing strategies I.E advertising I.E
post on social okay can also provide PR
opportunities so it's a chance for you
to you know put out press releases based
on the community that you buil so any
brand regardless of who it is should be
able to identify with your audience
their target audience and that target
audience eventually going to become part
of a community these are group of people
who identify with you what you're trying
to sell what your cause is what your
mission statement is what your services
they identify with you so leverage them
and reciprocate identify them talk to
them separately give them the what they
deserve the respect and loyalty that
they deserve deserve as well because
they're communicating and they're
following you as a brand so the next
thing you could do to drive traffic is
Be Active in the comment section so
engage in relevant and thought-provoking
conversations on other blogs and sites
it doesn't necessar have to be another
blog per se it could be other sites like
Reddit or core or medium sites that have
a lot of content that are broken out by
industry that allow you to engage in
conversation allow you to either up Vote
or share or respond okay so be active
because when you're active people are
going to see that hey you're a leader in
the industry you know what you're
talking about you have some some brand
Equity you have some thought and some
knowledge on the specific topic and
subject so it just puts you in a better
light when you can respond and be active
on these different platforms okay let's
turn our attention to search engine
optimization also Al known as SEO or
organic search so in order to drive
traffic to your site you're going to
have to implement an SEO strategy why do
you want to implement an SEO strategy
because it can help you improve your
overall searchability and visibility on
search engines and obviously that comes
with advantages one of those advantages
is obviously more traffic to the site
search is still King in terms of volumes
of people using search on a daily basis
so you have a great opportunity to be
found it also builds trust and
credibility because still a majority of
the people who do a search click on an
organic search listing and so if you're
found organically and you're ranked
number one then chances are somebody's
going to click on your listing and it
provides increased engagement in traffic
and so what that means there more
traffic more engagement an engagement is
something you define it could be again a
download of a document or the clicking
on the play button of a video or or
submitting a form or signing up for a
newsletter or calling these are all
forms of Engagement so the amount of
traffic you drive from organic search to
your website is only going to improve
engagement okay so you can also provide
an improveed user experience and what do
we mean by that well if you're getting
lots of traffic from organic search you
have a really good opportunity to do ab
testing and when you do AB testing you
can improve user experience meaning
you're showing one variation against the
other from people coming from organic
search and so this is helpful in that
you know if you're running an AB test
the variation has a chance to improve or
outperform the original and if it
outperforms the original you're
improving user experience and then it
helps Target quality traffic so SEO to
me or all search is the only medium in
which you're meeting somebody halfway
you're you're addressing what they're
looking for so if somebody's looking for
a paer of red women's Nike shoes the
2019 model and you have that particular
product to offer well you have a chance
of showing up via organic search
somebody types in you women's red Nike
shoes size whatever at the year 2019
model then of course they're going to
probably likely click on your listing
because you have what they're looking
for and and that goes with any keyword
any industry any business any segment
any type of product you're selling so
again you have a chance to really be
visible for what people are looking for
and so that's the beauty of search
engine optimization you have a really
good opportunity here to meet people
halfway to drive quality traffic to get
them to enjoy a good user experience all
the while generating engagement and
along with SEO we want to be able to
build backlinks so SEO is a two-pronged
approach meaning you have two strategies
in one on page and off page and so off
page involves backlinking so backlinks
are just links that direct users from
other websites to your own website so
with that inherently it's going to drive
traffic qualified traffic to your
website cuz if somebody's on a relevant
website that's linking to you yours and
they click on that link and go to your
website it's likely going to be
qualified meaning they're going to be
relevant and so back linking because
it's an off-page strategy why is it an
off-page SCS strategy because if Google
crawls that other site that has a link
to you then that's going to give you
credit because Google say hey this
site's getting some links from some
relevant sites we must think they're
relevant and therefore we're going to
trust this site so by Google Trust ing
your site it's going to improve your
organic ranking and with the organic
rankings being improved meaning it's
going to mean faster indexing so what
does that mean so you want to be indexed
by the search engines and so the quicker
Google can find your pages even if it's
on somebody else's site then that means
they're going to follow that link go to
that page on your site and take that
page back to their servers to be indexed
okay so the quicker you can get indexed
the quicker you can get found and then
it helps with referral traffic so again
we noticed that our efforts are on SEO
organic search but if you're getting
traffic from another website hey that
still counts that's referral traffic
okay so that's a side advantage to
having backlinks is good traffic from
other sites okay so those those are
inherently the some of the reasons to do
backlinking okay never hurts that I mean
there's brand awareness reasons to being
on other sites as well there's industry
leadership meaning if you you you post
content on Reddit okay you're coming
across as an industry leader but yet
generating a backlink which helps with
SEO and referral traffic so there's a
lot of benefits to building backlinks
and the opposite of backlinks are
internal links so you want to do
internal linking and that just means
connecting one page on your site to
another and why is that beneficial
because it can help direct visitors to
other Pages they wouldn't normally
otherwise find via your navigation
so if you're active on a Blog don't be
afraid to include multiple internal
links you want to move people through
your site you want the flow of traffic
to go from one page to another to
another and so when you do internal
linking just like with backlinks it's
going to improve the indexing of your
website Google's going to follow those
links and index those pages and Google
does give credit from an SEO perspective
from an internal linking perspective so
if one page is link to another and that
page has really good relevance in the
eyes of Google then the other page is
probably going to benefit from that the
other reason you want to do internal
linking again you want to move people
from your one page of your site to the
other and when you do that it's going to
reduce bounce rates so bounce rate is
simply the rate at which people land on
a page and then leave so if I have 100
people land on my homepage and only one
person went to another page and the
other 99 left the site then that's a 99%
rate so by putting internal links in
place you're helping people move from
one page to the other and thus reducing
the bounce rate and that's what you want
you want to keep people on your site you
want to be greedy it also drives traffic
to older post so again when we say older
post we're really referring to blog post
so if you have a relevant blog post and
you're writing a new blog post then link
the two together if it's relevant link
it I don't you know regardless of how
old it is you know you want to show
Google that these older blog posts just
cuz they were written a year ago doesn't
mean they're outdated and oldfashioned
okay or useless you want to keep them
alive by linking to them so to me that's
a good strategy for internal linking
link to older blog post you know show
people you're an industry expert you've
been doing this for a while and then you
have lots of content to share okay so
the longer you can keep somebody on your
website the more likely it is they're
going to engage and convert and some
other inherent benef benefits improves
page rank so what we mean by Page rank
is simply just a rank that Google gives
pages so the more internal linking you
have the better off you are and then it
helps spread link juice across websites
and what we mean by link juice again
just like backlinking it builds
relevancy so just keep all these
inherent benefits in mind to internal
linking the end result is keeping the
flow traffic on your site and all these
other benefits will fall into place okay
so another way way in which you can
really hone in on traffic to your
website is longtail keywords and
longtail keywords to me are more than
just one or two keyword phrases okay so
they're usually three or longer keywords
in a phrase okay so longtail keywords
really nowadays account for most web
searches people really take the time to
even post questions as a search query
say likely somebody it's unlikely
somebody's going to go into search and
just type in the word shoes they might
type in red shoes but that's unlikely
what they're probably going to type in
is you know red Nike running shoes
2019 or some variation of that okay
that's a longtail key word and some of
the advantages of using longtail
keywords to be found for are less
competition so if you're using broad
keywords like red shoes then who doesn't
want to be found for Red Shoes well you
don't necessarily you don't want to be
found for red red shoes cuz it's too
broad you don't know what type of shoes
somebody's looking for you just know
they're looking for Red Shoes it could
be running shoes it could be work shoes
it could be you know boots it could be
slippers okay it's too broad so longtail
keywords help narrow it in and the more
narrow and focused a keyword is the less
competition is going to have and when
something's not competitive in the form
of a keyword then that means your
chances of ranking for that keyword are
going to be greater and the chances of
you ranking faster are going to be
greater and then of course if somebody's
looking for exactly what you have to
offer then you have a higher chance to
convert that person so if you have
exactly those
2019 red Nike women's running shoes and
somebody does a search for that and
that's a longtail key word and they
click on your organic listing if you
have the right price then they're
probably going to convert so you have a
really good chance of converting
somebody using longtail keywords so my
point here is if you're looking for
keywords to use focus on longer tail
don't focus on one or two keyword
phrases what it also does is brings
targeted traffic so even if somebody
doesn't convert hey they could be back
because it's exactly what they're
looking for and if you're focusing on
longer tail keywords like I just
mentioned stay away from the shorter
ones it's just easier to optimize your
page for SEO so remember SEO is a
two-pronged approach on page and off
page we talked about off page with
internal linking and back links on page
is all about making sure those keywords
you choose are integrated in with the
page you want to be found for and so if
you're using a longtail keyword it's
just easy to work that keyword in so it
enables easier onpage optimization okay
let's switch away from SEO to email
marketing so what's focus on email
marketing as a form or method of driving
traffic to your website so email
marketing has been around a long time in
terms of digital marketing why because
it provides an effective way to convert
leads into sales why because you can
send personalized emails to a target
audience so when you send an email to
somebody on a regular basis you know who
that person is so what are you doing in
the email you're writing a specific
message to that person well email
marketing is the same thing except
you're just sending an email to a larger
group of people and when you send an
email to a larger group of people you're
still going to personalize the message
right you're not going to send a generic
email to 1,000 people okay nobody's
going to do that so make sure your
email's targeted and if it's targeted it
could be cost effective why because
sending large amounts of emails or let's
just say an email to a large amount of
people or a large group of people is
going to be cost effective it's not cost
per click you know it's not cost per
open okay so email usually depending on
the the email provider you're using
really is a flat fee so it just really
depends on how many emails you're
sending or how how many people you're
sending the email to as well so but
email generally tends to be more cost
effective than other forms of marketing
so look at the email content provider
you're using and just get a sense of
what they charge but if you look at it
and do a comparison email generally is
cheaper than say doing paper click
because with paperclick you're paying
for each click okay so that could be
expensive depending on the keyword
so email marking is also time saving
okay meaning it's a one-time thing and
done so once you send the email it's
just a matter of you know watching and
looking at the metrics and learning
what's going on so you don't make the
same mistakes again but it is time
conducive meaning you send out one email
and that's it with paperclick you're
constantly measuring and managing the
campaigns and it provides real-time
marketing so when you do send the email
more than likely majority of the people
on day one or the day you send the email
are going to be able to view it open it
click on some of the links and convert
so that's normally what happens in email
majority of the people open it on day
one and it kind of tails off from there
so think about it as real time so when
you send that email and if you have a
th000 people on your email recipient
list break it up send the first 500
first with a different subject line and
then you can see the data come in and if
you don't see the good results from the
subject line or the body of the email or
you know the page you're going to then
make adjustments before you send the
other email to the next 500 so that's a
great thing about emails you can break
up the email into two groups the first
group and then the second group with
different subject lines and you can
probably send them a little bit of time
apart that way you can learn from the
first email because with email you are
generally going to get results right
away okay within the first 24 hours set
that's a great thing about email okay so
the other thing about email it's less
intrusive so normally people who are
going to get the email are the ones who
sign up for the email so they're almost
expecting your email so when they get
your email again as long as you're not
sending an email on a daily basis
normally most companies send it monthly
or bi-weekly it's not going to be as
intrusive okay and then it also helps
build credibility increase visibility
and brand awareness meaning you're going
to build your brand in that email you're
going to put content in that email
that's going to show off your
credibility meaning you could put some
testimonials in the email you could put
some good affiliations you can put a
good article to an industry article you
just wrote so email is going to
inherently continue to build brand
awareness for you okay and it's an easy
way to track Roi so if you're e
e-commerce it's pretty clear you send
the email somebody opens it clicks on it
checks out and purchases is something
it's easily trackable because you could
track it right from that email so one
thing I want to say there is just if you
do send an email make sure you're
tracking that campaign and you want to
be able to use an analytics program like
Google analytics if you use Google
analytics you're going to be able to
track when you send the email who clicks
on it and who converts so you want to be
able to measure an Roi for these emails
and you can and that's the beauty of
email marketing okay let's move away
from email marketing to webinars so
webinars great method for Effective
social media promotion it's a great way
to bring traffic to your website so why
do we recommend webinars well because it
provides direct content contact within
your target group what do we mean by
contact with your target group well
you're going to host a webinar and
you're going to invite this targeted
group of people who are interested in
your product or service so if you have a
Facebook Community you can do a Facebook
live event or you could do a YouTube or
you know you can even set up a webinar
on another platform but promote it on
social media and if you're promoting
something on social media you're
probably promoting it to people who are
already following you or like you and so
that's what we mean by direct contact
with your target group so you're you're
going to be able to create a webinar and
talk directly to that group and that's
going to help build brand awareness and
credibility and the great thing about
webinars is you don't need some fancy
software I mean I'm talking to you on a
webinar right now and so webinars are
free all you need is a video camera and
a recorder that's all and that's all
built in with software so there's plenty
of software out there that allows you
just to do a webinar really quick and
easy there's lots of opportunities in
software so and a lot of them are very
cost effective so if you want to build
uh create a webinar you can do that by
spending very little money and webinars
again allow you to talk to your targeted
group your community maybe prospective
clients it helps build credibility and
in effect Drive traffic to your website
and when somebody does attend a webinar
they're likely going to be highly
engaged because you're inviting them
they're going to opt into the webinar
and the great thing about webinars is
even if they don't attend the webinar
the day you have it it's going to be
recorded so they can always go back and
watch it so whoever watches the webinar
is going to be engaged because is going
to be a topic they're interested in and
then users are likely to become
prospective customers so having a
webinar talking about something
inherently interesting to maybe a larger
group of people you can promote that on
social media and potentially get
prospective customers to sign up and
watch the webinar and if you do they're
going to be engaged and then take the
next step oh I like what this guy this
person has to say they seem to be
credible I like their personal ity I
like their brand I like their product
I'm going to go check their web out
their website okay so webinars allow you
to kind of pull in more people as well
as just your community because you can
promote the webinar and you can promote
it in advance and you can leverage
social media for that okay so something
related to webinars incorporating video
content so videos have been proven to be
a really good way to attract new
visitors and it just it makes your
website very engaging when you have
videos on your website as well so if you
create video you have an opportunity to
post it on various video platforms like
YouTube or vomo okay there's plenty of
video platforms out there or just
embedded in a blog post or embedded in a
Facebook post or a tweet okay so you can
do a lot with video and having video on
your site is going to increase
engagement okay when you increase
engagement good things happen that's
going to lead to increased conversions
in sales or or Roi or just like we
mentioned the webinar can help build
trust with your audience so even that
webinar you could post on your website
so you want people to engage by watching
this video they watch the video they're
going to gain trust in you because
you're talking directly to that person
that user that audience that visitor to
your website and when you get build
trust it's going to increase engagement
and that's the beauty of video unlike
text or imagery videos really do engage
with the audience and so the more video
you can do the better off you are
because again you can leverage social to
draw attention to your brand and product
and service and then you can have that
video on your website to increase
engagement which in turn increases
conversions and sales and improves Roi
so always think video there's plenty of
video software out there that you can
leverage and the great thing about video
to is hey most people are using mobile
phones these days smartphones and so
video works just as well on mobile as it
does on desktop so keep that in mind you
know video is going to be engaging
regardless of what device somebody uses
and then of course if they're watching
the video on Facebook or YouTube then it
chances are they're going to share that
particular video which is going to bode
well for your brand and traffic okay so
video if somebody likes a video it's
very easy to share video especially from
a mobile phone so YouTube just makes it
so easy to share or like or subscribe to
a channel it just it becomes that much
easier things can go viral and Chan of
them going viral with video are going to
be greater okay so other ways to drive
traffic to your website is submit your
content to content aggregators so what's
a Content aggregator well a Content
aggregator is like Reddit that provides
a great platform for you to post your
content so that's what a Content
aggregator is really a site like Reddit
or medium or Kora where you could post
content to a large number of people okay
so with Reddit people are either going
to up vote it or down vote it so the
more up votes you get or thumbs up or
likes or people who encourage that
content the more of a chance it has to
be found and so first thing out of the
gate if you do provide content to a
Content aggregator like Reddit make sure
it's good quality content that's
interesting and that should be a case
the case across the board whether it's a
a social post or blog post make sure the
content's unique professional and
interesting and then if you do say put
something on medium or you do put
something on Kora and it is professional
and interesting and thought-provoking
then people are going to react to it and
then that again could lead to traffic
but even if it doesn't lead to traffic
it helps build brand awareness so if you
have content just like videos leverage
it put the content out there okay when
you put content out there it's only
going to especially if it's good content
put it's going to put you in a good
light so don't be afraid to share your
content on the likes of Reddit or medium
or core or some of these other content
aggregator websites because good things
are only going to happen and again
referral traffic SEO brand awareness
conversions so all these are inherent
benefits of just sharing your content
okay and then finally we want to learn
from anal analytics okay so what do we
mean learning from analytics so there
plenty of analytics platforms out there
one of the most popular is Google
analytics so you want to make sure
you're tracking traffic on your site
with Google analytics so all you have to
do is just go to Google analytics via
search sign up add the analytics code to
your website and waa they're doing all
the heavy lifting they're going to track
traffic coming to your website and not
only they going to track traffic but
they're going to tell you how that
traffic engaged and and so the benefits
of it Google analytics is hey you could
figure out where users are coming from
are they coming from that email campaign
that I sent out to a th people are they
coming from YouTube based on that video
I posted or are they coming from Reddit
based on the content I just posted there
or are they coming from organic search
it so Google analytics can help us
understand how much traffic we're
getting from organic search so it'll
help us measure our SEO efforts and then
with Google analytics you can segment so
we could segment by mobile we can
segment by desktop returning user new
user by campaign by Page by Language by
city by region I mean there's so many
ways in which to segment your audience
and segmenting simply is breaking up the
entire group of people who come to your
website into different segments based on
what you want to see so if you want to
look at you know females between the
ages of 18 to 24 who come from mobile
via organic search that's a segment and
you can look at that information in
analytics if that's your target audience
then you could see how they're
performing okay so an there are a lot of
benefits to Google analytics definitely
want to take advantage of segmenting in
Google analytics you could look at your
competition so there's a benchmarking
report the great thing about Google
analytics you can also look at content
and how your content's performing once
somebody lands on your website are they
what page are they spending time on what
page are they engaging on the most okay
what pages have the highest bounce rate
or the lowest time on page so you can
really determine what pages work best
and then of course the end result in
analyzing all this data is you want to
be able to f- tune your website so take
advantage of the data that Google
analytics or any other analytics
platform is given you by learning once
you learn what's going on with your
website you can make adjust ments to
your website to improve user experience
okay so we went over a lot of different
ways to drive traffic okay you can
incorporate all this to your website
immediately so if you are looking to
grab a successful career in digital
marketing and learn search engine
optimization simply learn has got you
covered with a wide range of topn
digital marketing courses these courses
make you skilled in SEO content
marketing PPC social media marketing and
much more with hands-on experience in
the tools like Google analytics Keyword
Planner Sim rush and there's a huge list
on the board however one year of
experience is preferred to enroll in
these courses find the course Link in
the description box let's talk about
that keyword research for a website with
shoes and and it doesn't really matter
what particular product you have if you
need to rank number one on Google it all
starts with the keywords as I mentioned
before and so so in this example if you
have a website where you sell shoes for
kids you're going to want to be found
for certain keywords so the obvious
keyword here would be shoes for kids
well every keyw that you target has
search volume associated with it so that
means when we talk about search volume
we're talking about how many people on
average type in that keyword or related
keyword on google.com or Google search
and and there's always an average number
of searches associated with every
keyword and we call that search volume
how much search volume so obviously if
we're going to Target a keyword we want
to have as much volume as possible
however there's always going to be
competition for those keywords meaning
there's always going to be other
websites who want to rank number one on
Google for the same keywords and we call
that competition or difficulty so for
every keyword you're going to have
volume and you're going to have
competition ition or difficulty and the
difficulty ranges as well depending on
the tool you use and we'll get into that
in a minute but search volume is how
much on average people are typing in
that keyword or close variance of that
keyword and the difficulty is measured
in terms of how many other websites are
trying to rank for the same keyword and
so ideally when it comes to keyword
research we want to find that nice
balance we want high volume and we want
low competition but at the same time we
want to focus on keywords that are
highly relevant to our business so if
we're selling shoes for kids and shoes
for kids is highly relevant has high
volume and low competition then that's a
keyword we want to Target so we always
want to focus in on those three areas so
there's always a tradeoff with keywords
so shoes for kids might have high volume
but also might have high competition or
difficulty if we look for another
keyword that's just as relevant for
example shoes for children it may still
have high search volume but the
competition or the difficulty may be
lower and if that's the case then that
may be a better keyword for us to Target
instead of something highly competitive
like shoes for kids we can focus on
another relevant keyword like shoes for
children with just as much volume and
lower competition and the reason why we
want lower competition is because we
want to be able to rank for that keyword
so the higher the competition the harder
it is for us to rank number one on
Google for that keyword and so the whole
idea Beyond keyword research is
analyzing and choosing the best keywords
so we want to identify a list of
keywords that are always relevant we
want to choose the keyword that your
competitors are ranking for and we want
to use thirdparty tools to choose
keywords to identify which keywords have
low competition and what keywords have
high search volume so one thing to take
into consideration when you're doing
keyword research is that the longer the
keyword phrase or in other words
longtail keywords or keywords with three
keywords in the phrase or more you're
going to always have less competition
but there's always a tradeoff with
longtail keywords meaning the longer the
keyword phrase there's going to be less
volume but the trade-off is less
competition and so what we want to do is
we want to brainstorm some ideas and
find those relevant keywords so let's
look at an example here so if we go to
Google ads so Google ads has a tool
called Keyword Planner and let's just
say I have a a website where I'm selling
dried figs and if I'm selling dried figs
I want people to buy these dried figs
however in order to attract them I want
to be able to show them that hey we have
a a bunch of recipes and if I show you a
bunch of recipes where you can use dried
figs maybe you'll buy these dried figs
to using these recipes and so we're
going to look for key wordss related to
bread recipes because if we can optimize
for our recipes page for bread then that
will attract an audience who wants to
make bread and use dried figs with those
bread recipes so that's the example I'm
going to give here and so if I look at
the Keyword Planner in Google ads if I
just type in bread recipes what Google
is going to do is they're going to give
me an average monthly search volume so I
can see the average monthly search
volume here is 60,500 and so in order to
do keyword research what I would
recommend is keep a spreadsheet and so
the idea behind the spreadsheet is to
document the volume and the competition
you're getting for certain keywords so
if I go into a spreadsheet here my theme
of keywords is bread recipes my keyword
is bread recipes and my volume therefore
is going to be 60,500 however if I go
back into Google's Keyword Planner
Google's telling me the competition is
low so that's great I want high volume I
want low competition but how low is low
so we want to be careful so if we're
going to put in numbers into a
spreadsheet we want to figure out what
that competition really is for the
keyword recipes so if I go to Google and
just type in bread recipes I'm going to
be able to see
771 billion results for the keyword
bread recipes now is 771 billion are
real competition maybe maybe not what we
want to do is put in a syntax and we
want to put in the syntax all in title
and then colon space and then our
keyword and the reason why we do that in
search is because we want to be able to
ident identify the true competitive
number or the true number of websites
who are trying to rank for bread recipes
and if we put in the syntax all entitle
colon and then our keyword bread recipes
we'll be able to see that there are
$998,000 results that's a lot lower than
771 billion so that means that
998,199 in the title tag and the title
tag is what shows up in the search
engine results and so if I look down and
scroll down here I can see bread recipes
on every one of these title tags so
title tag is an important element to
rank number one on Google and we'll talk
about that in a few minutes but if we
understand that there are
998,199 trying to rank number one on
Google for that keyword and therefore
those are the websites we need to jump
over in order for our website to rank
number one on Google and so therefore
I'm going to put in 998,199
[Music]
th000 then my Kei or keyword effective
index or in other words the ratio of
volume to competition is 6% so that's
nothing more than volume divided by
competition so that tells me that my Kei
or my ratio between volume competition
is 6% so remember we want more volume
than we want competition so anytime you
do a keyword research you're going to
find a number of different relevant
keywords so if I go back into Google's
key Keyword Planner if I typed in bread
recipes you could see that Google is
going to give me a number of different
keywords related to bread recipes let's
just say I have another keyword that I
want to think about optimizing for being
ranked on Google for and that's banana
bread recipe very similar keyword as
bread recipes except it's a little
longer tail now if I type in banana
bread recipe in Google's Keyword Planner
now I can see the average monthly search
volume has actually gone up it's
368,000 I can also see the competition
is low so those are good signs so now I
can see 368,000 I'm going to go ahead
and put that in my spreadsheet now I'm
going to go into Google I'm going to put
in my syntax all in title I'm going to
put in banana bread recipe I'm going to
hit enter and now I can see I have
233,000 results with the keyword banana
bread recipe in the title tag so if I
look at the title tags I can see banana
bread recipe banana bread recipe banana
bread recipe on all the listings in the
Google search results so that tells me I
have 233,000 results that I have to jump
over in order to rank number one on
Google so I'm going to put 233,000 in my
spreadsheet now I can see my Kei or my
volume to competition ratio is 157
158% and so to me that's a lot better
number to work with or in other words
that's a lot better keyword because it's
just as relevant and it has a higher
ratio of volume to competition so
therefore banana bread recipe is going
to be a better keyword to optimize for
in order to rank number one on Google so
that's the whole idea behind keyword
research you want to brainstorm ideas
there are plenty of tools out there so
the tool I recommend is Google ads
Keyword Planner Google's going to give
you how much search volume they're going
to tell you the competition but then
you're going to go into Google search
you're going to use the syntax all in
title to get a more accurate read on the
actual competitive number and so to find
out how keywords that your competitors
are ranking for you can use those
keyword tools that I mentioned another
tool that I use is Miles so MZ if you go
to moz.com they have a tool called
keyword Explorer so if we just type in
the keyword for example bread recipes
it's going to be able to tell us how
much volume and the difficulty so you
can use other tools at your disposal
figure out the volume and the difficulty
there are plenty of tools out there but
the one thing I would just make sure is
you use everything at your disposal so
you can use social media to find the
most shared article for a particular
topic or keyword like bread recipes you
could check other platforms that have a
lot of shared content like readin and
Kora where you can ask people about
certain topics using keywords to figure
out how much competition or volume there
might be you could stay up to date on
industry news to get an idea of what
types of keywords are trending but when
it comes to keywords and keyword
research remember for every web page
page we want to be able to pick two
keywords we want a primary and secondary
keyword so when we do keyword research
and we enter all our keywords into our
spreadsheet we want to be able to have a
number of different keywords in this
case we're focusing on the theme bread
recipes we want to have different
keywords because we want to be able to
choose a primary keyword and a secondary
keyword because we want to be able to
focus on multiple keywords for each page
because we don't want to put necessarily
all our eggs in one basket meaning we
won't want to put all our emphasis just
on one keyword to rank for we want
multiple keywords to try and rank for so
the primary keyword can to find the
nature of our business the secondary
keyword could be just highly relevant to
our keyword at the end of the day we
want to choose multiple keywords to try
and rank on Google for that page so for
example we have a Blog and we're using
ice cream recipes and we're blogging
about ice cream recipes we can have a
primary keyword that is about ice cream
recipes or homemade ice cream recipes
we're going to always want to find out
what the volume in the competition is
our secondary keyword could be built
around other similar keywords like
lowfat ice cream recipes or fat-free ice
cream recipes or lowfat homemade ice
cream recipes those are complimentary
keywords just like our bread recipes and
bnana bread recipe so one thing we want
to do when we do keyword research is we
want to be able to Target one keyword
per content when you can Target many we
want to be able to Target multiple
keywords not necessarily Target one
keyword and so we want to be able to
Cluster keywords so we don't want to
Target just one we want to Target
multiple keywords per page and when we
talk about clustering if we go back to
our keyword research what we're doing is
we're clustering a bunch of keywords
under the theme bread recipes and so by
looking at the volume looking at the
competition looking at the Kei we can
choose different keywords for our page
and that's what we mean by clustering we
want to Cluster keywords into a Content
theme so why Target only one keyword per
content when we can Target many because
we don't want to put all our eggs in one
basket we don't want to Target just one
keyword we want to Target taret many and
so that means clustering your keywords
into a theme and choosing multiple
keywords for that particular page and
when we do that we have a better
opportunity to rank high on Google
Search and the whole idea behind ranking
high on Google Search is we can get the
volume so if we know we're ranked number
one on Google search for bread recipes
or banana bread recipe we know we stand
a chance of getting a majority
of the volume associated with that
keyword and if we can get the volume and
get the traffic then we can get the
conversions so let's move on to high
quality content and talk about the
impact content has on your ability to
get your website ranked number one on
Google so let's just say you have
content on your website and the content
is ranking on you know page four of
Google and and it's that blog with ice
cream recipes and if it's just content
for the sake of content is not really
informative then it's not necessarily
going to get good engagement in the eyes
of Google you know they want to rank
content that's very informative it's
very fresh it's exciting to read it's
interesting it's going to have good
engagement so if it's a recipe or an
article about any topic if it's the
content is just not informative then
you're not going to get good engagement
and when you don't get good engagement
if people don't stay on the site to
engage in the content and they just
leave the website after Ling on the page
causing a bounce then the content is
just going to continue to fall down the
rankings and we want to prevent that we
want to move up the rankings we want to
be number one on Google we don't
necessarily want to fall in the rankings
for our content so content is a key
driver in being able to rank number one
on Google Google so if the content is on
page n what can we do well we want to be
able to you know take that content and
do something with it we feel like we did
write engaging content so let's go ahead
and share it on social media and to me
social media is a good platform to share
your content because on social media
platforms like Facebook for example
you're building a community on that
platform that Community is already
interested in your content so if you're
sharing an
recipe especially in the summertime and
you're engaging with your community on
that platform then the likelihood of
that community on that platform is going
to increase engagement increased
engagement will send social signals to
the search engine that says hey this
content is good quality likewise for any
other platform most social media
platforms have engagement metrics and
those engagement metrics pass signals is
it good is it not good do we like this
content are we giving it a thumbs up are
we going to want to follow it are we
going to want to share it and so if you
share content that you feels engaging on
social platforms then it's going to be
engaging and it's likely going to cause
an increase in engagement for example a
decrease in balances and once you share
that quality content then the likelihood
of it moving up the rankings even as far
as number one on Google is going to be
greater so you always want to start out
writing good quality content so let's
talk about good quality content because
Google does take content seriously they
do take into account what other people
think of that content so high quality
content is an important factor so how to
create good content that's always the
question so let's talk about some best
practices here remember in the last
segment we talked about keyword research
so we want to perform good keyword
research why because we want to choose
keywords remember we're choosing
multiple keywords per page one keyword
could be related to our brand one
keyword could be related to the content
but another keyword could be related to
a user's intent like recipes if you
recall the example we use with bread
recipes maybe somebody's looking to type
in a keyword that says how do I make you
know a bread or how do I make a specific
type of bread or how do I make banana
bread or what's the best recipe for
banana bread they're question related
and we want to be able to answer those
questions so that's where choosing those
right key wordss that's going to respond
to a user's intent so starts with
choosing the right keywords so remember
we talked about a number of different
tools when we talked about keyword
research so there's a research tool that
you can use called phrase. iio and that
will help you do quick research on you
know keyword and Trends and whatnot so
if you know about a research tool that
you use for keyword research then drop
us a comment below I'd be interested in
getting your comments about keyword
research and what research tools are out
there so if you know something better
than phrase. drop a comment below and
we'd be interested in getting your
perspective so keyword research is key
but creating content that fulfills users
requirements so answering those
questions if it's a recipe we want to
answer that question if it's directions
we want to answer that question if they
don't know how to do something we want
to answer that question and that's the
whole idea behind content content is not
just to fill a page it's to really
fulfill users requirements that's when
you get good engagement so if somebody's
typing in something on Google and
they're looking for an answer your
content should answer that question but
we also want to make the content
readable so in other words you know
write for your audience don't impress
anybody with with very high vocabulary
type words that somebody doesn't
necessarily know the meaning of don't
use jargon don't use a street language
for example use everyday common language
that's just easily digestible when your
audience is reading and then we want to
keep that content organized and so when
we mean organized we want to use headers
and subheaders you know break your
content into paragraphs keep the flow
organized if we can keep the flow
organized it's going to be easier for
somebody to read and then it's okay to
add resources especially resources from
credible sites so if you can incorporate
those resources in there then it's just
going to add The credibility to your
content let the audience know that hey
I've done my research on this topic and
this is what this person has to say
about it this person who seems to be
credible okay so it only adds value to
your content so these are all tips to
Remember When creating content and then
the one important tip here is we want to
use white hat techniques and when we say
white hat techniques that means you know
if we've chosen keywords that are going
to answer somebody's question we don't
want to stuff those keywords into the
content we want the content to be
naturally written so when we say op for
white heck uh techniques that's what we
mean write the content naturally keep it
organized keep it readable include third
party sources and make sure it answers a
question so there are different types
content so there's content where you
just write words it's all text based you
could also use an infographic
infrographic is simply just a graphic
that visualizes exactly what you're
trying to explain for example if we want
to write an article about how to write
good engaging content we don't
necessarily have to write all that out
as a text we can create an infographic
so for example here's an infographic on
20 effective ways to basically not bore
your readers but write engaging content
so you could see this is an infographic
it's all graphically laid out so
infographics tend to be easier to
understand because they're visual
they're easy for the end user to
comprehend because there's generally no
jargon it's usually images that are
portraying the point of what you're
trying to get across and so it tends to
break it up the monotony of just text
it's more visually appealing and it's
laid out and organized so you can see
this infographic has 20 different steps
or rules and they lay those out all here
in this infographic and the great thing
I like about infographics is you could
you could share them on social media you
can re-engage them as a post you can
save them on really any social platform
so infographics tend to tell a better
story versus say just writing text you
can use video and images so you don't
necessarily have to lay it all out in an
infographic you can certainly insert a
video or an image into your content
especially if it's a blog post if it's a
blog post then sometimes video and
images on its own tell the story you
don't necessarily need text to go ahead
and tell your story a video or an image
as they say tells a thousand words and
so images videos are great to use in a
blog post so using different forms of
content you know you always want to
review your content when a user dwells
on your web page for a longer time
Google will tend to think okay this
person's engaged so we're going to rank
that favorably so if you're using
infographics videos and images then the
chances of somebody being more engaged
are going to increase versus just text
that's not well organized and written
out in a way that somebody doesn't
necessarily understand so be creative in
the types of content you use so longer
engaging content tends to bode well with
search engines so this is according to
HubSpot so the more word count you use
the more words you use the chances of
you ranking higher are going to be
better just take into account best
practices you want to maybe break up the
content with an image organize it make
make it engaging use headers so it's not
necessarily just words it's the words
and how those words are written how
they're structured the types of keyw
you're using how you're engaging with
your audience there's a lot of factors
again there best practices we just went
over but the key is you know if you have
longer more engaging content then it's
going to bode better for you on search
engines so couple of steps to create
high quality content so you want to
begin with a comprehensive introduction
so always introduce your content
remember the content should be relevant
to the keyword so if you're choosing
keywords in your keyword research think
about answering that question if
somebody's typing in bread recipes maybe
they're looking for banana bread recipes
how to make the best banana bread or how
to make banana bread using dried figs we
want to be able to align our content
with that keyword naturally you want to
create a title that's Worthy that's
click worthy so remember if you're in
Google search and you're doing search
for something simple like bread recipes
we want to some make something that's
going to be you know gauging for
somebody to click on like easy perfect
yeast bread or easy crusty French bread
or something that's going to be engaging
you know the best bread recipes or how
to make the best homemade bread you know
something that's going to draw
somebody's attention to the title of
that blog post so we want to include LSI
keywords so what I mean by LSI keywords
in your content we mean you know
longtail keywords make it natural
headings and subheadings should consist
of keywords and variants so if you're
writing headers and subheaders include
the keyword in there and that way the
the content always stays relevant to the
audience okay shorten your sentences and
paragraphs so don't write long
paragraphs remember we want to break
this up we want to make it easy for the
end user to read and we want to always
put internal links on our blog post why
because if we have internal links then
if we have a link from one blog post to
another blog post or say our blog post
to an internal page on our website we
want to make sure that it's relevant
content that way if somebody's reading
something and you have an internal link
let's just say from a bread recipes page
to a banana bread recipe page then they
may find it interesting click on that
link and go to the banana bread recipes
page so it's keeping somebody engaged on
your website so putting in internal
linking will help keep the the end user
engaged because you're offering up links
that's relevant to the content you
always want to break up that content
with images okay we want to use alt tags
meaning we want to pen the image with
text so that way if the image doesn't
look load then at least the alt text
will load so we can incorporate call out
boxes and more importantly we want to
update our content regularly so we
always want to get the best recipe out
there if it's banana bread or different
ways to create banana bread or always
just coming up with ways to update the
content so we want to keep our content
our blog post fresh and then we want to
include a CTA call to action if we
include a call to action then that's
going going to keep somebody engaged and
have them act on your content so these
are steps to creating highquality
content and so let's look at an example
here and this is a 3month Old Post on
BuzzFeed and it's it's 21 pictures that
will restore your faith in humanity so
it has a lot of likes a lot of tweaks
and that means it's engaged people are
engaged when reading that and so if we
go and look at it as an example we could
see it in a buzzfeed here pictures that
will restore your faith in humanity so
this was written back in 2012 again a
lot of Engagement but if we look at it
we can see immediately that it's taking
into account third party sources it's
got some content it's got images it's
being broken up by images we could see
there's call to actions on there in the
form of social so people can go ahead
and go ahead and share it if they like
it okay it includes video
includes images third party sources so
it's a good post because listen you know
it's engaging content it's probably
answering somebody's question about
humanity and we could see clearly that
look you know there's a lot of different
examples here from a lot of different
sources and we could take action on this
content so not just video not just
images but text as well and so it's very
engaging answers questions takes into
account the different types of content
available
so this is a good post in that regard so
content updated regularly it's engaging
and it includes sources from high
Authority websites some dos and don'ts
on the content so take into account the
best practices I mentioned about
creating high quality content okay
answer those questions that the end user
wants to hear you know CU that likely is
going to be their search and so you want
to be able to respond to the end user
that's part of creating high quality
content different types of content I.E
in the form of infographics or videos or
text or images you can add images from
public domain sites you can be relatable
and use examples to clarify points just
like the BuzzFeed article simplify
complex words don't use sophisticated
language talk to your audience as if you
they were standing right in front of you
and use bullet points to exemplify your
examples your points so some dud the
don'ts obviously don't lift content we
don't want to lift content from another
website so that's plagiarism so we want
to have our own unique content we also
don't want to take images from other
websites and so if you do happen to find
an image that works for your post and
it's on somebody else's website ideally
that's not a good situation but if you
do happen to do that then always give
credit to the website Okay so so if you
took it from xyz.com credit xyz.com for
the image and even put a link back but
ideally you don't want to take images
from other websites just as much as you
don't want to take copy you don't want
to take images use your own imagery and
content but if you don't have imagery
then you can always go to stock
photography there are plenty of websites
out there where you can sign up for a
subscription like uh Adobe stock images
as an example you can sign up for an
account and in some cases you can sign
up for a free account and use stock
imagery okay don't give less information
to your audience give your audience what
they deserve which is the information
they're looking for they're looking for
the best banana bread recipes give them
the best banana bread recipes
incorporate your own images break it up
with titles give them a good quality
piece of content that they're going to
be able to engage with and so if you put
long paragraphs s in your content then
it's going to be less engaging so try to
avoid those long paragraphs remember
shorten up the paragraphs keep the
language simple add in images answer
those questions use third party credible
sources but write it in your own words
and you should be on your way to
creating good quality content okay so
now that we've talked about high quality
content in order to get your pages
ranked high on Google search let's turn
our attention to optimizing onpage
elements and discuss some website level
factors that are both going to help you
rank high on Google search so let's just
do an overview of what we're talking
about when we talk about onpage elements
and website level factors so optimizing
on page elements include a number of
different things but primarily we're
going to focus in on meta tags also
known as meta description tags header
tags also known as title tags and URLs
so those are just some of the on page
elements we want to be able to optimize
using relevant keywords in order to rank
high on Google search we also want to
take a look at some website factors that
will affect our ranking on Google search
they include website architecture having
a secure website having a site map and
taking a look at page speed so all of
those are some of the website factors we
need to take into account in order to
rank high on Google search so title tag
and meta description together are
considered metat tags so both play an
important role in ranking high on Google
so we want to be able to write unique
title and descriptions for each page on
our website when I say unique that means
a title and The Meta description need to
be different for every page on the
website and so if you're not quite sure
what a title tag and a meta description
tag is if you go to search and just type
in any particular search query the title
tag is what's going to show up here and
bold and then the description is going
to show up below it below the URL and
that's going to describe the page so
both of these meta tags are important
because it describes what your page is
all about and that's what Google uses in
the search results pages so we want to
be able to pay attention to the length
of our meta tags so if we go back to our
search results Pages met title tags are
generally 6065 characters metad
description tags are generally 160
characters so anything really longer
than that then what's going to happen is
the meta description tag or the title
tag will get trunk headed and so if we
look here for example we can see all of
the title tags here fit the 65 character
limit but if you run over the character
count on meta description then Google is
going to truncate the copy so you want
to stay within your parameters in order
to avoid getting your content truncated
and so the other thing when we're
writing title meta description tags we
want to minimize keyword repetition so
if we're optimizing for keyword we don't
want to necessarily just plug that
keyword into the title tag and meta
description multiple times we want to
make sure our title tags and meta
descriptions are naturally written so if
somebody's typing for banana bread
recipe with dried fix you know we want
to have a nice title tag and a this
description that is going to get
somebody to respond uh based on their
need and so we definitely want to avoid
keyword repetition but we want to be
able to use that keyword in the title
tag because if you remember from the
earlier segment when we did the all in
title syntax to find out exactly how
many competitors were using that
particular keyword well we obviously
want to use that keyword in the title
tag because again the title tag is an
important factor when it comes to search
engine results so we want to use the
keyword but we want to avoid stuffing or
using it repetitively in our title tag
and our meta description we want the
title tag and The Meta description to
describe the page sound natural but also
be engaging because the point point is
we want people to click on our link and
go to our website from search engines so
title tags with numbers tend to result
in higher click the rates this is
according to mods so for example if you
just put in a title tag that says learn
digital marketing well that may work but
if you put a number in there like five
easy ways to learn digital marketing
that might get somebody to click on your
link and go to your website so having
question questions in your metax can
also increase your click theate for
example if you just put learn the
importance of first page rankings not
too bad but they again generic but if
you put it into the form of a question
how to rank number one on Google it's
more action oriented it's going to get
somebody to resonate with a question
that they have and that may be their
query how to rank number one on Google
and so these techniques will help you
get higher clicky rates and so according
to back Linko title tag with a keyword
can improve site ranking so remember we
want to include that keyword in the
title tag even though we only have 65
characters we want to include that
keyword but we want to avoid stuffing
the keyword in there we want to again
make the title tag action oriented maybe
with a number maybe as a question with
the keyword in there once naturally not
easy to do but that's the beauty of SEO
if you can follow these best practices
and write a good title tag then the
chances of you improving in your search
results are going to be greater so
having only one H1 tag in your post is
going to be good so remember when
somebody clicks on a link so let's just
say they do find a title tag engaging
and they click on this this link here
and they go to that website you know you
want to start out with having that
particular H1 tag because the H1 tag
especially with the keyword in it is
going to signal to Google hey we're
organizing our page and because it's an
H1 tag it's important we're structuring
the page according to best practices so
having only one H1 tag in your post is
definitely helpful having multiple tags
H tags in your post help organize the
page a lot better so we want to add that
targeted keyword in that tag and your
header tag should be relevant the
content so if we go back to our example
of the using dried figs with banana
breads well the title says California
fig banana bread and remember the last
segment when we're talking about high
quality content we'll look no further
than including a video into our content
so not only will this video help keep
the engagement high but it breaks up the
monotony of the page and it's from a
third party source so it adds
credibility to the page so adding a
video
based on the last segment of high
quality content definitely helps with
ranking high on Google search so
following hierarchal structure that
means putting those H tags in there H2
tags help break up the content and we
want to avoid repetition of H1 tags on
your different web pages of your site
meaning don't just put the same H1 tag
with the same keyword in it and keeping
it Blas we want to make those H1 tags
exciting to read but also used
appropriately to break up the content so
remember all white hat techniques we
want to avoid hidden text we want to
avoid stuffing keywords we want things
to be natural we don't want things to be
forced and your H1 tag should be 20 to
70 characters don't make long H1 tags so
if we go back to our page example a
short sweet tag here California fig
banana bread it's relevant to the
content it's short sweet it breaks up
the monotony of the content and more
importantly again any content you have
on the page should always answer the
user's intent remember people are using
search to answer questions find
information our content should be able
to answer that for them so according to
John mher Senior Web Master Trends
Analyst at Google header tags would
definitely help Google for rankings and
the search results so we want to use
header tags so when it comes to URLs we
want to use hyphens and avoid
underscores so if we look at this URL
here this uses hyphens fig and banana
bread so it's all broken up with hyphens
that's the best practice remember
canonical URLs a canonical URL signals
to Google this is the original content
so we want to use original content and
if you have multiple sources of content
out there on say different websites we
want to use a canonical tag to signal to
Google this is the original content
please Index this content and not
doesn't hurt to use a favicon in url
meaning a small icon it helps to break
up the monotony and help your URL stand
out we can add targeted keywords in the
URL so again looking at the URL here I
can see we're using targeted keyword as
part of the URL structure and banana
bread and notice the H1 tab is fig
banana bread so it's all consistent and
it flows naturally URLs that are no
longer existing then we want to be able
to set up a redirect for those URLs
meaning a 301 redirect is a server
response for Google that says Hey Google
this page is no longer available but it
we permanently redirected it to this
page which is now available so that's
what a 301 redirect does it helps signal
to Google and all the other search
engines that if the page is no longer
there that's fine you're just going to
go to this page this is the page that's
permanently there now and another thing
we want to do here is if you have mobile
URLs you want to include those in the
sitemap and we're going to hit on that
in just a minute but all urls should be
mobile friendly as well as desktop
friendly meaning take into account this
best practices keep your url short use
hyphens put the keyword in that URL and
make make it easy to understand want to
avoid capital letters in the URLs the
URLs are case sensitive so go lowercase
you should always go lowercase on the
URL readable URLs again the rule of
thumb here is if you understand what the
URL is then Google's going to understand
what the URL is so the shorter the URL
the easier it is to read the easier it
is to read the better chance you have to
rank high on Google search so according
to backlink to URLs that are shorter
definitely definitely help you rank so
we want to be able to shorten those URLs
keep them short and sweet don't make
them long and unreadable so those are
some on optimized ways or on page
elements that help you optimize now we
want to look at some website level
factors that will help you optimize and
rank high on Google search so good site
structure provides better crawling for
search engine Bots and what do we mean
by that well we mean having your site
organized in a fashion that Google's
going to be able to find all the pages
so what do we mean by that create a
logical hierarchy structure so if you're
selling shoes you know you're going to
have a homepage break the structure up
into men's shoes women's shoes
Children's Shoes then under men's shoes
you could have it by brand it could be
Nike Puma Adidas on the women's side it
could be Nike Puma Adidas on the child
side it could be Nike Puma Adidas and so
you want to keep the structure flow in a
hierarchy so we want to balance the
amount of subcategories within each
category so the men's if it has Nike
Puma Adidas the women should have Nike
Puma Adidas and so you want to code your
site navigation and CSS or HTML meaning
we want to be able to use something that
Google is going to be able to index so
most sites are built in HTML and that's
what Google likes to index they like to
index something that they could take
back to their service
and then more importantly build a
comprehensive structure for internal
linking so internal links mean that if
you're on a site you should have natural
links pointing to other pages on your
website so to keep the flow going and we
don't want to have unnatural inbound
links you always want to have natural
internal links to keep the flow of the
user going from one page to the other so
here I could see as an example all the
ingredients in this recipe well this has
an internal link to another page on our
site and this happens to link to a page
where somebody can buy the ingredient so
it's a natural internal link so John DH
of Credo has claimed that one of the
biggest changes that he can make in
fixing the Credo website is architecture
so for example in Credo John dhy has
increased the organic sessions by 74% in
Pages by procession by 41% just by
changing the site architecture so you'd
be surprised by Chang changing the site
architecture what that will do to
engagement and so let's turn our
attention to secure versus non-secure so
what we mean by that is securing your
site we want to make it sure that
compliant with certain protocols and so
if we go back here we can see that this
particular site is compliant it is
secure https means it has a secure
license meaning the site is secure so
Google likes secure versus non secure so
non-secure would be HTTP so we want
https as our protocol and what that
means is just enabling SSL certificates
and that means when you enable an SSL
certificate that means your domain or
your protocol is going to be turned to
https so Google prefers sites that are
secure versus non-secure so if you use
hsts as a protocol that adds an extra
layer of security over over the https
and
hsts prevents cookie hijacking so adding
multiple layers of security always helps
in my opinion if you have an HTTP
website a non-secure website you should
look into buying an SSL certificate
getting your sites flipped over to
https because what's going to happen is
your url structure is going to change
when your url structure changes Google's
going to recognize that because is going
to index your site and when they index
your site they're going to see those
secure URLs and that's going to work
favorably in your favor and help you
rank higher on Google search so websites
using secure or
https have a higher chance of ranking
higher so https is a ranking signal
because Google indexes those pages so
let's also talk about site Maps so
sitemap is one of the most important
ways to improve your website ranking why
well because sit maps are a way to
organize all your URLs into one file so
we're basically going to a prioritize
all our web pages in a Sit map so if you
go to any particular website and you
type in sitemap XML you're likely going
to see all the pages on your website so
usually the site map is located in the
root directory so if I type in
sitemap.xml I'm going to be able to see
all the pages in my directory and I can
also prioritize them I can also alert
Google as to how often they change and
every page is going to have a date stamp
associated with it so Google can
actually see how often it changes so
remember we want our content to be
updated frequently so if content is not
updated frequently or it's not fresh
then Google's going to see that SI that
date stamp that last modification Dam so
we want to be able to make sure
content's updated fre frequently we want
to let Google know that we changed it
frequently and we want to be able to
prioritize our Pages let Google know hey
these pages are important to us so all
that can be set up in a sitemap we want
to be able to add canonical versions of
URLs in the sit map so we want to be
able to add all our original URLs in our
s map and so we always want to build
Dynamic URLs sit maps for larger
websites and what do I mean by Dynamic
URLs that means that if I look at this
side map and we're always adding content
let's just say in the form of a Blog
well guess what we want those pages to
be added to the sitemap as they're
published so as we add pages to the blog
or to the site then they should
automatically be added to the site map
and so in effect what's going to happen
is we're going to be able to see the
sitemap grow with more URLs when the
sitemap grows with more URLs then that
means then Google's going to index more
pages they're going to index more fresh
pages so they're going to be able to get
those pages that are just published
quicker so that's the whole idea behind
Dynamic sit Maps is we want to be able
to capture all the URLs just as they're
published and we want to be able to
maintain our s maps and so I would
always recommend a dynamic sit map but
you can always create your own sit map
just by going to a tool called XML sit
Maps so if I just type in XML sitemaps
into Google search here I can see XML
sit Maps generator and I can be able if
I have a small website just create a
free and simple sitemap on my own when
XML sit Maps creates it or your platform
creates a dynamic sit map either way the
sit map's going to sit in the root
directory and then what we want to do in
turn is let Google know where that sit
map is so in search console we want to
be able to submit the sitemap so you're
going to add the sitemap you're going to
let Google know where it is it should be
in the root directory and it should be
called sitemap.xml and when you do that
Google's going to be able to take those
URLs and index them so we could see we
submitted 528 URLs Google index 521 so
one thing about URLs here is when we
create a site map we're putting all your
URLs in there we do not add no index
URLs in your sitemap and what that means
is is that any URL we don't want Google
to index we're just going to exclude
from the sitemap okay so we want Google
to take all the URLs we want indexed and
put them in the sitemap so according to
edgy using sitemaps for SEO can increase
your websites visibility and help you
get indexed why because what you're in
fact doing is taking all your URLs that
you want index you're telling Google how
often they're modified you're telling
Google which ones are important and
you're submitting that to to Google and
so Google's going to be able to take all
these URLs quicker index them quicker
and when they're index quicker you can
get ranked quicker and when you get
ranked quicker you can get traffic
quicker so that's the whole idea behind
sit Maps so let's turn our attention to
page speed now so one of the last
factors for our website besides
architecture making it secure and adding
s Maps is you want to take a look at how
quick our Pages load here are some tips
in order to H optimize page speed
because ideally the quicker a page loads
the more engaged the user is going to be
if it takes a longer time for the page
to load all the elements of that page
then what's going to happen is the user
is going to get impatient maybe leave
the website all together or go to
another page and so we want to be able
to optimize images so any image that's
of large size in terms of megabytes we
want to be able to optimize that
compress the image so that's one way to
speak speed up page speed we want to use
a simple website design you know HTML
with CSS or cascading stylesheets just a
simple design with simple hierarchy and
website navigation structure so nothing
fancy nothing complex just a simple
website design with optimized images we
want to leverage browser caching and we
want to upgrade the server response time
meaning all your files are sitting on
the server so when somebody goes to a
web page the server is serving up all of
those files the images the text Etc and
so we want the server to respond as
quick as possible so when it comes to
page speed we can look at the factors
affecting page speed in Google analytics
so if I go to Google analytics and I go
under behavior and I go under sight
speed and I go to overview I'm going to
be able to see what my average load time
is for my site and ideally we want our p
pages to load as quick as possible so
that means anything under 4 seconds
anything 4 seconds or higher and it's
likely the end user is going to leave
the page there's a correlation be
between page load time and bounce rate
and so what Google actually does is give
you speed suggestions so if we do have a
page that loads slow we can just go to
speed suggestions in Google analytics
and we go to speed suggestions then
Google's going to be able to tell us hey
this particular page P load fast this
particular page load slow and if it
loaded slow why is it loading slow so
here we can see the homepage as example
is loaded on average of 7 Seconds well
if we look here they're going to give us
some suggestions so if I click on this
page speed suggestions it's going to
load a report and a tool called page
speed insights and basically what it's
then going to do after it's done running
is this going to tell me all the ways in
which I can optimize my page
not only for desktop but also for mobile
so here I can see for desktop or for
mobile I can look at some ways in which
I can optimize it to increase page speed
for example sizing my images properly
server response time reducing my server
response time avoiding multiple page
redirects so there's a lot of
opportunities that we can do to speed up
page low time and all that's found in
page speed inside ites and all that's
found within Google analytics so
remember optimizing code minimizing
redirects optimizing your images
upgrading your server respons all of
those are factors and so again you can
go into analytics page speed insights
and you could see exactly what Google is
recognizing as what's lowering or
slowing down your page load time so
Google takes site speed as one of the
most important ranking factors why
because they're going to rank page PES
not only with high quality content that
are relevant to the keyword queries but
they want those pages to have a good
user experience so if somebody clicks on
the page then the user should be able to
see that content fairly quickly and so
that's why it's such an important factor
so the quicker your pages load the
chances of you ranking higher are going
to be better so according to web
performance today Walmart as an example
experienced a decline in conversions so
what they did was looked at their page
speed
and when they looked at their page speed
you'd be surprised what that did just
increasing it from 1 to 4 seconds or
decreasing it basically increase
conversion so there's always going to be
a correlation between how quick a page
loads and how engaged the user is
because if it's users engaged they're
going to stay on the site and if they
stay on the site then their chances of
converting are going to be higher so
just even one to two seconds increase in
page low low time will make a world
difference in terms of Engagement and
conversions let's turn our attention to
offsite engagement so previously we
talked about onpage elements and website
factors that affect our rankings for
search results but we also need to turn
our attention away from our website
meaning what we do on our website and
turn our attention what we can do for
our website off our website and on to
other websites so that's offsite
engagement and so let's look at an
example so that ice cream recipes blog
so we did everything we possibly could
we updated The Meta tags the title tag
The Meta description we added H1 tags we
made sure the site architecture was
sound we submitted a site map we we made
sure the page load was good and fast so
we did all the things we were supposed
to do on our web page but we're still
not ranking well what do we need to do
well we need to turn our attention away
from our website into other websites we
call this offsite or off page SEO and we
need to basically generate links from
high quality sites back to our site so
if we've done everything we can on our
own website and we're still not ranking
where we want to be well then we need to
turn our attention to other websites and
so if we turn our attention to other
websites and other websites that are
relevant other websites that are of
quality other websites that have
High domain Authority then we're going
to see an increase in rankings so it's
just a matter of getting quality links
from quality websites that are relevant
that's what's going to move the needle
on search after we've taken care of all
the on page elements so more backlinks
from high domain Authority results in
higher rankings SEO is a combination
between what we do on our website
meaning optimizing ing the page and
making sure our website has good site
architecture and follows the best
practices in terms of site maps and Page
load then we need to turn our attention
to the backlinking to improve our domain
Authority so according to backlinko
analysis offsite engagement is one of
the most important elements for ranking
number one in Google so you can't just
focus your attention on updating the
title tag and making sure the pages load
fast you have to turn your attention as
well to getting back links from high
quality sites that's offsite engagement
and so gaining links back links from
multiple DS is vital it's vital because
they bring referring traffic to your
site they bring credibility to your site
but more importantly Google's going to
recognize the relationship between these
sites and your website and if these
sites that have back links or links
pointing to your site and if they're of
high high quality then we call that
passing link juice so it's going to
bring quality to you in terms of organic
search so if we look at an example if I
do a search for banana bread recipe
they're
241 billion results for banana bread
recipe Why did this particular page from
Simply Recipes rank number one well we
can turn our attention to M and MZ has a
report called link Explorer and so ma
link Explorer report helps us identify
our own page Authority our own domain
Authority and how many links we have
from other quality websites so if I put
that particular URL into link Explorer
and notice the URL here is short even
though it uses an underscore when it
should use a hyphen it's still rank
number one and why because off-page
elements help this page rank number one
why their page Authority out of 100 is
58 their domain Authority out of 100 is
82 and what does that mean well that
means that they have a lot of good links
from other domains of high quality they
have 824 linking domains to this one
domain they have 3600 inbound links and
to ranking for a lot of different
keywords so if we scroll down we're
going to be able to see kind of a break
out the quality of websites that are
linking to them so they have 19 domains
with a domain authority of 91 to 100
linking to them they have 15 domains
between the range of 81 and 90 so what
does that tell me between 15 and 19
that's 34 particular domains that are
very high quality linking to them and so
we could see the breakout of the linking
domains we could see the top file links
to the site and we could see the the
page Authority so the link explor report
gives us an overview of what pages are
linking to ours and it also gives us an
idea of what our own page Authority and
domain Authority are because domain
Authority and Page Authority both need
to be high in order for us to rank on
Google Search and in order for it to get
high we need links from high quality
sites so that's the whole idea behind
offside engagement so some of the
offside engagements are in influencer
marketing meaning is there somebody out
there on social who has a huge following
but not only do they have a huge
following but are they relevant to our
product for example usin B who's a
famous Sprinter if we're selling shoes
and we're selling Nike shoes maybe
Hussein Bol can reference us on Twitter
or Facebook that's influencer marketing
getting people to influencing people to
buy our product we can engage with
audiences on multiple social media
platforms like Facebook and Twitter
meaning if we're running a promotion on
those running shoes then we can promote
that on Facebook okay we can promote
that on Twitter we can also bookmark our
web page on popular bookmarking sites
like stumble upon we can also put our
content on discussion forums like Reddit
we can join High PR quality Q&A sites
excuse me and post answers to questions
related to our business like Kora
so we can engage in sharing our content
and answering questions so there's lots
of ways to get links to your website if
you have a blog post as an example you
can make sure that maybe that content is
shared on a similar blog post so you
have an ice cream recipe blog post well
maybe you can look at a dessert blog
post and share your content on that
particular blog post and and have a
backlink pointing from that blog post to
yours as an example and you can
reciprocate so the whole idea of content
is sharing the content but at the same
time of sharing it you're producing
backlinks and backlinks help domain
Authority so not only do it help domain
Authority but they improve the search
ranking so in Google's eyes the higher
your domain Authority hire the page
Authority in Google's eyes that means
your page is important it's credible and
we're going and improve it in the search
engine rankings it increases brand
visibility if we have our content on a
highly engageable website a highly
popular website or blog it's not it's
going to lift our brand visibility if we
have usin B who's very famous Sprinter
do some influenc in marketing for us
then that's going to increase our brand
visibility so anytime we can associate
with something that has some influence
or some clout or high domain Authority
then it's only going to increase our
brand awareness and visibility so again
it's going to increase our domain
Authority because of the association of
passing linked use from one domain to
another it's going to then as a result
increase referral traffic because if
we're on a high quality website that
gets a lot of traffic then the chances
of some of that traffic going our s's
going to be great and again it improves
The credibility and Trust of our website
and that's what we want we want Google
to trust us and a way to build trust is
by associating our website with other
websites of high equal or higher quality
so when we talk about offsite engagement
we want to do some guest post on
relevant websites so if you have that
ice cream blog go to another blog like
the the dessert blog and do a guest post
so not only that will that improve your
brand awareness but it'll generate a
backlink and maybe drive some referral
traffic you can participate in forums
and blog discussions like core.com or
Reddit get your content out there start
a discussion about a specific topic to
engage users build brand awareness and
generate that backlink you can always
you know put your your site on a
directory like Yelp for example or Yahoo
directory you could prefer testimonial
link building meaning if you serve
products or offer up a service well
somebody could provide a testimony on
their website or you can just earn
backlinks from relevant authoritative
web pages like we mentioned Kora or
Wikipedia or there's plenty out there so
the idea is to associate yourself with
highquality websites but do it naturally
you don't want to force anything so if
you're selling a specific service or
you're selling a specific product look
for like mining services or products
that complement what you do and that'll
create the natural environment natural
ecosystem that will eventually give you
the benefits that you need to rank
higher in the Serv results pages so we
don't want to purchase any links we
don't want to cloak content we don't
want to just inject links on sites that
aren't relevant we don't want to just
have sitewide links all over the place
pointing to the same page and we
certainly don't want to be on low
quality websites or directories it's all
about quality not quantity with offside
engagement so having offside engagement
complements what you do on your website
for Onsite together both of those
efforts will get you higher search
engine results now when we're talking
about the trends there are significant
shifts happening in organic search the
first of which is machine
learning uh that is more artificial
intelligence analyzing search queries
and
developing new algorithms within the
machine learning to serve up results
determine intent which is the primary
goal of machine learning and to return
not only the results but the information
you need as well as predicting
information you might need in the near
future uh the second is voice search
more and more voice assistance are
becoming popular through your smartphone
through your laptop through home
assistance and people are asking for
information and so it is completely
happening at an auditory level not in
visual level
and so how that is happening and how
that affects SEO reporting is really
going to be a factor moving forward and
then also as I'm sure if you've been
doing any search engine optimization for
any length of time you are familiar with
the struggle uh that has happened ever
since Google decided to strip keyword
data out of any analytics reporting uh
that took away really the number one way
that you were able to measure the
effectiveness of gaining keywords in the
search engines now to hit each one of
these just to explain them a little bit
more so that you know exactly what's
happening and what it looks like as it
affects your current level of SEO work
as well as reporting uh as an example of
machine learning uh if you go into
Google AdWords right now and you were to
set up a campaign looking at maybe like
auto body or Auto work or something like
that if you typed in a few keywords into
Google what's happening is Google is
only reporting one phrase that might
cover two or three or four phrases based
on for example Auto Body being is it one
word or is it two words Google here is
providing it as two words so even if I
type in Autobody as a single word this
is where the machine learning is coming
in in realizing that these are the same
queries and so rather than treat them as
individual queries what is happening is
through machine learning is they are
trying to figure out what is the intent
of the search and then grouping the
intent into single categories or single
searches and then all the variations
would be included in that now if I do
keyword research at a third party such
as word tracker or something like that
now what I'm going to find are multiple
different ways that people search uh
they're going to put in locations
they're going to put in details they're
going to you know use one word two words
and so in a third-party keyword research
format we're going to see a lot more
variations because those are tracking
what people are actually typing in what
Google is doing from the machine
learning standpoint is condensing
everything and trying to group it into
as I I said similar forms of
intent now What's Happening Here It
means that phrases or words that are
plurals
acronyms typical variants uh such as
words that may mean the same thing uh
but then they're different words so
they're going to group them together uh
and then also as you saw there words
with spaces or without spaces uh
conjunction words as as well as hyphens
and apostrophes a lot of these are going
to fall out of what you're able to bid
on also in the paid search side and it
will all go into a particular group of
words under a primary heading so that's
where voice search is taking us is
really a a condensing of the language
into intent what a people searching for
and how do we give that their in how do
we give their information back to them
now obviously this isn't perfect uh I've
worked with a number of clients where
they may offer a service and because of
that service Google is trying to then
associate them with another service uh
and it's not relevant and so because of
that machine learning sometimes uh what
we're seeing is a difficulty in trying
to get unique businesses new ideas or
something that just is isn't a part of
that overall big picture uh they're
trying to force it into neat little
boxes but as we know business is not
full of neat little boxes uh it's messy
it's fuzzy it it's it it's all kinds of
different types of businesses suppliers
industries that are going to have some
level of uniqueness about them so
hopefully this can continue to improve
uh but it does at this point still need
some human
intervention the second aspect ECT is
voice search and maybe some of you have
uh maybe the Google home or the Alexa
Appliance in your home and you've been
playing around with it and seeing what
it can do uh but also everyone's phone
uh and then also Cortana is on uh any
Microsoft operating system desktop and
so being able to search from your phone
simply by a voice command uh now this is
a affecting our ability to report
because this does not show up uh as a
search now if you're using Google now
and you are searching on Google or a
Google app it will show up as a search
referral however if you're using Cortana
if you're using uh Siri it's going to
use the search engine of the operating
system and so in that case and I'm going
to address this a little bit later it
shows up as a direct visit rather than
uh a search initiated visit and so this
is affecting the reporting of SEO
metrics uh but at the same time it is
also changing the search landscape
entirely uh right now uh Amazon is
probably Google's biggest competitor uh
for most searches especially for
electronics uh especially for uh what
you would consider things for home uh
and
Garden uh Amazon right now has taken
about 40% of the market share away from
Google in terms of electronics and uh
Home Products uh because people are
going to Amazon first and they're using
Alexa to do this uh so how voice search
it really is going to be uh a volatile
industry to follow over the next five
years and then as I mentioned before
probably the biggest frustration of
anyone doing search engine optimization
or wanting to measure the effectiveness
of optimization or where they stand in
the marketplace is the keyword not
provided uh now there's a number of
reasons why Google has gone about this
the first reason that they gave was for
privacy reasons uh that they wanted
people's searches to be private but at
the same time if you are doing paid
search you have full access to keywords
uh and also if you are advertising
through Google you can Target People
based on their Search terms so we know
the Privacy thing uh was really kind of
a smokees screen I think what's going on
here is that this was really the first
step to getting people away from
thinking of individual keywords or key
phrases and focusing on one or two
phrases that their that would describe
their business by taking away the vast
majority of keywords that you're going
to see in your analytics it will force
you to look at other words it will force
you to think bigger picture rather than
those one or two words that most people
believe that's what my business needs
this is where I'm going to focus my
attention and in and so in some ways
this has been good by making people
forcing people to think Beyond a single
word or a single phrase about their
business and looking into the bigger
picture this also plays into the Mach
machine learning because as I showed you
before machine learning is condensing
all of these keyword phrases trying to
determine intent and what better way to
really assist that than to start taking
away keyword data in the search engines
however when you take that away you have
then taken away the number one reporting
Factor uh of SEO and that is what
keywords am I ranking for what keywords
are bringing in not only visitors but
business and so by taking away the
number one factor we're forced to look
at a number of different methods that we
can use then to develop better campaign
metrics now one of the first things
about uh metrics is the expectations
whenever I work with a company I want to
know specifically what are your
expectations for the campaign what are
you trying to get out of it what do you
expect uh I'll I'll never forget I was
uh Consulting with an agency about how
they are developing their SEO campaigns
and how they were reporting them to
their clients uh and I went with them
oops to one of their client meetings and
uh after some of the agency people left
um I asked if I could talk with the
client for a bit after the meeting and
because the main reason was on this
whiteboard in the corner of their office
uh they had visits this month and visits
last month and the client asked me about
the agency um you know what I was doing
for them and what they what the agency
was trying to do uh and then they said
that they had concerns and the reason
why they had concerns is that the visits
last month uh were higher than the
visits this month and that over the past
few months the number of visits had been
going down and because of that they were
having a lack of confidence in their
agency now this was really kind of
surprising because this goes right to
the heart of client
expectations uh now what I had asked
that client then after that you towards
the end of the conversation is how how
is your business how are leads how are
your key performance indicators how are
the conversions on the
site basically asking them how's
business uh and the response to that was
well business is great business has been
improving over the past few months
however the primary metrics they were
looking at was visits rather than the
business-oriented metrics and so this is
where
establishing expectations of what
campaign metrics we're going to follow
and what those campaign metrics mean to
a business this is a conversation that
must take place rather than just
reporting basic information the same
charts and graphs every month or every
quarter that really might not
communicate the information that
everyone needs and so a conversation
between agencies and clients about what
are the expectations of this SEO
campaign what do we want out of that and
what constitutes success that
conversation needs to take place and
then that will
determine how the campaign metrics are
then developed and presented and the
discussion that will happen around them
now one thing that I think has been uh
you know I would say both a struggle as
well as what needs to happen the the
first thing about SEO metrics is the
myth of the number one ranking once in a
while I'll still run into this where
someone
will hinge the entire success of a
campaign by seeing the number one
ranking they want a single word or a tow
phrase to rank number one in Google and
that is their only standard of success
uh unfortunately I you know anymore I
will not even work with that kind of a
client because it's an unrealistic
expectation and it also o shows a
complete ignorance of how search works
and what it the power of what it can
bring to your business that this is much
bigger than a number one ranking and if
that's all you want then give me a
budget and we'll pay for it uh but I
would say for the most part we've moved
Beyond a number one ranking uh and now
what we have to educate people on is
that rankings are really a personal
metric that you the rankings you see are
probably going to be slightly different
than everybody else and I'm going to
walk through why that happens and so you
can help educate people within your own
organization of why ranking is a
personal metric now rather than a
universal metric and then of course as I
mentioned before it's all in the
expectations campaign metrics need to
focus on the business objectives not
just on the external factors of rankings
and and somewhat
invisibility uh we want to look at the
visibility of a company but ultimately
what we need to look at is how is your
search campaign delivering on your
business objectives because that's the
point of it all is what are we what are
we trying to accomplish and how is it
being
accomplished see it's when I see charts
like this that still make me a little
queasy and still make me roll my eyes
this was done uh about two years ago
asking people what are you measuring and
unfortunately there hasn't been much
change since this initial survey that
the vast majority of people are
measuring the number of visits to the
website uh and then they're measuring
social sharing time on site and less
than half are still measuring SEO
rankings um now that still boggles my
mind because that's what I'm going to
walk through here is why we can't
measure SEO rankings it is a completely
undependable metric and so what what
really surprises me shocks me is that
35% of people are measuring subscriber
growth and
27% a little more than a fourth of
businesses surveyed here are measuring
sales leads this is what it show so
shocking and surprising especially when
we come to campaign metrics and
expectations of a client and that is
what are the business objectives what is
it that you want to grow because the
last column here sales leads is what
makes business grow that is a direct
contributor to revenue and subscriber
growth well that builds my list and
marketing to my list is a direct
contributor to revenue and so as I said
this is just so mindboggling because the
two things that directly contribute that
have a direct impact on Revenue are the
least measured in this survey the four
things that have an indirect impact uh
meaning that you can have is as I
mentioned before an incredible number of
website visits but absolutely no Revenue
coming in as a result of that
these are all key performance indicators
visits sharing time onsite those are key
performance indicators they're not
business objectives and so part of the
expectations of developing campaign
metrics is understanding the difference
between a key performance indicator and
a business objective because it's easy
to get sidetracked especially with
search metrics especially with these
types of things of L you know visits
time on site uh page views rankings but
they're all indirect which is why they
are under the key performance indicator
uh grouping whereas we want to look at
the business objectives of subscribers
sales leads downloads getting
information into people's hands engaging
with them and moving along the customer
Journey when we can develop metrics that
focus on the experience of a prospect or
a customer then and tie that to our SEO
performance now we're developing how our
Campaign Will directly impact the
business and the
customer now I want to just go off to
the side for a little bit here and talk
about rankings and this is the whole
concept of rankings are personal not
Universal now you'll notice notice on
this this is the this is a uh a rankings
report from 2008 and compared to 2006 I
had to go back really far to find this
screenshot and this is of uh if you were
doing a search for the keyword latest
news this would show you who ranked
number one uh and the change in the
rankings over the past two years and it
also we're looking at it in Google n MSN
for some of you this may look really
familiar because what this did is you
put in the domains that you are tracking
the keywords and you would get a report
about who ranks where for what keyword
now this is back in the day and even
around 2008 uh we were still seeing some
or we were starting to see fluctuations
in rankings based on where you are
searching from as well as some history
coming in but we weren't seeing it to
the extent that we see it today you see
now today your rankings that you see are
largely based on your search history
it's based on past searches it's based
on content preferences uh what types of
content you tend to search on click on
or visit uh what business or industry
you tend
to uh search on as well as any behaviors
such as your uh predilection to click on
ads paid ads display ads or anything
like that and and so what's happening
here is this has been actually going on
for the past 10 years is that more and
more of your rankings are going to be
personalized to your unique history and
the words the sites that you visit the
words you use uh the types of queries
that you make all of this is being
developed in order to provide you the
most relevant personal results
ultimately it's also being done in order
to focus the paid search ads
specifically to you and your behavior
and the industry that you're in because
that's how the search engines monetize
so the better they understand you and
what you're looking for and again it all
comes down to intent if they can figure
out your intent and provide you results
that are relevant both paid and
organic then that's the goal that's what
they're trying to do and so simply based
on your history we're seeing that
rankings are going to vary from person
to person and maybe even from computer
to computer to smartphone depending upon
how you use
them the second thing is Regional
results uh if you search for specific
things in one region
it's going to show up differently in
other regions if I search for right now
if I go to Google and type in for
dealership I'm going to see the one
that's near me and I'm not going to see
one that's out in another state or
another region because based on the
localization that search engines are
providing it's going to look at that
query as a localized result and serve it
to me specifically So based on location
now sometimes we will see things brands
are more Global however if I'm looking
for something that is specific to my
region uh that can be based on my IP
address my country my city my state even
into a zip code uh local results
targeted results can be limited to a
small area to only show to people who
are within that area or searching in
that area and so more and more based on
localization we're seeing that affect
the results and that has been highly
impactful especially over the past two
to three years as local search has just
gotten miles better uh in all of the
search engines and it's only going to
increase as
well uh but then also based on the
different types of media based on
language based on the type of search uh
the int of search or what words you
might use uh as well as here we have the
machine learning come in uh what you'll
notice here is simply if I do a search
for something in Spanish as compared to
English I get different results I get a
completely different results page uh
there's more videos on the Spanish
results uh from the Spanish search than
the English uh also the makeup of the
page is completely different so the
words you use how you structure the
query the language those are all going
to affect the type of results that you
see uh and then also what you can see
here is that the organic results you
know we're seeing videos uh taking over
results howtos uh actual uh you know
multiple things happening in the search
engine results page and so it's no
longer just a list of 10 links and
running a ranking report to see where
you rank because what's happening here
is we're seeing multiple videos being
served prior to even seeing any what you
would call a traditional link uh or
traditional website snippet here showing
up in the search engine results page so
as you can see all of these things are
just completely
transforming a individual's rankings and
so if you were to measure rankings what
you're measuring is unreal it uh you're
you're measuring something that doesn't
exist uh and and as I like to say it's a
it's extinct before it's even run uh
because no person will ever see a
ranking report they won't see that
reflected in their results it's going to
be personalized and unique something
also to throw into the mix that even
based on your device you are going to
see different result results primary
reason is because if you're using a
smartphone it knows your location and so
you're going to have location results
mixed in also based on contracts with
different search providers uh with
different uh you know licensing from
Google licensing from YouTube uh the
results will be different based on the
phone you use based on the provider that
you have uh and BAS based on uh simply
just being mobile as opposed to desktop
so results are different based on the
device uh so hopefully if anyone uh was
hoping to run a simple ranking report as
an SEO campaign metric uh just this
little sidelight here has shown it's
really a a non-starter anymore the
traditional ranking report is extinct
and we have to move beyond that so how
do we move beyond that because there's
also now that I just shared the the
difficulties of a traditional ranking
report we also have a couple other
obstacles thrown at us that are
specifically uh both from a search
engine standpoint and from a user
standpoint the first obstacle that we're
running into is from a search engine
standpoint this is what Google is doing
if I do a search for top car reviews in
2017 at the very top of the result
I get a snippet of
information uh pulled from Consumer
Reports now what's happening here and
you may have seen this as well if you
type a question or something like that
that Google is not only displaying
websites but they're displaying the
answers and they are pulling the content
from these websites now when they do
that that does not show up as a visit
and it doesn't show up as a ranking to
Consumer Reports Consumer Reports has no
method of tracking this visibility and
it's incredible visibility so at one
point Google is providing information to
the
Searcher but the owner of this result is
having its content displayed by Google
without any knowledge that it's
happening unless someone has gotten in
in order to see that so this is is a
significant amount of visibility that
right now goes unreported because
there's no way to integrate this into
any metric
calculation uh other than a visual
inspection to see what's happening with
this we're going to see more and more of
this uh Google is presenting more and
more answers through the search engine
results page rather than just the
website the main reason is Google has
seen the more they do this the more they
deliver the answer in the search engine
results page rather than having people
click through to go to a website they
find that people are more likely to come
back and use Google again and what's
happening here is that Google
essentially is eliminating the
clickthrough they're trying to keep
people on the search engine results page
as long as possible think about some of
the searches you've done recently if you
search for weather information if you
search for flight information if you
search for sports scores on Google uh
those types of things you're going to
get your answer in the search results
page you don't even have to click
anywhere else to get the information
it's right there this is going to not
only grow under Google but this is
really the big question mark as to what
is the whole purpose of Google and what
are they doing how does it benefit me as
a website being in these results when I
can't track this and when Google is
trying to keep people on their site on
their property as long as possible this
is the big question mark moving forward
for SEO
metrics the other side of this is from a
consumer standpoint and this is what we
call dark search dark search are
searches that originate from a
non-traditional search engine for
example if you do a search from your
computer for example Cortana uh or if
you do a search from uh your operating
system in uh in apple you can do a
search uh almost on the uh the desktop
through the spotlight search and it will
bring up search results if you go
through that uh it's using basically the
search engine capability built into the
operating system but doesn't get
reported as a search engine referral
instead what's happening is it's sending
you to that site as a direct traffic so
anything that's from an operating system
uh a search that comes through an app
now if you're using the Google app this
is kind of a kind of a a gray area um
but it it does happen uh so you
basically have to install the Google
Search app or use something in the
browser uh but if you're in an app with
a search function and that app is not a
search engine app it will show up as
direct traffic uh your voice-based
searches that's using the operating
system uh now you can use a voice based
search in the Google Search app and that
will show up as a search referral I know
this might get a little confusing uh but
this also is you know this is sort of
the dark search of what's going on uh
and then also Amazon like I said is
stealing a lot of business away from
Google uh but there's no way to really
know what your Amazon ranking is for a
specific product or query uh so in that
way you're kind of losing some of
whatever Amazon is taking we're also
losing some of that data so those are
some of the obstacles that we're running
into in terms of getting a big picture
of campaign
metrics so like I said we need to start
with a business goal when we start
developing campaign metrics this is
where the expectations need to be very
very clear uh and I kind of like the
acronym of clear here that we need to
clearly State what is the business
purpose what are we trying to ultimately
accomplish and how will search help to
accomplish that based on that we create
a set of goals we lay out the goals of
the campaign what do we want people to
do and then carry that over into how
does that accomplish the purpose we then
explain how and define success explain
how success is accomplished as people
meet those goals how does that fit into
the customer Journey where is that in
the customer Journey how does it move
them from one stage to the next next how
do we measure that and how do we Define
that as success then we align metrics to
that strategy we don't just start with
the metrics we start with the purpose
the goal defining success and then
aligning metrics as we have our strategy
and then the final stage is the ideal
customer experience how do we relate
that through these metrics how do we
explain that our customer has seen this
and then they did this or they looked
for this information and it was a
successful visit now what will they need
this is where we look at the overall
customer journey and how search is a
part of that
Journey now getting into some very
specific metrics that will assist this
one of the things that I like to look at
and this can be a part of the reporting
if I'm looking at just the cold old hard
facts of of SEO campaign metrics one of
the first things I'm going to look at is
that audience overview and I'm going to
look specifically at my organic traffic
now one of the things I need to caution
is making sure and and I'm I'm I'm
surprised I still have to say this is
comparing like time frames you can
compare year over year if you're
comparing the entire year quarter to
quarter example is I'm looking at first
quarter 2017 compared to first quarter
2016 I want to compare like time frames
I am amazed at how many businesses still
look at month to month to month to month
and there is such a drastic difference
between month to month uh you have to
compare this quarter to the same quarter
last year this month this year to La you
have to compare the like time frames
going month-to month is is a is chasing
your
tail so from here I want to specifically
just look at my organic coverage at this
point what I'm looking at here is with
the audience overview I'm looking at my
total number of sessions this year
compared to last year and I can see that
it's higher uh and in some areas I've
seen some dips uh but then when I want
to go look at specifically in Google
this year or this first quarter compared
to first quarter last year where am I at
in terms of sessions new users bounce
rate conversion rate and
transactions that's what's going to help
me as far as getting the first step in
my SEO
metrics the next is looking at total
organic visits this is everything that
comes through search now again this is
part of the conversation this is
everything we can track uh because there
are things that are completely outside
of this uh this might be a good time to
say this I was talking to an analytics
provider a couple of years ago and in
comparing different analytics systems
and I asked them what makes your
analytics more accurate than your
competitors it was very interesting
because this is the lead engineer and he
sort of shushed me this was on the trade
show floor and he says in analytics we
don't talk about
accuracy he says what I like to say is
that our analytics are less inaccurate
than our C than our
competitors and that is really the case
when it comes to analytics if you've
ever compared analytics from two
different systems and looking at the
same metrics they never agree I'm always
amazed at how many people try to make
their Google analy analytics line up
with their omniture analytics and it
will never happen or they'll look at
multiple different packages or they'll
tell me my agency is reporting these
numbers but these numbers are what I'm
seeing and they're using two different
systems that's because analytics it's
tracking what it can track and what is
unclear an algorithm tries to organize
it or an algorithm tries to assign
things that are unclear to different
areas so each analytics program kind of
has its own
methodology of organizing the
information and interpreting it based on
that that's where you come up with the
we're less inaccurate than our
competitors so when we're measuring
organic coverage we're measuring what we
can based on this system it may not
agree with another system uh don't try
to make it agree because it just simply
won't now here I'm looking at my total
organic search visits and I can see
compared to the year prior this quarter
is up 18% in visits I can look at total
conversions I can see that it's up
30% uh and then also what I want to do
is look at landing pages and my keyword
Concepts now this is a sense because the
search engines don't provide us any
keyword data what we can do is look at
our landing pages and the amount of
visits those landing pages are
generating then it doesn't take much to
kind of look at those landing pages and
see what what are they basically about
what are those keyword Concepts now you
can go to uh Google search console you
can go to Bing Web Master tools and you
can see which
keywords uh uh are driving traffic to
your business through those Web Master
portals and you can get the concept of
what
keywords uh are driving traffic now one
thing I do like about being Web Master
tools is that being webmaster tools will
not only show me which keywords I'm
ranking for and which ones are sending
traffic to my website but they will also
show me which pages are the recipients
of those keywords so they are able to
tie together the keywords and the
landing pages and so I'll do that in
bing uh and on also Google search
consult will do that to an
extent uh but to some degree this is
still a manual process of looking at my
landing pages and comparing them to the
keyword Concepts as I said Google's
trying to push everything together into
intent and so evaluate your landing
pages in terms of intent what would
someone be searching on in order to get
to this page and utilize Google search
console and big Web Master tools maybe
some of your analytics in order to
figure that
out also what I like to look at are
comparative metrics uh when I'm looking
at the success of an SEO campaign as
tied to other types of campaigns I also
want to show the value of search engine
optimization and what it's providing and
so in looking at a source medium I'm
using Google analytics here uh what I
can do here is for this time frame look
at the overall numbers of sessions
generated through each Channel as you
can see there Google on its own is about
67% of all visits Yahoo is providing
about uh
1.28% of visits uh and then we can
see a little less than 20% are direct
visits so comparatively I can see where
my search engine optimization is
contributing in comparison to all the
other channels and I can get a sense
there in terms of I can run a revenue
report by Source uh where I can see
where my search is responsible for the
greatest amount of revenue for the
greatest amount of orders uh and also
when I look at uh one interes thing here
I can also do a value per session
breakdown and what this shows me is uh
the email campaigns those by far have
the highest value per session visitors
coming through the blog uh are next in
value per session uh and then we can see
our search visitors showing up there as
a significantly high value per session
um and one thing you might uh jump out
to you there is you can see that Bing
has a 4 pound 27 value session compared
to Google with a
177 that's normal I over the past 15
years it has been a really interesting
phenomenon that visitors from Bing or
MSN have a higher value even though I
will get just sheer numbers and higher
revenue from Google uh but they are
higher value visitor uh than Google
visitors uh that's just a phenomenon
that uh we've just observed for more
than about 15 years and really kind of
interesting there uh so from a a metric
standpoint I like doing comparative
metrics to see here's how search
compares to your other channels here's
what it's driving compared to your other
channels in terms of visitors in terms
of Engagement in terms of Revenue and
revenue per
user uh and again I I kind of mentioned
this associative metrics using Google
search console uh to see some of the key
keywords that Google is driving uh
Google my business I'm going to show
that uh as we get into here before we
wrap up B Web Master tools as I said
they will show you the keywords as well
as the associated landing pages
analytics uh getting into analytics and
looking at your organic traffic I showed
you a few reports there uh but that is
where people need to live in order to
understand what's going on with their
search traffic and more and more um
alongside analytics I'm seeing a CRM
integration with analytics really
becoming a a different standard because
within the CRM integration I can then
look at the entire customer journey I
can track the initial touch point of a
consumer I can then see how that spreads
into different searches so maybe they'll
find me first from a paid ad but then
how does subsequent organic searches
contribute to to different touch points
and then maybe there is a retargeting
touch Point uh and so I really like what
I'm seeing with modern CRM systems in
tracking more of the customer journey
and how search is a part of it and that
really then gets to the point of looking
at that customer Journey that ideal
customer experience and it immediately
puts it in the context of the purpose of
the campaign uh and the goals of the
campaign focused around the user
experience when I'm talking with a
client laying out expectations really my
first question is what makes you money
because that's what we want to track
there's our purpose we want to look at
sales and leads and so I want to look at
these prioritized outcomes this gets
back to what is the purpose of the
overall
campaign then we need to look at what
are performance goals now not all of
these
goals carry the same amount of weight
what I mean by that are inquiries
support uh people viewing videos online
chat subscribes downloads those are all
a different level of Engagement than a
typical like or retweet or a pin um
that's what I call you know it it these
are much more active if someone makes an
inquiry that's a lead if they contact
support if they're viewing videos about
new cars that's a performance goal that
means I'm engaging somebody and I'm
answering their questions uh we can look
at people subscribing and asking for
more information downloading brochures
downloading information this is where
we'll attach different value to
different actions because some actions
will contribute much more in terms of
value in the customer experience than
others and so we want to look at the
performance goals and establish a level
of value around them and then explain
clearly the difference between a
performance goal and a performance
indicator performance indicators
visibility visits time on site Pages
viewed bounce rate these are all good
performance indicators but they are
removed from a direct impact on the
business goals it's an indirect factor
in fact they can even be misleading if
that's what you're using because you
could see that business goals are
excelling while these numbers might go
down or they might go up and business
goals go down because it's what are you
doing with the information and how are
you focusing your efforts I want to
focus uh real quickly before I wrap up
here on uh Google my business and this
is something that uh Google has done
more and more of I'm using actually a
local landscaper that I've been helping
out simply because I love the numbers
that are showing up on this
um and it's really cool because you just
put your business in and then you set
the service area so it can be a zip code
it can be a
radius uh and then you can view the
insights this is just on the left side
is the login panel and it will show you
how many searches your business has
shown up for in the past month as we can
see here we are over we're almost at
about 6 and a half th000 search
es
where people searched for uh their
business we we can see about 8.3 th000
views of their local listing and about
uh
16,000 actions uh so we can see here
this now this probably right here is
probably going to be I think the future
of SEO metrics the main reason is this
is what happens when you do a search for
a local business and the business box
shows up in the results and that
business box has a picture of the
business a description hours uh pictures
and phone number and what can happen
here just like with the information
where Google is showing all the
information and you don't even have to
click through it this is tracking that
type of visibility this is showing you
how many times simply your business
information showed in the search results
and so now from here we can look
specifically on uh what customers how
they viewed your business and we can see
how many times the business showed up in
Search and how many times it showed up
on maps in the top graph in the lower
graph and this is where I think this is
I I think this where reporting is really
going to be moving is from that business
box in the search results we're now
showing in the past month how many total
actions people have taken and that is
how many people visited the website from
the the in information box how many
people requested directions and how many
people called from that business listing
and the far right graph shows you how
many people uh the dark green so maybe a
little over a fourth of people were
looking for the specific business name a
little more than or a little less than
three4 of people were looking for
related keywords and because of that saw
the business information so from a
visibility metric standpoint within
Google search results I love what Google
my business is doing because it's
providing me a view of how many people
are seeing my listing without even
clicking on it but then because of the
interactions available through
smartphone searches local searches uh
map based searches I can track a lot of
this local activity and how people are
then integrating uh or engaging with my
local search result on
google.com uh so reporting has changed
and it will continue to do so that is
the only uh that is the only hard and
fast rule here uh and so metrics need to
focus on uh emphasizing conversion rates
optimizing landing pages and it requires
analytics expertise much more than ever
and ultimately what we want to get to is
a measurement of the user experience
like I said that big picture of the user
experience did they find what they
wanted uh doing task-based user testing
where they have to find a specific bit
of information uh from the search to the
site uh and from that you can gather an
understanding of how quickly they're
able to find it how they can navigate
there both in a desktop and a mobile um
and this gets to the the micro moment
assessment when people are searching for
things such as can I afford it uh show
me the new cars uh where can I get
financed those types of micr moment
questions that people type into the
search box or speak into their phone
that's where we went to assess the
experience of what do they see what do
they find how easy is it for them to
accomplish their objectives and then
integrate that into a campaign
measurement uh reporting scheme on
behalf of Marketing sales and service in
most organizations the people who are
doing search engine optimization have
been doing it for a
while and I can tell you cuz I've been
doing it for a while that in the old
days it was mostly technical with a
little bit of content sprinkled in so
for arguments like let's say 8020 80% of
what an SEO needed to learn how to do
had to deal with you know you know your
metat tags your metadata you know uh CMS
systems blah blah blah blah blah and oh
by the way yeah you needed some content
on the
page well here we are a long time past
that and if this you you you look
through this slide here for example uh
this is the latest guidance from
Google on the kind of content they
want and if you look through the list
here most of the items on it aren't
Technical and frankly most of it is
content and if you think about it what
this means is is that the job
description for SEO has changed
dramatically particularly beginning with
the panda update but then including the
uh penguin update and then hummingbird
and pardon me more and more and more
seos had better be interacting with the
people who are
creating quality content engaging
content credible qu
content um useful content it's not
enough just to put keywords in the right
places anymore on pretty thin content
that won't get you where you want to go
so
again different uh paths maybe the same
direction but the folks in content
marketing and the folks in SEO frankly
need each other and they may or may not
recognize it in your organization but
you know it's a starting point this is a
conversation you you probably need to
have content marketing is
complex it often overlaps with other
elements of uh
marketing uh the the most typical
overlaps are with social media marketing
and
SEO and uh there probably already
are in your organization those kind of
groups the seos may be
on one floor and uh the social media
marketing people may be in a different
building you know
whatever but the new success formula
says we got to get all those folks to
the same table now we may have to do it
virtually we may have to use you know
webinars in order to hold those kind of
meetings who
knows but the point is is that uh you
know the world is Shifting and
organizational structures need to shift
with it and again you know that's not
something you can change
tomorrow but that is something that will
evolve over time and for what it's worth
it turns out that let's just say uh the
people who were in
SEO uh they may or may not admit it at
first but they absolutely need to work
with the people in content
marketing why because basically after
Panda and Penguin the rules
shifted and it's less about your title
tag and it's most mostly focused now on
the quality of your content and whether
that content is link worthy with which
means it's really compelling content
it's remarkable content that's content
that's going to get people to link to it
because wow that's you know and that's
not necessarily part of the skill set
that was required to be a successful SEO
five years ago or 10 years
ago so again you got to get these folks
to the table they've got to work
together you know and um and again that
means the organizational structure
probably needs to
shift and the same is true with the
social media marketing folks you know
they went out and their initial goals
and objectives were you know get lots of
likes you know get lots of fans uh get
lots of views get lots of Twitter
followers why because that seemed to be
the metric that the platform gave
us and so we used it to measure success
well it turns out none of those measures
actually measure real success because
they're focused on being successful on
the
platform boy I have lots of fans as
opposed to being successful in business
wow that generated lots of leads and
sales so there is a real real
discrepancy between let's just say the
center of
gravity okay it's not Facebook you're
not going to make
uh a lot of money on
Facebook you know it's just not set up
to do
business you got to get those folks that
you've engaged in Facebook to your
website where they can buy
something and that's a you know radical
shift for all the folks who uh are in
social media marketing to say wait wait
time
out but that's not what I was told a
couple years ago and the answer is
that's correct what we've learned over
time is that being engaging is
useful if it's harnessed to a benefit
and I'll tell you in most organizations
the social media marketing people are
under Cloud because they aren't
delivering business
benefit and they too need to learn to
work with the content marketing people
in order to do that and in some cases
they may not be creating the the right
kind of
content that actually generates leads
and sales as opposed to you know is
inexpensive to create to get my next fan
or my next Twitter
follower so the key metrics here are no
longer how many likes or comments or
shares did you get that's
nice
but how many sales leads did you
generate what percentage of those
converted into
sales that's a radical change but again
it helps when the social media marketing
people are at the table with the content
marketing people so if you are looking
to grab a successful career in digital
marketing and learn search Eng and
optimization simply learn has got you
covered with a wide range of topn
digital marketing courses these courses
make you skilled in SEO content
marketing PPC social media marketing and
much more with Hands-On EXP experience
in the tools like Google analytics
Keyword Planner Sim rush and there's a
huge list on the board however one year
of experiences prefer to enroll in these
courses find the course Link in the
description box so let's talk about what
we're going to cover today and we're
going to start out with how to set up a
Google analytics account and so we're
going to talk about everything that
entails including creating your Google
analytics account we're going to talk
about setting up a property in your
account and what a property is we're
going to talk about setting up a
reporting view in your property and
we're going to talk about installing the
tracking code so those are the series of
steps we're going to go through today in
terms of setting up a Google analytics
account so let's get right to it and so
really the bru prerequisite here when it
comes to setting up a Google analytics
account is to have a Google login an ID
so when you actually go to Google
Analytics you need to be able to sign up
or sign in and so once you actually sign
in then you're going to go walk through
a series of steps but really that's
really all you need to get the account
going is a Google ID and login so if you
have a Gmail account or other email
account that you use for other Google
products then you're good to go that's
all you need to do so when you actually
go to sign up for Google Analytics
you're going to be asked to set up a new
account and these are the series of
steps you're going to walk through or go
through to set up a new Google Analytics
account so you're going to choose an
account name and then you're going to
choose a property name okay so the
account name can be anything you want it
to be the name of your company your name
whatever you want to name it the
property name is really the website name
so what website are we talking about so
here I'm going to set up a fictitious
website name for now now it's called
demo simply learn so the URL for this
website demo simplylearn is going to be
demo. simply learn.com so that's the
property when we talk about properties
in analytics we're really talking about
what websites we want to measure and
then you're going to be asked to choose
an industry category and so for simply
learn we're in jobs and education but
you have a number of different
industries that you could choose from
this is important go ahead and choose
the
most relevant industry that your
particular business is associated with
okay and I'm going to talk about why
that's important here in a minute and
then you're going to choose your time
zone and the time zone is also important
because that's when the day starts in
analytics and the day ends based on that
time zone so the data that Google
analytics collects starts and ends with
that time zone so very important to
choose the time zone your business is
located in okay and then you have some
additional options here okay so you have
some settings and so the first setting
is to allow Google products and services
so if you opt into this then basically
what Google's going to do is share some
products and services with you via email
I would go ahead and opt into that
that's of course recommended by Google
it doesn't hurt to hear from Google on
related products and services that may
enhance your business the second is
benchmarking so benchmarking to me is
something you should opt into so going
back to that industry and category we
chose jobs in education so by opting
into benchmarking basically what
Google's going to do is share your data
that it collects on your website in this
case demo. simplylearn
in it's going to do the same exact thing
for you it's going to share Anonymous
data on other websites in the same
industry and the benefit of that is we
get to see what other websites or how
other websites are performing compared
to ours what's the Benchmark in our
industry and so the benchmarking to me
is important and I'm going to go over
that in a few minutes when we go over
the different reports but to me I would
always opt into benchmarking because
this is the only report Google provides
in analytics about how others in your
industries performing versus your
website okay so it's a way to compare
your website performance against others
in the same industry the other options
here technical support and account
specialist I would also recommend you
opt into those because then it allows
you to basically Google allow Google
access to your account and they'll be
able to help you if you UR or run into
any issues so these are the options in
setting up a Google analytics account
it's very simple very easy to do you're
just entering in a few Fields note that
we talking about a website right now so
I'm talking about demo. simply learn.com
but just know that if you want to track
a mobile app Google analytics will allow
you to do that as well you just choose
the option mobile app so we're tracking
a website we want to know how users
behave when they get to my website and
that's what Google analytics is going to
allow us to measure and look at we just
need to do a couple more steps in the
process so once we fill out these fields
here we're going to click get tracking
ID now I'm going to accept the terms of
service I'm going to accept another
terms and service in relation to data
protection I'm going to click accept
once I accept I'm going to be able to
get some tracking code the tracking ID
is the ID associated with with your
account and so this number is going to
be associated with your account so your
account ID starts with UA and it's going
to be this number here now the dash one
is the property you set up so in this
case I set up demo. simplylearn
docomo that every property I set up in
that account account is going to have a
d
1-2-3-4 Etc depending on how many
properties I set up so by default I set
up one property so my first property ID
is -1 if I set up a second property the
same account number it's just going to
have a-h to and that's important because
that ID that account and property ID is
going to be associated with that
particular property or website so again
once you finish setting up the account
settings then you're going to be asked
to add some tracking code to your site
and that tracking code is going to be
related to the account and the property
so notice my tracking ID up here notice
the tracking ID in the snippet of code
now this snippet of code needs to go on
every page of your website that you want
to track and you don't have to put it on
every page but if you want to track
website behavior on every page P your
website then it needs to go on every
page of your website so if you're using
a you know platform like Drupal or jumo
or even more popular platform like
WordPress adding the tracking code
sitewide is as easy as maybe adding a
Google analytics plugin to Wordpress for
example and then just simply pluging in
the ID now there's an alternative to
adding the Google analytics tracking
code to your site and that's Google tag
manager so so Google tag manager is the
way I would recommend going so if you're
not familiar with Google tag manager I
would recommend watching the YouTube
video we have on Google tag manager you
can just go to YouTube Type in simply
learn Google tag manager and this will
give you a nice overview of you what
Google tag manager is and how it works
but basically this is the way I would go
and I would recommend that in addition
to having Google analytics you set up a
Google tag manager account and then that
way you can put the tracking code in
Google tag manager so if I go to Google
tag manager and I just go into an
account on tag manager I can just simply
put in the Google analytics ID right
into tag manager and so if I have it in
tag manager then tag manager is going to
be the place that holds the code and
fires page view when somebody comes to
my website so that way I don't have to
add the tracking code to my website if I
do it in tag manager so that's the
recommended method for me is to add the
Google analytics ID associate it with
tag manager if you can associate it with
tag manager then that's the easier route
to go versus putting code on your
website okay so again take a look at the
video we have on YouTube for Google tag
manager that's the route I would go now
once you do get the tracking code on
your website whether that be through
Google tag manager or through a Plugin
or you know just simply adding the
script to your site to pages on your
site then what's going to happen is
you're going to start collecting data so
that's ideally the way it works you need
to add this code to your website now if
you're not ready to do that and you
simply want to basically understand how
Google analytics works then I would
recommend getting access to Google
Google analytics demo account and so if
you just type in and search Google
analytics demo account basically what
you're going to do you're going to
choose the first listing there and
you're going to go to demo account so if
you have a Google analytics or Google
login then all you need to do is click
on access demo account and so what
Google's going to do is put this demo
account into your account and so it's
going to look something like this if I
click on demo account here it's going to
add to my Google analytics account so
I'm going to have then access to the
demo account from Google in Google
analytics so I would recommend going
this route here if you're not familiar
you're not sure what you're getting
yourself into so think of the demo
account as kind of a test drive you're
test driving Google analytics before you
even add any code to your website so
again all you need is a Google account
and if you have a Google account and you
add the demo account to your Google
analytics account you're going to be
able to see how analytics works okay and
so that's what I would also recommend so
if you're not ready to start adding code
to your website then what you can do is
just simply add the demo account and
then once you add the demo account
you're free to peruse around Google
analytics to see the different types of
reports it has to offer now when you do
actually set up a Google analytics
account you're going to have some
settings that you're going to want to
pay attention to so when you set up the
account you have the account name and
then you have a property so under each
property you have by default you're
going to have one View and so here you
can see this view here so if we look at
the account we set up we set up a demo
simply learn account property is demo
simply learn so that's associated with
the website we're going to track and
then again by default under each
property you're going to have a view and
so by by default the name of the view is
going to be called all website data and
so in that view is where all your
analytics data is going to be stored so
you can see my screen here there's a lot
of different settings you have you have
settings under the account you have
settings under the property and you have
settings under the view so we're going
to talk more about these settings in
future webinars for advanced Google
analytics users but for now know that
there's a bunch of settings that you
have that you can play around with when
it comes to Google analytics anything
from adding users to your Google
analytics account your Google analy
property or view you can actually set up
goals you can set up filters you can set
up segments you can link up Google ads
you can you know set up remarketing list
there's a lot you can do in terms of the
settings as it relates to Google
analytics but so know those settings are
there they're located right down here in
this little sprocket icon that's the
admin icon so if you need to get to
these settings at any time you could
simply just click on the sprocket or the
admin icon and then you'll be prompted
to choose any one of these settings here
that you want to edit or alter so now
let's take a look at some Google
analytics reports so once you've
actually set up your account you have a
number of different reports that you
have available to you in Google
analytics so we're going to take take a
look at you know customize reports we're
going to look at real time audience
reports acquisition behavior and
conversion so these are all the
different reporting buckets if you will
that you have available to you in Google
analytics so if I'm an admin and I'm
looking at the Google demo account let's
start out by looking at real time so if
I click on the real time report and I
just click on overview so basically what
this is is going to do is show me at
this point in time how many users I
actually have active on the website okay
so that's why they call it real time
reporting because it allows you to see
the behavior of users who are currently
on your website and so this is the
overview report under real time and you
can see here I can see that
79% of my users are coming from desktop
18% 20% are coming from mobile and then
approximately 3% are coming from tablet
here I can see how they actually came to
the website so this is the referring
Source if they came from say search or
social I can see the source there and I
can see what pages they're active on and
then here I could see what locations
where they're located and so if I want
to see a breakdown of everything in the
overview I can certainly do that if I go
to locations under real time I can see a
majority of my users are coming from the
United States
okay where are they coming from I'll
just click on traffic sources and here I
could see the different sources and
mediums medium is the means in which the
traffic was driven so if it's Google
it's either PID search or organic search
so I can see here it's organic then I
can actually see what content they're
looking at on my website so I can see
currently I have three active users on
the homepage two active users on the
Google's women's
page so forth and so on now most
importantly if you have a event tracking
set up so if you taking a look at our
Google tag manager webinar you know that
you could set up event tracking in
Google analytics to measure engagement
on your website whether that be a form
submission or somebody clicking on the
play button of a video so if I click on
events I'll be able to see what events
are firing so here I can see we have
event track set up and I can see how
many different events are firing on my
website in real time so here I can see
e-commerce somebody clicking on the
quick view click some a couple of users
clicking on add to cart a couple of
users clicking on the promotion click
and as these events are fired you're
going to be able to see them highlighted
so if something gets fired it's going to
get highlighted and I could see that
these are the current events that I have
currently firing on the website and
that's what's currently fired now if I
want to look at the events that have
happened in the last 30 minutes I could
just click on this link here last 30
minutes and it's going to give me an
overview of the events that have
happened over the past 30 minutes okay
so that's event tracking and then more
importantly we can also look at what
conversions are happening in real time
just by clicking on conversions and so
now I can see I had one active user who
entered the checkout so so that's goal
number four so in analytics you can have
up to 20 goals and so here I can see we
have goal number four has already had
one active user and so if I look at the
last 30 minutes I can see I still have
only one goal over the last 30 minutes
and that was somebody who entered the
checkout so that's real time reporting
in summary it just gives you an idea of
what's currently happening on your
website and so for me ideally if I'm
launching a campaign or let's just say
you do a new website redesign and you
want to see how users performing and
behaving then real time's a good option
for you so you can see how things are
happening in real time now let's jump
down to audience reporting so if I click
on audience it's is just right
underneath real time I'm going to see a
number of different reports available to
me under audience and so let's click on
the audience overview report so audience
reporting basically allows us to get a
sense of who is coming to our website
when I say who is coming to our website
it doesn't necessar have to be a
specific person in fact Google doesn't
allow personally identifiable
information in Google analytics personal
identifiable information such as a
specific name uh social security number
credit card information Etc however we
could still paint a nice picture on who
is coming to our website meaning what
country city or state did they come from
what language what device did they get
to our website from how old were they
okay were they male or female or other
what interest did they have what browser
did they use so we can paint a nice
picture based on all this information
that Google analytics is providing us
under audience so if I go to audience
overview here I can see I have all these
different options available to me to get
a basic understanding of who is coming
to our website so for example I could
see a majority of the people coming to
our website speak English and are from
the United States okay in fact that
represents 61% of the users and so
Google analytics does a great job of
giving me an overall percentage so if I
have a 100% of the users I could see 61%
of those users represented
English-speaking users from the United
States 7% represented English-speaking
users from Great Britain and so when it
comes to analytics we have users and
users are broken down into two
categories they're either returning or
they're new so when you add the Google
analytics tracking script to your
website what's going to happen is if a
user or when user goes to your website
they're going to get cookied and if it's
the first time they've been to your
website what Google analy is going to do
is store a cookie in the browser so when
that same user comes back another day in
the same browser analytics is going to
recognize that that cookie is in the
browser and so then analytics is going
to categorize that user as a returning
user okay so that's how analytics is
able to differentiate new versus
returning so if that user doesn't have a
cookie in the browser then analytics is
going to recognize that store the cookie
and then count that user as a new user
and so when you're looking in analytics
you're going to be able to see a
breakdown of new versus returning so
here I can see over 34 of my traffic
over the past week here I can see April
6th through April 12th three over three
quarters are new users to the website
here I can see about 23 24% are
returning users okay so I can get a good
breakdown of what type of users are
coming am I I driving new traffic am I
driving traffic that's been to my
website before what language are they
speaking okay I can also paint a bigger
picture how old are they are they what
gender are they do they come from mobile
so let's take a look at some of these
different reports under audience so if I
skip down now to demographics I can
click on overview and when that report
loads I can see now under demographics
overview I can see the breakout of age
ranges and so here I can see the
majority of the traffic coming to my
site again over the past week now if I
want to change this date range I could
simply do that I can change the date
range just by clicking on the date range
and then maybe going say the last 30
days and I can even compare it to the
previous period or the previous year I'm
going to choose the last 30 days I'm
going to click apply now I'm looking at
data over the last 30 days and again you
can change the date range to any range
you want you can only go back as far as
when you actually created the Google
analytics account you can't go prior to
that so here I'm looking at the last 30
days and I can see almost
47% of my users were in the age range of
25 to 34 now when it comes to gender I
can see
66% represent males so I can get a
breakout of gender and age as well as
interest and click on interest and look
at the overview there and see what the
interest is of the users who are coming
to my site based on in market segments
or Affinity I can also choose language
and location so if I want to know
exactly where my users are located when
they're coming to my website I can click
on location and here I can get a
breakout 43% of the users of the last 30
days were from the United States more
importantly I can align my audience with
goals and we'll talk about goals here in
a minute but here I can see if I have an
e-commerce website I can see of those
43% 29% of those converted or purchased
something and that equates to 94
transactions so I can get a good sense
of not only how many users are coming
from a specific country but are those
users converting if I click on mobile
mobile to me is one of those reports I
tend to spend a bit of time on because I
want to know what devices users are
coming to my website and so for my
website here or this is the Google demo
website I can see mobile represents
approximately
27% of the traffic so desktop still
represents a majority of the traffic so
for you you want to keep an eye on
mobile because mobile is definitely a
majority of what people use nowadays
that's how people start their day that's
how they transact Via Mobile whether
that's purchasing something
communicating or searching it all starts
with mobile so you want to keep an eye
on mobile and more importantly you want
to keep an eye on Behavior so Google
analytics is telling me that yes I have
approximately 27% of my traffic of the
last 30 days came from mobile how are
they interacting with my website so if I
look across this report I'm going to be
able to see different metrics so if I'm
measuring specific metrics against my
dimension in this case the dimension is
what we're measuring and in this example
we're measuring mobile I can see that
the bounce rate is approximately 48% and
bounce rate means that if a user in this
case from mobile landed on a page they
left the site without going any further
so they consider it a bounce if they
don't go to another page if they leave
the site from the page they landed on
and they don't go any further that's
considered a bounce so a bounce rate is
the percentage of people who come to the
site and leave the site without going
any further so in this case we have 48%
bounce rate that's almost half of our
users who come from mobile leave the
website from the page they landed on so
is that good is that bad well it's open
to interpretation is definitely
subjective but you want to keep the
balce rate as low as possible you want
to keep people on your site especially
if you have an e-commerce website you
want people who come to your website to
purchase and so here we can see 48%
Mobile in desktop it's a little bit
lower at 41% now if I look a little bit
further at engagement I can see how many
pages on on average do mobile users look
at so versus desktop it's a little bit
lower you can see
3.86 on desktop it's 4.5 now if I look a
little bit further in engagement I want
to be able to measure how long somebody
from mobile stays on the website if
they're bouncing at 48% but they're also
looking at 3.8 Pages 3.9 almost four
pages per session then that means in
this report analytics is telling me
they're spending about 2 minutes on the
site and interestingly enough I can see
that mobile over the last 30 days had
more transactions so 51 transactions
versus 34 transactions from desktop and
interestingly enough the Ecommerce
conversion rate is at 29% that's higher
than desktop at 07 it's lower than
tablet but it's higher than desktop and
mobile has the most transaction
and since they have the most
transactions they have the most Revenue
at
2380 so yes the engagement isn't exactly
as great as it is as desktop but we can
see that people are still purchasing
with their mobile devices so it's
something to keep an eye on and mobile
is something I definitely look at in
fact since it's such an important report
one thing you can do in analytics is if
you actually like a report and you think
you're going to look at that report m
multiple times then you can simply just
go ahead and click save at the top here
so if I click save I'm going to enter a
name for this report I'm just going to
call it mobile report and click okay and
then what's going to happen is it's
going to be located under save reports
and save reports is located under
customization customization is located
above real time okay so if I close that
up you can see audience real time
customization if I click on
customization if I click on Save reports
I should be able to see my save report
here and I do so here I can see mobile
report if I click on it I can simply go
to the report I was looking at before I
saved it so save reports to me is a good
feature in analytics cuz it allows you
to quickly access a report that you've
saved in the past so let's take a look
at one more report under audience and
let's go to benchmarking so remember
when we were setting up our analytics
account we had the option to opt into
benchmarking and I recommended you do so
and so if you did actually opt into
benchmarking then you're going to be
able to see how your site compares to
others in the same industry so if I
click on benchmarking and then click on
channels what I'm actually able to do
now is compare my website with others in
the same industry so if I go back to say
jobs in education
and I choose education all education as
my industry vertical I should be able to
see websites that are in the same
particular industry and how I compare
with those websites so I'm choosing all
countries I can narrow that down if I
wanted to I can just search for the
United States I can choose a specific
State and then I can choose a particular
site size so here I'm choosing sites by
daily session so these are sites that
have an average of 5,000 to almost
10,000 sessions a day and so in this
vertical education in the United States
sites that have 5,000 to
99,999 sessions per day that means that
there are approximately 310 web
properties contributing to this report
okay based on this criteria I chose now
if my site is similar meaning if I'm in
the United States if I'm in education
and I'm receiving 5,000 to
99,999 sessions per day then I'm able to
compare my site against 310 other
websites now Google's sharing this data
anonymously from the other websites and
they're doing the same with your website
to those particular websites
benchmarking reports okay so it's shared
data anonymously in particular
Industries and verticals and so now I'm
looking at a channel report so if I want
to see how I compare to others in my
industry then I can go ahead and see by
channel for example am I driving as much
traffic as others in my industry and you
could see I'm not in fact I'm 76 77%
worse in terms of the amount of traffic
being driven from organic search so
anything in red is going to show as a
negative result a negative comparison
whereas something in green is a positive
comparison so if I look at engagement I
can see that I might not be driving as
much traffic but I can see that the
pages per session are better than the
site average or the industry average I
can see if I go over again looking just
at organic search I can see the bounce
rate is better than the industry average
so the channel report under benchmarking
allows you to measure how you compare to
others in your industry and you could do
so by looking at location and devices so
if you opted into benchmarking when you
set up your account then you'll be able
to compare your website against others
in your industry in your country region
and based on the size of your website in
terms of how many visitors or sessions
you're getting per day so let's go from
audience to acquisition so if audience
is who is coming to your website
acquisition allows us to see how the
traffic was driven to your website so
how did these users get to our website
and so under acquisition if we click on
overview we'll be able to see an
overview of how users whether they're
returning or new came to our website and
so what analytics does by default is
they have a number of default channels
and when we say channels we mean
analytics is grouping different channels
based on how users got to your website
meaning how did users get to website did
they come via organic search meaning did
they type something into Google and find
you in the organic listing analytics
also groups users based on whether they
came to your site directly meaning did
they type in the URL directly into the
browser or did they bookmark your
website and come back via the bookmark
so they're grouping users under direct
they also group users under referral
meaning do they come from another
website they group users by social do
they come from a social media platform
like Twitter or Facebook if you're
running paid search meaning if you're
running paid search on say Google then
do they come from Paid search ads now if
you're running display ads on say
Google's Network Google's Display
Network that's a default channel so
analytics Will Group users there so if
they don't recognize a channel then
they're going to group it as others so
by default Google analytics groups users
on how they came to your website via
these default channels and so I can see
how many users came to the site from
each Channel now if I want to drill down
on this report I can click on all
traffic and then if I click on all
traffic I can go to channels I can look
specifically at the channels report and
so now I can see organic search again
over the last 30 days is the number one
channel driving traffic and they
represent approxim imately again you can
see this number here in parentheses next
to the raw number of users I can see
that number is about
56% so 56% of my traffic over the last
30 days came from organic search and so
those are the number of users again as a
metric you're also going to have
sessions and you'll see sessions a lot
as a metric so users are broken down
between new and returning so every time
a new or returning user comes to the
website basically what they're doing is
initiating a session so you can have a
user who can come back multiple times
every time they come back to the website
it's a session so session is simply the
start of somebody coming to your website
and the session ends when they leave the
website and so just like we looked at
with the audience reports when it came
to mobile we can also look at engagement
by Channel so just like mobile we looked
at balance rate pages per session
average session duration we can do the
same thing here with our Channel report
more importantly in addition to behavior
we can see conversions and since we're
running it e Commerce platform we could
see what the conversion rate is by
channel so organic search did drive the
most traffic and they did have the most
transactions over the last 30 days and
the conversion rate in this case is17
okay so how Google determines the
conversion rate they basically take the
number of transactions and divide that
by sessions so that means that over the
last 30 days organic search drove 38,1
123 sessions and of those 38,1 123 64
actually turned into a transaction which
equates to17 which also equates to 3,000
in Revenue so I'm able to determine not
only how users are getting to my website
by looking at the channel report I can
actually see if they're engaging and if
they are converting and notice when you
look at a report in analytics you can
look at it by Channel you'll also get a
summary so here I can see a summary or a
total based on my date range so I can
see over the last 30 days I've had
54,000 users
49,000 of them were new okay that meant
that out those 54,000 users I had 70,000
sessions I can see my average bounce
rate was 43% the pages per session were
just over four and the average session
duration how long did somebody stay on
my website on average about 2 minutes
and 55 seconds the average conversion
rate was .14 and add a total of 97
transactions totaling
$5,500 okay and that's all over the last
30 days so any report you look at in
analytics is going to have a summary and
note that any report you look at in
analytics is going to allow you to save
it so if it's a report you think you're
going to go back and look at at a future
date then you simply just have to click
on the save button conversely if you
don't want to save it you can simply
just export it so you can export it as a
PDF if I click on PDF it's going to
allow me to export that as a PDF now you
have other options available to you as
well you can do a Google sheet you can
export it as an Excel or you can export
it as a common delimited file so here
you can see I can save it as a PDF if I
want to and if I click okay it's going
to save to my desktop or location of my
choosing and then I can go back and look
at it in that format at a later time so
that's the export feature available to
you in analytics again if you you could
say save it as well or you can export it
okay some other reports under
acquisition if you're running Google ads
note that you can connect Google ads to
analytics and this is key because now I
can see how many people are coming from
Google ads to my website and are they
converting now this is important because
with Google ads I'm actually paying for
the click so you can see here I'm
running a report based on campaign data
so I could see what campaigns are
driving traffic how much I'm paying per
click and you can see on average I'm
paying 34 cents per click and then more
importantly I want to be able to see if
they're converting so you can see I've
spent
$810 over the last 30 days and received
$858 in Revenue so you want to make sure
that you link up your Google ads account
to your Google analytics account for
this very reason you want to be able to
see how your Google ads campaigns
perform once the users get to your
website and so I want to see if they're
engaging and I want to see if they're
converting so there are all sorts of
reports under Google ads so you can look
at it by keywords by search queries by
hour of the day if you're running
display campaigns you can look at
display targeting so there all sorts of
reports under Google ads you just have
to link it up and you link it up under
the admin now there are other reports
that you can look at so if I go to
campaigns I can look at all campaigns so
if you're running all sorts of different
types of campaigns whether that be on
Facebook whether that be email whether
that be you know other types of
advertising let's just say Twitter or
Instagram you're going to be able to see
those campaigns here and that's under
all campaigns and again you'll be able
to see the campaign name and you'll be
able to see metrics associated with
those campaigns and more importantly
you'll be able to see your e-commerce if
you're running e-commerce platform or if
you have goals set up so you'll be able
to look at how your campaigns are not
one not only driving traffic but two are
they converting let's go from
acquisition reporting to behavior so
Behavior reports are going to actually
show you how users behaved once they got
to your website once they landed on on a
page on your website how did they behave
so when we looked at audience we got a
sense of who is coming with acquisition
we get a sense of how the traffic got to
our website did they come from organic
direct social Etc the behavior reports
allow us to actually measure how that
traffic behaved once they landed on a
page on our website and so if I go to
overview under Behavior now I'm looking
at this graph here it's showing me how
many pages have had and a page view is
simply once a page is viewed it's
counted as a page view so if a user
comes to my site they're initiating a
session and if they look at a page then
that page is going to have a page view
okay so a user can look at a page
multiple times in a session and every
time they look at that page it's going
to count as a page view so here I can
see in this graph how many pages I've
had again over the last 30 days and if I
look further at my overview report I can
see the specific pages and how many
pages they've had and I can also look at
some other metrics okay the average
balance rate the average time on page I
can look at the exit rate which means
how many people actually exited or the
percentage of people who exited from
that page so I can dig deeper into my
behavior reporting so if I click on site
content and I click on all pages then
I'm going to look at a report for by
Page this is my Dimension this is what
I'm measuring my page and now I can see
how many page views each page had over
the last 30 days now note you also have
something called unique page views so
unique page views is equivalent to one
per session in other words if a user
came to my site and looked at the
homepage then the homepage is going to
have one unique page view and one page
view now if the user in that same
session looks at other Pages then every
page that user looks at is going to have
one unique page view however if the user
goes back to to the same page in the
same session then it's still going to be
one unique page view but in this case
the homepage if they look at the
homepage a second time then the homepage
is going to have two page views if they
look at the homepage five times in one
session then the homepage is going to
have five total page views and one
unique page view okay so that's why
unique page pag is equivalent to one per
session where page views is a
accumulation of how many times the page
was viewed in the same session so in
other words you're always going to have
more page views than unique page views
okay so this gives me a sense of how my
page is performed so again I can look at
total page views and then engagement so
ideally what you want to do with a
report like this is if a user is not
engaging on the page then that should
tell you something about the page itself
if they're not engaging if the bounce
rate's high if the time on page is low
if the exit percentage of exit rate is
high then you probably want to do
something with that page now these are
all pages but if I jump down to landing
pages my landing page report is showing
me how many people actually landed on
that page and so here I can see under my
landing page report I can see the
homepage had
36,7 sessions in the last 30 days that's
how many people landed on the homepage
so here I can see 71% were new sessions
meaning that I had a lot of new users
who landed on the homepage in fact
25,000 or
52% of the people who landed on the
homepage were new I can see the balance
rates about 42% but of those who didn't
bounce they went on to look at about 4.5
pages per session and spent about 3
minutes on the site and the one thing I
like about the landing page report is I
can also see whether that particular
page in this case the homepage did it
help contribute to a goal or conversion
and in this case I can see of those
36,000 sessions I hit 22 transactions
totaling 1,200 in revenue and that's an
e-commerce conversion rate of
.6% so the homepage over the last last
30 days contributed to
.6% of the revenue so this gives you an
idea of when somebody lands on your
website and they land on a page is that
page helping to move that person along
meaning are they not bouncing and is
that page helping to move people towards
converting and so that's what the
landing page in effect allows us to
measure is the engagement and in this
case we're measuring transactions okay
okay so analytics also gives us some
other reports under Behavior including
sight speed so sight speed to me is an
important report to look at just like
the mobile report to me sight speed
important because what Google analytics
does is they take a sampling of pages
and in this case you can see over the
last 30 days they sampled
2835 page views and of that sample they
came back and said the average page load
load time is about 4 seconds now ideally
you want to keep it as quick as possible
I would say even under 3 seconds okay
now there are other factors involved
with page load time the browser you're
using the country that you actually
browsing that page from mind how to have
the best infrastructure you may may not
even be on the best internet Network
meaning you're on a cell network or the
Wi-Fi is not that great or you can be on
a page that just has a lot of images or
a lot of code that may slow it down so
there are other factors involved and so
what Google analytics does is show you
what those factors are so here I can see
by browser what the average lad time is
if I want to look at Country I could see
what country is contributing to the low
time now the great thing about the site
speed report is if I go to speed
suggestions okay what speed suggestions
is going to do is it's going to show me
the page load Time by Page and then it's
actually going to provide a link where I
can actually click on to get suggestions
on increasing the page load time so for
example I can look at this particular
page here this Google redesign shop
bybrand slout page line number five if I
look at line number five I can see the
average load time of this page is 8
seconds almost 9 seconds okay that's an
eternity to some people now notice this
link next to it so Google's recommending
seven total suggestions so if I click on
seven total what it's actually going to
do it's going to open up a new window
and it's going to open up another Google
report called page speed insights and
Page speed insights is going to give me
some information about what I can do to
create corre correct the page load of
that particular page so look at the site
speed report it's important because
there is a correlation between site
speed or page load time and user
behavior of that page and there's also
correlation between page load time and a
page ranking organically on search so
page load time is very important it's so
important that I'm even going to save it
so I'm going to click save and click on
speed site speed suggestions as my name
and click okay and now that report is
going to be saved under customization
under save reports let's jump from
Behavior to conversions now conversion
reporting is arguably the most important
section in Google analytics because what
the conversions reporting allows us to
do is see how people are converting or
if they're not converting on our website
and so in Google analytics we have the
opportunity to set up goals now you have
the opportunity to set up 20 goals in
your Google analytics View and so to set
up a goal goal okay so you're going to
click on admin and Under The View you're
going to see goals and so if you don't
even have goals the first step is to
create goals and so you have four
different goal types in analytics so you
have pages per session so how many pages
per session is so if your goal is set to
say three or two if somebody actually
looked at two or three pages per session
it's going to count as a goal okay so if
I look here I can see I have page per
session set at 10 so that means that if
a user came to the site looked at more
than 10 pages per session then it's
going to count as a goal another goal
type is destination so destination means
that if somebody actually went to a
specific page then it's going to count
as a goal and in this case I can see
here that the goal is set to this
particular page here and so when
somebody actually lands on that page
it's going to count as a goal now there
are two other goal types we can look at
one is duration so just like pages per
session in our previous example if
somebody looked at 10 pages per session
it's going to count as a goal with
duration it's based on time so in this
particular case if you set up a duration
goal and the duration is set to say 1
minute and 30 seconds then that means if
a user comes to my website and they
spend at least 1 minute and 30 seconds
then it's going to count as a goal okay
and then the fourth type of goal in
Google analytics is an event based goal
so when you set up event tracking you
could turn that event into a goal so if
somebody clicks on say the submit button
of a form you can turn that event into a
goal so here you could see the category
equals contact form so you can always
verify if a goal works just by clicking
on verify this goal
and in this case this event is turned
into a goal so anytime somebody fires
this event it's going to count as a goal
so you have four different goal types in
Google analytics you have pages per
session destination event and duration
and so once you've set up a goal then
you can measure goals under conversions
so now if I look at goals overview I can
be able to see how many total goal
completions I've had so if I want to
look at it by goal I can just choose the
goal option here so if I want to look at
for example goal two engaged users this
was the pages per session I can see that
I had a conversion rate of 10% meaning
that I had
7,000 of all the users who came to the
website 7,000 goal completions meaning
7,16 users looked at 10 pages or more on
my website and so that's how you want to
be be able to measure whether users
where they ever they're coming from
whoever they are whatever Pages they
look at you want to be able to look at
the conversion reports to see if they're
actually converting based on the goals
you've set up whether that's pages per
session duration destination or event
goal conversion tracking reports can
help you measure who is actually
converting and then the great thing
about Google analytics here is that I
can actually see by segment so the
default segment and a segment is just
looking at a specific user set so the
default segment is always all users
however I can choose a different segment
so if I want to choose instead of all
users if I want to choose Mobile Traffic
I can select Mobile Traffic hit apply so
I'm actually now looking at a subset of
data I'm looking at mobile traffic so if
all the mobile users who' came to my
site I can can see
1,400 engaged or looked at 10 pages or
more okay and that's a 7% conversion
rate so the great thing about Google
analytics is you have the opportunity to
set up four different goal types okay
based on those goal types you can go to
goals overview and look at the
conversion rate of each goal but you can
also change the segment of that
particular goal to see who exactly
converted okay another report I like
under conversions is the multi- channel
funnel report so if I click on multi-
channel funnel basically what this
allows me to do is see how different
channels work together to convert so
remember the channel reporting we looked
at under acquisition here I can see now
how different channels work together to
drive the conversion so if I look at
three channels direct organic and
referral I can see all three together
Drive 2% of the conversions if I look at
direct and referral 12 1/2% if I look at
direct and organic
12.24% so I can see how different
channels work together and so if I look
at top conversion paths as an example I
can actually see what channels how
channels work together to drive the
conversion so in this example I can see
over the last 30 days that my top
channel grouping was direct times two
meaning that somebody came to the
website directly meaning they typed in
the URL in the browser or they
bookmarked it and came to the site okay
they came the first time but didn't
convert but then they came back a second
time via direct and then converted so
that combination is my top conversion
combination of the last 30 days my
second best conversion grouping is
organic search and direct meaning that a
user came to the website via organic
search first did not convert and then
came back via direct the second time and
converted so basically what analytics
does is give credit to the last referral
meaning if you came to the website via
referral a referring website and
converted then the referring website's
going to get the credit for the
conversion but analytics does a good job
of showing you how different channels
work together so a channel may drive a
lot of traffic like organic search but
that traffic may not not convert the
first time around for number of
different reasons whether it could be
brand recognition Price shopping reading
content whatever the case analytics is
able to measure if that channel actually
did contribute at a later point and in
this case we could see organic search
drove traffic that didn't convert but
that traffic came back a second time via
direct and did convert so that's our
second best Channel grouping and so the
multi- channel funneling Report top
conversion pass to me is a good report
to look at so you can actually see not
only how channels work together but you
can see sources and mediums and
campaigns and how all that all those
different campaigns and different
sources work together to convert so
that's just a good report to look at
there are so many different reports
available in analytics there's so many
that we haven't even gotten to yet so my
advice if you look at the demo report
you get a feel for each of these reports
under each section whether that be
audience acquisition Behavior or
conversions take a look at these reports
see what makes sense to you see what you
can use to improve your website
performance for this particular webinar
we're going to jump into Google
analytics directly and spend all of our
time there because it's about learning
practical application so goals are
important goals uh let me just say this
goals are in analytics something that
should be align with your business and
we call goals that are aligned with your
business kpis or key performance
indicators so it's very important as a
precursor that you know how to set up
goals in Google analytics because if
you're using Google analytics you want
to measure everything against a goal so
without further Ado let's jump right
into Google anal analytics so if I go to
Google analytics and I log in okay what
I want to do is go down to admin click
on admin here and admin will take you to
basically a screen that looks like this
where you have a account column you have
your property column and then you have
your view column now the view column is
where you're going to go to setup goals
okay so every view in every property has
up up to 20 goals okay so by default in
analytics you're going to have at least
one view for your property so if I have
a property I'm going to have at least
one view but if I happen to set up
multiple views like you see here then I
know for every view I set up I have 20
goals to work with so where are those
goals so Under The View I'm going to
click on goals and now I can see I have
20 at my disposal now you can see here
by clicking on the recording column I
can see I have in this particular
property this particular view I have
five goals that are active so you can
use up to 20 but you don't have to have
20 active Okay you can have one active
two active my recommendation is at least
have one goal again when you set up a
goal you're going to measure everything
in analytics against that goal okay so
in this case we have have five
particular goals we're measuring so we
have five active out of 20 total so if I
don't no no longer want to use a goal I
can simply just turn it off if I want to
continue using it just turn it on okay
it's that simple you could turn on and
off goals so here I already have five
set up so if you want to set up a new
goal the one thing you need to know in
Google analytics is in order to set up a
new goal okay you need need to have edit
access at least the view level I would
say at the property level so you want to
make sure whoever is in charge of Google
analytics for your organization or if
you're in charge okay you simply just
want to go to user management and user
management you want to make sure the
email address you're using to log into
Google analytics has at least edit
permissions so you're going to need edit
permissions to add new goals so I have
edit permissions I'm going to go to
goals and I want to set up a new goal
but before we jump in and set up a new
goal what is it that we want to achieve
that's really the question we want to
ask ourselves what is the goal of the
website well if it's somebody
downloading something okay are you
measuring that download via an event
okay or they filling out a form
submission before they download so if
they submit that form submission is that
the goal do you have an e-commerce site
is somebody purchasing something so
these are things you want to ask
yourself before you actually set up the
goal what is it that I'm trying to
measure now when you actually do go to
set up a goal you're going to click on
the red CTA button that says new goal so
analytics actually has some templates
set up for you okay you can see them
here okay if you're somebody's
registering online or creating an
account or reading review downloading
something sharing something you could
choose all of these options here what I
normally do is choose custom 99% of the
time I'm just going to choose custom it
doesn't really matter if you use the
template or not it's just a template is
basically some free prefilled
configurations but my recommendation is
always just go with custom you want
total control over how to set up your
goal so we already have in mind what
type type of goal we want to set up so
for example if somebody goes to fill out
a form submission and they go to a thank
you page after that well what's the URL
of that thank you page we want to be
able to track how many people go to that
page because we know if somebody does
type in or fill in a form submission and
goes to that page we know that they
filled out the form and so for example
if I go to continue I'm going to name my
goal first so I'm going to say than you
page as an example notice analytics is
assigning an ID so notice this is goal
ID 15 that means that that's the next
available goal there are 20 goals
available in analytics and so what
analytics does is they group goals
together so 1 through 5 6- 10 11- 15 16
through 20 into goal sets so for example
goal 16 through 20 is part of goal set 4
and why does Google analytics combine
these goals into different goal sets
well because it's easier to me measure
and look at data by goal sets so for
example if I jump into any report here
if I go to all traffic channels and I
want to measure how many goals by
Channel I can look at it by goal set so
if I have goal set one selected then I
know any goal I have active in there
between goal id1 through goal id5 I'm
going to be able to see those goals and
goal set one and now I'm going to be
able to measure every goal I have active
in goal set one against the channel so
if I choose goal set two whatever goals
are active there goal set three Etc
notice I don't have any goals 16 through
20 active that are in goal set 4
therefore I don't have that option
available to me so back to admin the
bottom left navigation again go goals
okay we want to measure somebody going
to the thank you page we have edit
access we're going to choose custom as
our goal setup we're going to type in a
goal name I'm just going to say thank
you okay this is goal 15 now this is the
important part Google analytics has four
different goal types destination
duration pages per session or screens
per session so screens per session is
related to mobile because Google
Analytics measur
mobile app activity and then you have an
event so we're going to cover all four
of these but for the sake of this simple
example I'm going to choose destination
why because if somebody goes to that
thank you page we're going to go ahead
and put in the thank you page as the
goal the goal URL so for example
destination is my choice I'm going to
click continue now this is where I'm
going to put the URL so if my URL is
just simply thank you. HTML I can just
go ahead and put thank you. HTML or if
it's just thank you then I can just do
thank you depends on the website depends
on the URI structure so whatever that
URL is that's what you're going to put
in and when you're done you can verify
it so what Google analytics does is
actually will verify over the last 7
days if anybody's actually gone to that
particular page so if we click verify we
could see 0% conversion rate so that
tells us that if this is the correct URL
then we've had 0% people go to that page
this is just an example however if you
didn't see a conversion then you might
want to make sure you check the URL here
that you put in and if you do see a
conversion rate then you know it's
working so Google analytics actually has
options so we're saying thank you is
equal to so the destination URL is equal
to thank you or thank you. HTML or thank
you. ASP or whatever that thank you page
is okay you do have options so if you
have a long URL you could say begins
with and you could say begins with say
thank you so this is the logic we're
going to say hey if anybody goes to a
URL that begins with thank you then
count it as a goal or you could say
equals to so if anybody goes to a UR all
that equals to thank you then count it
as a goal you have one more option Here
regular Expressions so Google analytics
understands the language of regular
Expressions so regular ex expressions
are just special characters used to
communicate with Google analytics in
order to hone in on exactly what you're
trying to track so we can always say you
know starts with or ends with so we can
you know use characters like the dollar
sign ends with or begin with so we can
always do that so you can use regular
Expressions as well if you're familiar
with regular Expressions if you're not
then you don't have to use them but
there are special characters where that
you can insert in that are used as
regular expression so if you're not
familiar with regular expression don't
choose that option you can choose the
other option of equals to or begins with
now note that on all three of these
options I didn't put the domain so if if
my domain is-f foundation.org SL and
then thank you I don't need to put the
domain because analytics is already
already knows what domain we're tracking
so you don't have to put in the domain
here when you're entering in in this
case the go URL so you can omit the
domain so when you put in that URL you
know that you have three options to work
with and then you always always want to
ver ver ify that go URL you always want
to verify it because if you see 0%
conversion and in this case over the
last 7 days then that should tell you
something either your goal is not set up
correctly or you just don't have any
conversion either way you want to double
check that now when it comes to the
destination URL goal you do have an
option here for funnel so if I turn on
funnel then that means I have the
ability to track how people went through
my funnel so if I have a cart and I want
to be able to check how many people go
in and out of the cart then I have the
option of adding specific Pages as part
of the cart so we could say you know
step one which is basically cart we
could say step two is billing
information that could be/ billing we
could see step three is shipping
information SL shipping and then step
four be you know confirm and that could
be SLC confirmation so whatever your url
structure is for your cart and it
doesn't necessarily have to be a cart
basically all I'm doing is putting a
series of steps with URLs as each step
and why do I want to do that because I
can then track how many people go
through my funnel that I've created okay
so here I could see this is my funnel
that I've created for this particular
goal okay and the funnel is only
available for the destination URL so the
funnel is available if you want to see
traffic through the goal okay and how
people go through the funnel and where
they drop off now you have an option
here to make the first step required so
if you make that first step required
then that means you're measuring the
funnel through the first step only now
if I turn that off then I'm measuring
the funnel through each step meaning
that I can measure people as they drop
in and out of the funnel where if it's
required the first step then I'm only
measuring traffic as it enters in the
top of the funnel so you have that
option available to you the funnel and
then for all goals you do have a value
so if somebody did actually convert Okay
Google analytics is going to count it as
a conversion and you can assign a value
so if you're not an e-commerce website
then you may want to think think about
assigning value if you are an e-commerce
website then analytics has the ability
to track e-commerce revenue for your
website so you don't need data value but
in this case let's just say you're
nonprofit organization and you're
collecting donations and on average over
the past year every donation that
somebody contributed was equal to $5
well you can just go ahead and put $5 in
there as the value for that goal so that
means that if somebody did go to in this
example slank you and convert analytics
is going to count it as a goal and then
assign $5 value alongside that goal so
if you're non Ecommerce if you're say a
nonprofit like this organization or
you're B2B and you want to track some
value then you have that option there so
with the destination your Ro goal you
have the option of adding a funnel with
all all goal types you have the option
of adding a value all goal types and
we're going to go through the rest of
them you have the option of verifying
that goal so that's the structure of
setting up a goal destination URL is
just one goal type we're going to talk
about the other three goal types because
in Google analytics there are four goal
types again destination is one of them
with destination as you do have the
option with all goal types is you have
to be able to choose your logic here so
we're going to cover that with the other
three but just know when you set up a
destination your or goal you have the
option of adding a funnel now when you
actually do set up a funnel what's going
to happen is analytics is going to
measure traffic as it goes through the
funnel so where do you look for that
funnel information well you want to get
out of admin you want to go to the left
side navigation you want to click on
conversions then goals then funnel
visual ization So based on the funnel
you set up you're going to be able to
see traffic as it goes through the
funnel so notice on this particular
funnel we don't have the first step
required why because I could see traffic
as it goes in and out of each step of
the funnel so let's go through this
funnel and see how people react so here
I can see the first step is the store
front page so over this particular
period of time I have 8 84 sessions
enter the storefront page so out of
those 84 I can see 21 left the
storefront page 63 went on to the next
step in the funnel which is the cart
page I can then see 24 people went on to
the cart page directly and five exited
the site Al together okay so that gave
me 87 total and from 87 I saw that 8 two
went on to the next page with the next
step what analytics does is they give
you a percentage so in the first step we
had 63 move on to the car page out of 84
that's 75% so from the car page to the
create your account page we had 94% move
on so we didn't have anybody enter in
the create your account page we didn't
have anybody leave to create your
account page so we have 82% 82 create
your account and then have 82 move on to
the payment page so that's 100% okay we
have one exit so we have 81 that
proceeded to beyond the payment page
which was purchase so 81 of 82 is
98% and we started with 84 so that gave
us plus the 24 that we accumulated along
the way so that gave us a 75% funnel
conversion rate so 75 5% of the people
who entered in the funnel went on to
purchase okay so don't be confused with
the overall e-commerce conversion rate
so 75% is the funnel conversion rate the
overall conversion rate for this
particular goal is
18.45% over this particular period of
time why because that takes into account
all sessions that have won to the
website so 18% of all traffic went on to
convert but those that did go into the
funnel 75% converted so that's a look at
the funnel so if you set up a funnel
that's what it's going to look like you
have the option to measure everything
from step one and Beyond or measure as
traffic goes in and out of the funnel so
the purpose of this is we're going to be
able to see where traffic drops off how
effective our funnel is what pages we
need to address in that funnel okay so
that's the whole point of the funnel and
the funnel is available with the
destination URL goal so if I go back to
admin if I go back to goals Under The
View I can actually see what that funnel
looks like so here we chose regular
expression so this is what the URL is
okay you can see our funnel in each of
the steps we have set up notice we're
using regular Expressions here and then
if we verify this goal we could see over
the past 7 Days 19 % conversion rate so
that tells me something's working in
this particular with this particular
goal because we do have a conversion
rate okay so that's the destination URL
goals let's now talk about the other
three types of goals so the next goal
type we're going to talk about is pages
per session so if you're not sure what
type of goal to set up for your website
at the very least you should try and set
up either duration Rel related goal or
pages per session related goal so let's
talk about the pages per session so
basically what this goal is going to
allow us to measure is for example if we
set the goal to three pages per session
then we're going to be able to measure
if how many people went to the site and
looked at three pages per session so
let's take a look at that goal so if I
open up the goal here I can see three
pages per session is what we're naming
it so basically what we're asking
analytics to do is anything greater than
two pages which would be three and
Beyond count as a goal so if anybody
comes to the site looks at more than two
pages three pages or more then it's
going to count as a goal and so here we
can verify it so if we verify it over
the last 7 days we could see a
4.12% conversion rate and that tells me
that 4% of my traffic over the last 7
Days looked at at least three pages or
more so you're probably asking yourself
well what number should I put in for the
actual variable so in this case we see
two well what you want to do is you want
to look at on average let's just say
year to day you want to make sure you
have statistical significance so you
want to look at a period of time so if
you go to analytics go to audience okay
and then if you go to overview and if I
change my date range to year to dat I
could see on average right now I have
1.21 pages per session so that's on
average so we don't want to make our
goal one page we don't want to make our
goal two pages we want to make it three
so we want to be able to basically
measure at a higher rate okay why do we
want to measure measure at a higher rate
because if 1.21 is the average then two
pages per session really isn't moving
the needle so what we really want to do
is get people to stay on the site longer
look at Pages more uh during their
session so look at more pages and so we
want to be able to see what segment of
the audience is looking at more pages
what channels driving traffic that's
looking at more pages what pages are
contributing to more pages per
so the whole idea is you want to hone in
on what your goal is and see what's
working and then see what's not working
so you can make adjustments the whole
idea behind Google analytics is to
improve website performance and so if
our average is
1.2 then if we change it to just two it
may not be good enough so in this case
you know we want to up the bar a little
bit so we're going to choose three now
you can choose four or five that's
perfect perfectly fine just know if your
average is 1.2 I wouldn't choose one
page per session as my goal and I
probably wouldn't choose two so I'd set
the bar a little bit higher now the
third goal type available in Google
analytics is also engagement related and
that's duration so just like pages per
session we can measure how long somebody
stays on the website and we could set up
a goal for that so in this case I have a
goal set for 1 minute 30 seconds so my
goal type is duration so if I click
continue then basically I'm asking
analytics in this case anybody who stays
more than 1 minute and 30 seconds on the
website count it as a goal and so before
you actually put in the number of hours
minutes and seconds you want to look at
that average so if you go back to
audience overview here I can see a
minute and 7even so do we want a minute
and 30 Maybe maybe we could do that
maybe we can go with 2 minutes so again
the whole point is you want to set the
bar a little bit higher than what the
average is and so here I can see over
the last seven days if I verify this
particular goal I can see 8% of my
traffic over the last 7 Days stayed on
the site at least 1 minute and 31
seconds okay they stay greater than 1
minute 30 and so the whole point is you
can hone in because this is a goal I can
go in this is goal okay this is a goal
here and so I could see that this is
goal 13 so now I can go to acquisition
as an example I can go to channels as an
example since this is a goal this is
goal 13 so that would be in goal set
three so I can actually see what channel
is basically driving that goal okay in
other words what channel is driving
traffic that is staying on the side at
least 1 minute and 30 seconds and so
that's the whole idea behind goals so
likewise for pages per session we can go
into channels and here I can see we've
have a over this period of time year to
date pages per session we have 3%
conversion rate and here I could see for
example organic search has a 133%
conversion rate here I could see social
media has a 10% so I could see that or
people coming from organic search are
staying on the site longer or they're
looking at more pages than any other
channel so just like duration or
destination or any goal you set up you
can measure that goal against any
Dimension just because it's engagement
doesn't mean you can't you absolutely
can and so the whole point of Engagement
related goals is to figure out what's
driving traffic to the site but what
traffic is engaging so you want to be
able to pinpoint that so you can improve
website performance now the fourth goal
type available in Google analytics is an
event so if you click on new goal you
close custom click continue you have the
option to choose an event so an event is
something that you can measure on your
website that analytics can't measure by
default so if you want to measure PDF
downloads or clicks on buttons or clicks
on play buttons on a video or click on a
submit button or click on an external
link I mean you can measure pretty much
anything with an event then you want to
be able to turn that event into a goal
so let's quickly summarize what an event
is so again we want to be able to
measure a particular event that happens
on the website so in order to do so we
need to identify that event so if I go
to for example this particular website
here and I want to measure how many
times somebody clicks on the Donate Now
button well if I me I can measure that
as an event so when you set up an event
in analytics you have to actually assign
a category and an action for that event
so that's the first thing you need to do
when you identify an event related goal
first you need to set up the event and
in order to set up the event you need to
assign a category an action okay so once
you identify what you want to track as
an event on your website you're actually
going to go in a tag manager or have
your Web Master go to tag manager and
set up a tag and in that tag they're
going to assign that particular category
and action and so here you could see we
have this set up our category is named
donate now and our action is click and
that's what we want to do we want to
measure how many people click on that
donate Now button so anytime somebody
does that then the category donate now
is going to appear in analytics with the
action click so when you actually do set
up an event you can go into analytics
and you could test that event so if I go
to the website and I click donate now
Okay the reason why I have this as an
that is because I'm taking to a third
party website to handle the donations so
here I can go into analytics and now I
can see a category is being fired for
header donate with the action click so
that's my category and that's my action
so that category and action is what is
firing after somebody clicks on the
Donate Now button so if I want to turn
this event into a goal I can easily do
that now that I've set up the event now
that I've identified the category and
action I want to go back to admin and
set up the event with these parameters
in place so just turns out we already
have the goal set up so let's go through
how this goal was set up so first we
chose custom we chose event we gave it a
name so as the best practice when you
actually set up a goal as an event or
turn an event into a goal I would add
the prefix event col into it and then
that way when you're identifying goals
and you're reporting you know it's an
event so I'm going to click continue and
now that I've actually have set up the
event already in Google tag manager I
given it a category I given it an action
okay see here you could see we have a
regular expression set up so anything
with the header donate or donate is
going to fire this goal so over the last
7 days have a 81% conversion rate okay I
could have easily put in equals 2 and
put in whatever the action what or the
category which is donate now or I could
have put action equals click I could
have done that as well so let me show
you another example here so if I do this
custom continue event donate now here's
my goal ID it's going to be an event so
all I need to do is put in the category
and action so donate now and then click
so that's all I have to do and that's my
goal so I can verify it okay to see if
anybody's fired it and basically that's
what I need to do to turn that event
into a goal okay so you need to set up
for an event first you need to identify
the event set it up in Google tag
manager which is another platform and
once you've done that then you have your
category in action once you have your
category and action you're again going
to go into analytics and then simply put
in that category and action into the
appropriate fields to set up your event
related goal now all events don't have
to be turned into a goal if you actually
do set up an event and you're not worthy
of a goal meaning it's not a kpi or
doesn't align with your business goals
well don't fret you can always just go
to behav here okay you can always go to
events you can always go to overview and
measure your events that way so here you
could see all of our events that are
fired now we do have this one turned
into a goal so if it's important for our
business then we want to make sure we
convert that particular event into a
goal okay if it's not important for
example somebody's just clicking on a
social button then you don't necessarily
have to turn that event into a goal if
you don't want to know that it's sitting
here under events under Behavior so the
point I'm trying to make here if it's
important to your business and you're
already tracking it as an event via
Google tag manager then feel free to
turn it into a goal all you need is that
category all you need is that action and
so so one final note on that event
related goal just like any other goal
you can add a value okay so if I have an
event set up I can choose to add a value
here or in Google tag manager if I've
assigned a value to that event so if I
go back to the actual event in Google
tag manager you could see I have a value
set up for $1 then I could just go into
analytics and say you know what I
already have the value added so go ahead
and use the value added in Google tag
manager okay so I'm going to choose yes
now if I choose no I have the option to
add the value here just like I would
with any other goal so just keep that in
mind you can add a value to any goal
type with an event related goal you can
add the value right into the tag in
Google tag manager just as I've done
here so remember when you actually set
up your goals whether it's a destination
pages per session duration or an event
you can just go ahead and choose that
goal set that it's in and measure any
Dimension again against that particular
goal so here I can see e newsletter
signups by Channel I can go into another
goal set here I can see contact form
submissions okay I can see what
particular channels driving contact form
submissions okay so just know that you
can align a goal against any Dimension
so if you have e-commerce you don't have
to set up a goal for that that's
separate but if you want to take a look
at your goals and analytics on its own
you can just go to conversions goals
overview here I can actually get a good
sense of how my goals are performing
over a period of time so again if I
choose for example year to date now I
could see based on the goals I've set up
how many total goal completions value
which takes into account the value we've
added into these goals okay the total
conversion rate and here I can see a
broken down down by the goal I actually
have set up and I could see it by Page
or I could see it by source and media so
I could see Google organic is driving
the most goal completions then Google
CPC direct and then I could see some
others in here as well contributing to
goals now I do want to point your
attention to another report in Google
analytics that does take into account
goals and that's multi-channel funneling
so again under convers goals
multi-channel funnels if I go to
assisted conversions I can actually see
what channel in this example is
assisting with the conversions I've set
up and so what do we mean by assisted
conversions well that means that if a
channel let's just say organic search
drove traffic to the website and that
traffic didn't convert when it arrived
at the website and left but it came back
a week later via another Channel let's
just say email and when they came back
via email they did convert during that
session well what analytics does is they
give an assist to organic search because
they help Drive the traffic to the
website so it's similar to the game of
basketball if I have the ball and I pass
it to my colleague and my colleague's
the one who scores because they had the
ball last well they get the credit for
the point I.E the conversion but I get
an assist and so analytics works the
same way they're always going to give
credit to the last click or direct
conversion but they will give credits to
the channel in this case that assisted
with the conversion so that's under
assis inversion and that's based on the
goals you have set up you can highlight
any particular goal here if I want to
hone in on say the Donate clicks only
then I'm going to be able to see what
contributed to that particular goal so
there's another report in here top
conversion pass that I think's important
so after you set up your goals you can
actually see what channels in this
particular example help to drive
conversions again this is year to dat so
I can see all the different combinations
of channels that work together to
contribute to a conversion so again I
can choose a specific goal or I can
choose all my goals so those two reports
are under multi- Channel funneling
there's also another report that I think
is good and that's time lag meaning how
long did it actually take somebody to
convert so here you can see most of our
conversions 265 year to date happen on
the day somebody arrived on the website
but I can see I did get some conversions
a day later two days later Etc so you
have time lack top conversion pass
assisted conversions they're all under
multi- Channel funneling and they're all
available after you set up at least one
goal and so if you're not sure what goal
to set up okay don't fret you can always
at least set up an engagement related
goal so that's available to you duration
pages per session you also have
destination and event tracking and
they're all available to you you have 20
available per view now if you're if
you're not quite sure exactly what type
of goal to set up there is an option
available in analytics and that's the
gallery so you can always import a goal
from the gallery so in other words we
could take a look at what other people
have set up in terms of goals so you
just have to click on the button import
from gallery and it'll take you to the
gallery and you'll be able to see what
are the goals others have set up today
we're going to talk about how to set up
a vent tracking in Google analytics so
let's get started so many of you out
there have a website similar to the one
I'm looking at now this is a nonprofit
that I work with I'm a foundation and
like this website and probably like your
website you probably have some
interactivity on there that needs to be
tracked for example buttons uh if you
have buttons like this one that says
donate or newsletter sign up or there's
a PDF download or a video that needs to
be you know tracked based on the amount
of people who click on the play button
so I mean all sorts of inter activity on
a website have you ever wondered how to
track that well there is a way to track
that because by default Google analytics
can't track interactivity and engagement
on your website like you probably want
to have your website tracked so if you
have buttons and videos and things of
that nature that you have tracked well
you're going to need event tracking and
if you're in analytics and you're always
wandering around the data and you're
happen to find yourself under events
well if you want events on your website
and you want data to populate under
Behavior top events you're going to need
to set up event tracking so event
tracking is a two-part process and we're
going to talk about that two-part
process the first part of that is to
identify what you want to track okay
okay so if we go back to our example
website here I'm a foundation again we
noted there's a lot to track here we got
a donate now bu we got a newsletter sign
up we have some social icons okay we got
a donate Now button here we got a play
button here got all sorts of
interactivity you know we got a button
here that says you know purchase tickets
for an upcoming event I can go
throughout the website and find
different buttons and things to to to
track let me just say this there's no
shortage what you can track on your
website with event tracking so event
tracking is just basically in layman's
terms tracking engagement on your site
because Google analytics by default is
only going to track page view data
meaning how somebody got to your website
what page they looked at how long they
stayed on that page what page they left
from more or less their timing how long
somebody stays on the website and what
pages they look at so there's more to a
website than just how long somebody stay
on a page and so in this example we want
to be able to track everything here not
just the Dona Now button but everything
because once you get the hang of event
tracking then it's very easy to set up
okay so step one identify what you want
to track okay so there's a lot we want
to track we're just going to use one
example to start off with and that's
going to be this donate Now button okay
so this donate Now button we want to
track now we have a newsletter sign up
we have Facebook and and that's fine you
could track all that but for the sake of
going through a step-by-step process
today let's just focus on the Donate Now
button what's focused on the Donate Now
button then we'll come back and start
tracking these other things but this is
what we want to track to start out with
okay so step one identify what you want
to track now when it comes to tracking
events on a website you want to identify
those events so we did that by choosing
this donate Now button now once we
identif ify what we want to track we
need to assign two parameters for that
event so with event tracking you have
three parameters but one is actually
optional so you have two Mand mandatory
parameters that you have to assign to
everything you want to track on your
website and that's the category and then
the action so event label or label is
the third parameter but again that's
optional okay so basically when we
identify an EV vent our website we want
to assign it a category and an action
okay so why do we want to assign it a
category and in action because when we
are in analytics under Behavior under
events top events we could see we have
different categories here and we have
different actions we have different
labels so if I click on any one of these
Dimensions I'm going to be able to see
some of the parameters I've entered in
for previous events I'm tracking okay so
the whole IDE idea is you want to be
able to group different events together
into a category and assign an action and
assign a label to it that's really what
you're doing you're just grouping and
identifying the events you're trying to
track and so in this case I have this
donate Now button sitting in the header
okay in fact I have a lot of things
sitting in the header so if I wanted to
and I want to track all these buttons I
can create a category called header and
then if I track all these buttons all
these buttons can sit in that same
category if I wanted to or I can create
a separate category for each of these
buttons it's up to you how you organize
your categories because basically all
you're doing is giving a name to what
you're trying to track and the name is
equivalent to a category so in this case
the Donate Now button is very important
I'm just going to call it category
header donate now I need to give an
action to each category and so in this
case I'm just going to say click because
that's what the action is doing it's
it's somebody's taking the action of
clicking now if it's a video and it's a
play button I can assign an action of
play it's up to you whatever you name
these parameters you just need to be
organized and methodical about what you
name it that's all and so in this case
header donate and then click okay and so
that's our category and action and so
that's clearly step two so step one
identify what you want to track step two
assign
a category action and or label but
remember label is optional so if I go
back in analytics here I can see some
categories and if I click on action I
can see some actions that I've named now
step three so we've identified in Step
One what we want to track we've assigned
a category and action so step three is
going into Google tag manager to set up
the event okay so if you're not familiar
with Google tag manager then you can
easily just you know do a Google search
for Google tag manager and basically
you'll have all sorts of information on
it there's a good video overview of tag
manager here that you can watch so tag
manager basically is what we want to use
to set up event tracking now tag
managers use for a lot of different
things but the main thing we're doing
here is setting up an event for our
website and so I'm logged in to the same
email address I'm using for analytics
okay so now I'm in tag manager and I
want to set up my event for this donate
Now button so what do I need to do well
for every event I want to set up I need
to set up a tag okay so if I go to tags
I can see I already have some tags set
up and some of these are events and so
when you actually set up a tag I WR
recommend having a naming convention so
here you can see any event we set up we
start out by calling it g- event-
Whatever It Is we're trying to set up
and so in this case we want to set up a
new tag for the Donate Now button on our
website so we're in Google tag manager
because tag manager is what's going to
fire that event so if I click on new
okay and I click on tag figuration I'm
going to choose Google analytics and
then I'm going to choose event as my
track type so we want the data to show
up in Google analytics and we're
tracking an event we're not tracking a
page view we're tracking an event and so
now remember in step two you identified
what you want to call that category you
identifi what you want to call that
action and you have some optional
parameters like label so first things
first header donates the name of our
category and our action is click and if
you want to add in a label and value so
if you want to sign a value you can if
you want to add in a label you can okay
those are optional so you just need to
focus on category and action and then
the last setting here that's probably
worth mentioning is a non-interaction
hit okay so this is automatically set to
false and why is it set to false because
it's a non-interaction no that's false
we want this event if somebody clicks on
the header donate to be an interaction
so for example if I land on this page
here and I click on that donate Now
button that I'm tracking as an event and
I actually leave the site because I have
my settings set to false I want that
click to be an interaction then
analytics is not going to count a bounce
if I change it to true so from false to
true then that means it is going to be a
non interaction if somebody lands on the
page and if somebody clicks on the
button so I don't want it to be a
balance I want it to be an interaction
so my advice is leave it set to false
we're going to choose Google analytics
as our setting here this is our variable
for Google analytics so in other words
that variable is set to our analytics
property ID and more or less that's what
you need to do to set up the tag okay
you need to in step two identify the
category and action Andor label and or
value now value can be anything you want
you're assigning a numerical value so if
you just assign one anytime that event
fires in analytics it's going to have a
value of one okay and we have our
non-interaction set to fall so anytime
the event fires it's going to count as
an interaction and therefore not count
as a bounce if somebody landed on that
page so that's more or less all you need
to do to set up the tag in Google tag
manager now if somebody else is setting
up the tag for you then again you want
to revert to step two you want to be
able to give that person the appropriate
category action and or label Andor value
why because you're the one that's going
to be going into Google analytics and
you're the one that's going to have to
go to behavior events top events and
look for the particular act category in
action Andor label so you need to be
able to communicate that information
information to whomever is setting up
the tag now if it's you great you
already know what it is because you're
entering that information into tag
manager so in this case I'm going to go
ahead and choose a variable for my label
parameter and why do I want to do that
because in tag manager I have something
at my disposal called variables and
variables allow you to see specifically
things that are being tracked so in this
case I chose page path okay so page path
is a URL and why did I choose page path
as my variable for the parameter label
because if somebody does click on the
header donate button and the header
donate button on our website is on every
page so if I go to the children's page
I'm still going to see that header
donate button and so for me I want to be
able to see what page somebody clicked
on that header donate button and so this
allows me to actually see in Google
analytics what page somebody clicked on
the header donate down button and so now
if I go back to GTM Google tag manager I
have a category I have an action and I
have a label which is a variable okay so
note that in Google tag manager you have
a lot of different variables at your
disposal and variables are there to help
you identify specifically what is being
tracked so take a look at all the
variables at your disposal in tag
manager in this example I'm using page
path so now once you set up your tag
pretty straightforward again tag types
Google analytics track type is event you
are assigning the category action indoor
label andoor value you're changing or
leaving the default in place for
non-interaction hit and then you're
choosing the variable for Google
analytics which is your property ID so
once you've done that you have a tag the
second part of setting up a tag is to
assign a trigger to that tag so tag
manager needs to be able to know when to
fire that event and so here I'm going to
look at a trigger I've already set up
for this particular event and so if I
click on it I'll be able to see that
what it is is a click on some links not
all links but some links I'm actually
saying hey
Google tag manager fire this event when
the click ID equals header donate button
now it just so happens that if somebody
did click on this donate Now button
they're going to go to another website
in this case Network forg good.com so in
tag manager I could have set the trigger
to equal URL equal instead of Click ID I
could have said UR L equal Network forg
good.com so that could have been my
Logic for my trigger in this case I
decided to go with the click ID and so
in this case that button has an ID
associated with it called header donate
button so if you wanted to use click ID
for your event for your button you could
simply just go to the website you can
rightclick on that button and click
inspect element and so when I actually
inspect the element I can see now the
button here you can see it's highlighted
in the upper Pane and in the lower pane
I can see where it's linking to it's
linking to network forg good.com but
here you can see if I hone in a little I
could see ID equals header Das
donate-button so that's the click ID
notice there's also a class I could have
set the trigger to equal this class or
again I could have set the trigger to
equal the URL or the page that this
button is pointing to I could have
chosen any one of those but I decided to
go with the ID so this is the ID I chose
and that's the ID I have in my trigger
okay so that is what's going to fire
that event so if somebody clicks on a
button that equals header D
donate-button it's going to fire that
event which is going to equal category
head or donate action click and then the
label is going to be page path so now
that we've set up our event we want to
test to see if it actually works so
there's two ways to go about testing an
event and the first way is through
Google analytics so if we go to Google
analytics and then we go to real time
okay we can go to events and here you
can see one is already fired so let's go
ahead and go to and test this and go to
the we site so if I go here for example
and I click on amagar alumni okay so if
I click on that you can see I'm under
our family and if I click on that button
then go back to analytics and look at
real time I should be able to see this
event fire so if I click on it I'm going
to go to network for good now if I go
back to analytics here in real time
under real time under events per second
I can see that event f buing category
equals header donate the action equals
click now if I click on the category
here I can see the label the label
remember was page path and here you
could see this event fired on the r
family page which was the page I was
just on so that's one way to test to see
if your event works and in this case
analytics recognized the event so it
works it fired and so therefore it's
going to show up under Behavior under
events you can go under overview or top
events okay and what am I going to look
for in this case I'm going to look for
header donate okay if I click on header
donate as my category I'm going to be
able to see my action and if I click on
action I'll be able to see my label in
this case homepage and then later on
when the data propagates in analytics
I'll be able to see under label the page
that I clicked on that head or donate
button which is slash our family okay
the second way in which you can test to
see if an event fires is if you preview
so if I click on preview in tag manager
okay I'm going to go into preview mode
okay and preview mode allows you to see
in analytics in tag manager and on the
website what tags are firing so here I
can see I'm in preview mode now so I'm
going to go to the website and I'm to
refresh and in my browser same browser
I'm using for tag manager I can see the
tags that are being fired on this page
already okay cuz I'm in preview mode so
here I can see remarketing I could see
page views I could see Google optimize I
could see some tags that are already
firing on this page now if I click on
this button here by holding down my
shift command and then click on that
button I'll be able to see that that the
tag fired in preview mode there's my
event header donate and I can see it
fired so now I can see it fired in the
preview mode so in addition to Google
analytics in preview mode I can see that
that tag is fired and I know that it's
working so there you have it you have
two ways to test to see if the event
fires again you have real time in
analytics okay so in real time if you
just go up to real time all you need to
do is go down to events go to your
website click on the button if you see
it firing in real time then you know it
works the second version or second way
to test your event is through the
preview mode okay if you see it firing
in preview mode then you know it's also
working okay so let's rehash our steps
first step is we want to be able to
identify what we want to track okay so
it could be this newsletter sign up it
could be click on a Facebook it could be
anything we want to be able to track an
image a click on a CTA button whatever
we want to track identify it second step
identify the category action and label
because that's what's going to show up
in Google analytics remember label is
optional variable or excuse me value is
optional third step go into tag manager
actually set up your tag and your
trigger so if you set up a tag and it's
an event name it g- event that way you
can see in your list of tags and tag
manager what event tracking you have
already set up so when you set up your
tag you set up your trigger your trigger
is based on logic that can be a URL it
can be a click ID it can be a class ID
whatever you want to use to fire that
event and then once you do that you want
to test it you could test it in GTM or
you could test it in Google Analytics if
it doesn't fire you want to tweak your
trigger if it does fire then great and
then one thing I would recommend is if
you're setting up various events for
your website as a best practice what I
would recommend is set up a spreadsheet
and in that spreadsheet you know you
want to put a note what's firing what
are you doing to fire it could be in
this case when somebody clicks on the
Donate Now button in the header you want
to put the tag name in here the type
okay then you want to record your
category action and label and then the
great thing about events is you could
turn those events into goals and that's
as simple as going back into analytics
okay so if I go in analytics and I go to
admin and I go to goals if you set up a
new goal okay all you need to do is
choose custom click continue you're
going to choose event as your goal name
and then from a naming perspective in in
Google analytics for your goal I would
definitely put event first and then
click on header donate okay so if I
click now continue what is my category
it's equal to header donate my action is
click and so I can verify to see if this
is working and here I can see in
analytics that the goal would have a 22%
conversion rate so that tells me that
the goal is working and I can turn this
event into a goal and when you turn
something into a goal and analytics then
you can measure it across all dimensions
that's what I would recommend if the
event is equal to a kpi or business goal
or it's of importance it's something you
really want to measure okay if it's just
a click say on a Facebook button I
wouldn't recommend setting that up as a
goal okay so once you've set up your
event you recorded it in your
spreadsheet it's firing you want to be
able to then go back into Behavior back
into events okay you can go to top
events okay so top events tell you by
category as a default what events are
firing or what category is firing the
most okay so if I choose my date range
here I can just go here to date so here
I can see my header donate button
fortunately for me has the most total
events now notied in analytics you also
see unique events events and so the
difference between unique events and
total events is that unique events are
equivalent to one per session where
total events means that somebody can
come to your website initiate a session
and click on that button multiple times
in the same session so if I go to the
Yama Foundation website okay I can click
on that donate Now button three or four
or five different times in the same
session so what analytics is going to do
is is actually in that session count it
once but accumulate the number of clicks
as a total event for that session so
you're always going to have more total
events than unique events because in
some cases users May click on the button
more than once in the same session and
so here I can see total events unique
events and if I added a value to that
event I should be able to see it here so
if I added a dollar as an example to
this particular event because it had 164
unique events I should be able to see
164 as my value but since I see Zero
that means that I did not assign value
and so average value basically is just
giving me how much average I have per
event so it's taking into account the
number of or the value the total value
divided by the total number of unique
page views or sessions and so because I
don't have value I'm not going to have
average value but here you could see
because value is optional here I can at
least see how many events or how many
clicks I receive for particular button
again it could be a video if I clicked
on this video as an example I can see
how many people actually started it I
could see the unique in the total events
and if I click on label if I have a
label assigned then I'll be able to see
what page triggered that event so if we
go back again to our header donate
button back to category if we click on
label as our primary Dimension here we
can see the homepage had the most unique
events Then followed by the children's
page the contact form Etc so what you
can do in analytics you can also look at
the pages that have driven events so
here I can see the home page has
accumulated the most total events
followed by the contact us so that's how
you would would look at the data in
Google analytics under Behavior under
events and then under top events or
overview is where you can start
analyzing your event tracking so first
you need to do identify it assign a
category action and or label set up that
tag and Trigger once you do that once
you test that it's working this is where
you going to go to analyze the data
let's start out with Y GTM so let's just
say your Sam and you have your own
eCommerce website and you want to
understand how people are interacting
with your website well Sam today's world
of websites contain a lot of
interactivity everything from videos to
PDF downloads to commenting to form
submissions uh to all sorts of chat
functionality interactivity going on
throughout the website so there's just a
lot that you need to to track outside of
just page views and so really what GTM
does is they help you track all these
things I just mentioned everything from
somebody clicking on the play button of
a PDF to somebody clicking on the submit
button of a form to somebody entering in
something on a chat function so that's
what GTM is so why GTM because it helps
us track all that interactivity so all
GTM is is really allows you to really
place a piece of java code which is just
script and this script that's added to a
web page to collect information so
that's really what a tag is it's just
some script that gets put on a web page
in order for you to collect information
like page views clicks Etc and they send
it to thirdparty tools okay so that's
what GTM does it it basically allows you
to take all these tags that collect
information and you can use them and GTM
so if you want to for example collect
how many people you know enter a chat
functionality and start chatting well
you're going to take that script and
you're going to put it in GTM and GTM
will then allow you to start tracking
that information so that's really what
GTM is it just allows you to put tags
into a container or think of it as a toy
box you have all these toys and you want
to track well you can put all those
those toys or tags and a toy box or
container and we're going to talk a
little bit more about that but before we
get into GTM let's just say you know
you're communicating with your developer
and there's a new user request on your
web page and you want to update the tag
well your developer considering it's
probably a small update to your website
is probably going to not um hesitate and
is going to go ahead and turn around and
do it normally and so normally what
happen happens is the developer is going
to go to the website and update the tag
well what if you have a few things that
you want to track all the things I
mentioned before from downloads to
clicks to you know somebody checking out
to watching a video well your Web Master
your web developer is going to go well
hold on a second now all these requests
are going to take time I need to put
them into the work CU so to speak well
what happens is when they go into work
CU usually it's going to take some time
and in some cases you as a marketer need
to launch a campaign and you want to get
that tracking uh added to the website in
time for the campaign launch so you want
to go ahead and quickly turn around the
tracking for that particular campaign
let's just say you're launching a
campaign and you're sending people to a
landing page that has a form submission
and you want to be able to track how
many people click on the submit button
of that form submission well if you need
to turn that around your developer is
like well I need to put that in a work
queue the timing isn't going going to
always work out between you and your
developer is my point and so that's
where GTM comes in because there is a
solution update your tags faster and
that's Google tag manager so when we say
GTM that's what GTM stands for Google
tag manager it's a place for you to add
tags quickly and easily so tags remember
are just Snippets of code that allow you
to track things on your website
interactively interactive actively and
basically when you have GTM you can buy
past the Web Master and do it quickly
and easily so that's what GTM is all
about so why GTM because we just
identified two benefits one you could
track all the interactivity on your
website and two you can bypass your web
developer or Web Master and so that's
the benefit of GTM so the benefit you
get those tags updated very quickly via
Google tag manager Okay so that's what
tag manager is so what we're going to
talk about today is specifically what
tag manager is and what it does we're
going to list some of the benefits of
tag manager we're going to show you how
it works and then we're going to show
you how to get started with tag manager
tag manager if you're not familiar with
working with web Masters and dealing
with JavaScript and tags and all this
jargon is just new to you today okay
well don't fret sit back we're going to
take it slow this is an intro uction
into Google tag manager again let's
start out with what is tag manager so
we've already introduced it to some
degree because we already introduced as
a tool where you can put all your tags
into a toolbox toy box or container so
to speak right and we already already
mentioned that hey you can bypass your
web master so you're probably thinking
well if I'm if you're not familiar with
tag manager how can I bypass my webmas
well first of all it's a free tool and
it's a Google tool hence the name Google
tag manager and it helps you really
that's the main point is deploy and
track tags on your website by passing
your web master so that's tag manager
and so examples of tags that can be
deployed via Google tag manager are
numerous these are just some examples
like Google analytics Facebook's pixel
tracking or Google ads There's No Limit
into the number of tags you can track
and tag manager there is no limit you
can add any number of track tags and tag
manager okay so some of the benefits
well again I we just listed two you can
put any tag into tag manager and track
that onto your website and we know you
can bypass your web developer or Web
Master and what it also does is it also
allows you to test and deploy your
JavaScript codes quicker so remember
these JavaScript codes or Snippets of
codes are just there to track certain
things on your website whether that be a
pay page view or somebody clicking on a
play button or tracking somebody who
converts or even just goes to your
website so the biggest benefit is you
can take that snippet of code let's just
say Facebook let's just say you're doing
Facebook marketing and you want to put
that Facebook pixel on your website so
that you could track people who come
from Facebook and convert well you don't
need to put that Facebook pixel on your
website you can go right to tag manager
and you can put that snippet of code
right in tag manager really quick
quickly and the other benefit here is
all tags are managed in one place and
that's that to me is really a good
benefit because when you start adding
tags on your website and you have some
tags and tag manager it just gets very
confusing so ideally all the tracking
code you have on your website needs to
be in tag manager think about that all
the tracking so if you're doing Bing or
you're doing Facebook or you're doing
Twitter you're doing LinkedIn and you're
doing Google you're doing all this type
of marketing on all these these
different platforms you're going to have
tracking code for all these different
platforms and instead of putting all
that code on your website return going
to slow down the slow low time of your
web page and website you want to put
them all in tag manager so they can be
organized and you know exactly what
you're trying to track and the other
great benefit of tag manager is there's
a versioning control so let's just say
you have added tags to your website via
GTM for the last 6 months well and let's
just say you another tag yesterday if
you added that tag yesterday and
something doesn't work well you can just
roll back to a previous version It's
that simple so you have versioning and
that's that's a good thing when you have
versioning you can control what gets
published and if something doesn't work
after it gets published then you can
roll back to a previous version so it's
a a piece of mind so to speak just
because you've add code to your site
there's no guarantee it's going to work
and so you can always control what
version you're dealing with in tag
manager and we'll talk a little bit more
about that that so the biggest benefit
here to me with tag manager is you have
event tracking and so we talked about
some of the things you could track on
your website from videos from play
buttons to somebody clicking on the stop
on the video or pausing it all the way
to somebody again chatting or let's just
say somebody clicking on that purchase
button on your website okay and you want
to track all these different things
these different interactivities and
buttons well event tracking is what
you're going to use to track all those
buttons and to me this is the biggest
benefit of tag manager and I'll show you
some examples as we go along and if we
didn't mention it already I'll mention
it again it is free tag manager is free
there's no limit so once you have tag
manager going you can add as many
tracking codes as you want there's no
limit on the number of tracking codes
you can add to tag manager okay so it's
free and you can use it to its fullest
Advantage okay so it's also high
security meaning that it has different
levels of permissions okay so you can
have uh somebody just go in and look at
the different tags and tracking codes
you have in GTM or you can ask somebody
who is very familiar with tag manager
and can go in and add the tracking code
to tag manager and then publish that
tracking code when it gets at it so
those are all the benefits let's talk
about how it works now specifically how
does tag Manager work CU you're like Rob
okay again a lot of jargon you know you
you got tags and JavaScript and and
versioning and Publishing and all this
other stuff well I know I'm throwing a
lot at you at once but just bear with me
here okay so let's start talking about
how it actually works so you have a
website okay whatever that domain is you
have a website and there's chances are
on your website you have some form of
interactivity whether that be a video
whether that be a Blog whether it be a
form submission you have a website with
some some interactivity and let's just
say you're even thinking about getting
ready to launch some type of campaign on
maybe Google or Facebook and you want to
drive traffic to your website fair
enough you're joining the millions of
other websites that are out there that
have interactivity that also Drive
traffic to the website so Inc comes
Google tag manager and so tag manager is
important because again we know we want
to track people coming from that
Facebook campaign or that Google
campaign interacting with our site so if
you are running Facebook and and you are
running Google analytics well guess what
you want to put that tracking code in
tag manager so Google analytics being a
Google product works very nicely with
tag manager Facebook has its own
tracking code and but you still want to
be able to track people who come from
the Facebook campaign to your website so
you're going to get that tracking code
from Facebook and put it in tag manager
that's generally how it works so here
information from your website is shared
with another data source through tag
manager so think about that if I add
Facebook tracking code to tag manager or
let's just say I had Google analytics
tracking code to tag manager tag manager
is the one that's pushing out and doing
all the heavy lifting they're the ones
that are controlling what code gets
fired and what code doesn't so if you're
putting the code in tag manager tag
manager is controlling the code think
about it that way and let's show you an
example of what that looks like so here
I am I'm in tag manager I just went to
tag manager. gooogle
and here I can see a list of tags so in
our conversation we're talking about
tracking Facebook and we're talking
about tracking Google analytics well
Google analytics is easy because it's a
Google product so here if I look at all
the different tracking code I have on my
website through tag manager let's just
take a look at Google analytics so if
you're going to use Tag manager you
might as well put the Google analytics
code in here so here I can see I have
Google Analytics as a tag in tag manager
now for Facebook if I'm running a
Facebook campaign well I can take that
pixel tracking and put it in GTM as well
and here I can see Facebook pixel that
is that code is added to GTM I just
basically took what Facebook gave me and
put it into Google tag manager so you
can see I can add Facebook and Google
analytics and again I can't stress it
enough any tracking code from any
platform I can add to Google tag manager
in order to track the behavior from
those sources so let's take a little bit
deeper dive into how tag manager works
so I just showed you an example of how
you could take Facebook and Google
analytics code and put it into tag
manager but if you're not familiar with
tag manager then how do I do that well
let's talk about the structure and how
tag manager works so when you have a tag
manager account you have a container
remember I mentioned toy box earlier you
have a bunch of toys if they're they're
code and you're tracking different bits
of code from different platforms like
Facebook think of those as toys and you
have a toy box okay well that's what
this code is and that's what a container
is the code is the code and that's going
to go into the toy box or container and
so the way tag manager works is you have
tags triggers and variables so if I take
my Facebook tracking code and put it
into a container I need to set up a tag
and a trigger okay okay so let's take a
look at what that is so first if I go
back to tag manager I'm going to have an
account and if I have an account I'm
going to have a container so here I'm
just going to click on an account with a
container and a container is nothing
more than what website you're adding the
tracking code to okay that's all the
container is we're just letting tag
manager know this is the website we're
adding all this code too so you have
tags triggers and variables that's
that's the structure of tag manager so
tags are just what it says tags what are
we trying to quote unquote tag well if
it's Google analytics that's easy here I
can see I have Google analytics added so
if I click on Google analytics here's my
tag and if I take a little bit of a
deeper dive there since Google analytics
is a Google product it integrates
already with tag managers it's pretty
easy I can just choose Google Analytics
then I'm going to check page view and
that's my tag now every tag needs a
trigger okay so I need to tell tag
manager how or when to fire the Google
analytics tracking code so in this case
I'm going to tell tag manager to fire on
all pages so if I get somebody a visitor
to my website analytics is firing on all
pages so whatever page that visitor
lands on Google analytics is going to
fire so that's really what it comes down
to is I have a tag and I need to tell
tag manager when to trigger that tag
that's really what the structure of tag
manager is it's tags triggers and
variables and variables what we're going
to talk about here in a couple minutes
but you have a piece of code you're
going to go ahead and put that into tag
manager you're going to tag it and then
you're going to fire that trigger so
let's take a look at another example
here if I go back here you can see
Facebook
well here's my Facebook pixel okay
that's my tag so when is it going to
fire well it's going to fire on a
specific domain or subdomain that's
basically what we're doing we're trying
to tell GTM when to fire that particular
tag so those are the three main
components a tag okay which is going to
contain the JavaScript code that you get
from say Facebook the trigger so you're
going to go into tag manager and tell
tag manager want to fire that code
that's the trigger and then you have
variables and so variables are basically
just additional information that tag
manager may need for your tag and
Trigger to work so that's what a
variable is it's there to get the tag
and Trigger to fire so variables are
divided into builtin and userdefined
variables so common used variables
include say page path or page URL or
host name or click class again they're
there and these examples I just gave you
are there to get your tag and Trigger to
work think about it that way they just
that's a component and if I go into tag
manager here and here on the left side I
can see variables so remember I have
builtin and user defined so builtin
means that tag manager already built
these for me so in case I need to get my
trigger to work with my tag I can use a
variable so those those are built in and
then I have user defined so these are
what I Define these are what I created
and again the variables are there to get
the tag and Trigger to work okay so
that's the job of the variable the job
of the tag is to host that JavaScript
code okay in the case of Facebook or
analytics that's where we're putting our
code so here if I click on AdWords
remarketing again it's a Google product
so I don't really need to even deal with
code I'm just going to select Google ad
words REM marketing okay so you could
see GTM integrates nicely with some of
the other Google products but let's just
say you have a Facebook pixel tracking
code you're going to choose custom and
you're going to put the code here so
that's part of the tag and then the
trigger again is there to get the tag to
fire so you're telling GTM when to fire
the tag and the variable is there to
help you make sure that that trigger and
that tag work together so that's how all
three
kind of work together you need the tag
to put the code you need the trigger to
tell GTM when to fire the tag and code
and the variables there to help you
define when that tag and Trigger should
work or how it should work so again
review tags are they just small codes of
JavaScript are tracking pixels on your
website and so tags are allowed to
manage events like scroll track and
remarketing clicks downloads files play
buttons you name it even clicks on
external links for example let's just
say you have a click uh or a Facebook uh
icon on your site and when somebody
clicks on it they go to Facebook you
want to maybe track that you're going to
create a tag okay the trigger is there
because you need to tell GTM when to
fire that tag so it's a certain
condition whether it's you know fire the
tag if the URL equals facebook.com or
some other condition so the tag cannot
be created until the creation of the
corresponding trigger so tag tags and
triggers go together you can't just
create a tag and not have a trigger
otherwise your tag will never fire and
then the variable is there again it
stores the information when defining a
trigger or transferring data to tag so a
variable has a variety of data okay so
you pick and choose the variable you
want to use with that trigger okay so
you're making sure that by defining a
variable you're making sure that you're
telling GTM how that trigger should be
fired so let's take a look at another
example here of how all three play
together if I'm in this account I'm in
this container if I look down here I can
see Google optimize that's another
Google product so what I'm doing here is
I just chose Google optimize as my tag
it's already integrated so what does
that mean I don't even need to deal with
any code I'm just going to select
optimize well we have the tag Google
optimize but we need to tell GTM how how
to fire that and so here we're going to
tell GTM to fire it on all pages so
that's basically a very simple example
because we're firing it on all pages so
if I want to look at something specific
again Facebook here's my tag here's my
code what's my trigger well my trigger
is it's going to fire on specific Pages
how do I know that well if I look at the
trigger here I could see the trigger is
a page view but but I'm telling it to
fire on this particular host name so the
tag and Trigger go hand inand so how to
get started with tag manager so first
things first you have to create that
account so you're going to go to tag
manager. google.com or you can do a
search for Google tag manager and you're
going to create your account and then
when you create your account what's
going to happen is you're going to set
up a container and when you set up a
container you have choices so you could
set it up for your website for an app on
iOS or maybe Android or you can even set
it up for& an accelerated mobile page so
most people by default are probably
going to set up tag manager for their
website and so when you do that when you
actually select website what's going to
happen is you're going to get some
Google tag manager code in return and so
the whole idea here is you're you're
going to do a swap what you're doing is
basically you're saying Okay Google I'm
going to take this Google tag manager
code and I'm going to put it on my
website I'm going to put it on every
page of my website so notice tag manager
has two scripts one goes in the head as
high as possible the other goes into the
body tag as high as possible and so what
you're doing is you're making a deal
you're putting this tag manager code on
your website and in return every code
code you deal with whether that be
Facebook or analytics or optimize or
remarketing or whatever it is is going
to go in GTM okay it's going to go into
the Container you created so you need
the tag manager code on your website in
order for tag manager to work okay so
when you add this code to your website
then you're free to start adding all
sorts of tags to your container but if
you don't have this tracking code on
your website then none of the tags you
add to your container are going to work
so that's the idea behind the container
and then one thing I wanted to mention
on the account is it's a Google account
so when you create your account then
make sure it's the same account you use
with say Google analytics or some other
Google product that's a good best
practice is always use the same email
address when you set up your account so
that it integrates nicely across all the
different platforms meaning you can go
from say Google analytics right to
Google tag manager in one browser
without having a log out or log in okay
so when you create the account you're
going to create your container if you
choose web then you're going to be asked
to place code on your website and when
you place that code on your website then
you are free to start using tag manager
and that means you're free to start
adding tags so if you want to know more
information about installing Google tag
manager then what I would recommend is
visit the quick start guide website of
GTM so again if you're curious as to
where that code is located in Google tag
manager well when you create an account
and you create a container that
container is going to have a specific ID
so if I click on that specific ID here's
where I can get my code okay so again
when I'm logged in to tag manager I'm
going to click on workspace but in the
top navigation I'm going to see my
unique GTM ID if I click on that that's
where my code is going to be located and
so again your code needs to go in the
header and there's another script that
needs to go in the body and if you're
not sure how to add the code to your
website well you can always click on the
quick start guide here okay and that'll
take you to a quick start guide page a
reference page related to Google tag
manager so let's talk about creating a
tag so once you get tag manager
installed I'm sure you're excited to get
going and create that first tag so so
let's talk about how to create a tag in
tag manager so when you're in tag
manager all you need to do is basically
you're looking at all your tags if you
click on tag in the left side navigation
you'll see all your tags and there's a
new button there so you just click new
and so basically what you're going to do
is you're going to create your first tag
and so what I would recommend once you
get tag manager installed on your
website I would recommend setting the
first tag up as Google analytics so that
will get you going with tracking page
views on your website when some when
somebody visits your website okay so
ideally that's what you want to do you
want to get Google analytics as your
first tag and tag manager so what I'm
going to do is because analytics is a
Google product it's already integrated
nicely with tag manager so I'm just
going to click on Google analytics it's
going to be a page view that's what I'm
tracking and now I have to set up a
variable and so what it's going to do
it's going to ask me to set a select a
variable and so what you're going to do
is you're going to select new variable
and what you're going to do is you're
actually going to go and add your
tracking ID here that's going to be your
variable so where do I get my tracking
ID in analytics well if I'm in analytics
I'm going to go to admin and then under
property settings I'm going to see my
tracking ID and all you need to do then
is go to tag manager and paste copy
first you got to copy over that tracking
ID then you're going to go to tag
manager and going to paste it and then
that's going to create a variable for
you and then when you create that
variable you're going to see it in the
drop down here so I've already created
it and basically that's your tag with a
variable then what are you going to do
you're going to set up a trigger so see
I have some triggers already set up
you're going to see a default trigger
already set up for you and that's going
to be all pages so ideally what you want
to do is you want to select all pages in
order for analytics to fire on all pages
so that's what we're doing we're setting
up a trigger we're basically telling tag
manager hey if I get a visitor to any
page on my website then I want you to
fire Google analytics so that's
basically in summary how to set up your
first tag and my recommendation is your
first tag should be Google analytics and
when you set up analytics you're going
to have to set up a variable for the
tracking ID and so you get the tracking
ID again from admin property settings
copy and paste that tracking ID over
save it you have your variable that
variable is going to be included in with
the tag and your trigger is going to be
all pages and there you go you have your
first tag you have your first variable
you have your first trigger so that's
basically what you want to do and once
you've added that tag once you've added
that trigger then the only thing you
need to do now is basically publish the
tag and so anytime you save a tag you're
going to go ahead and submit it so that
way it gets published so again what
you're going to do is let's take a step
back here you're going to choose new tag
you're going to choose analytics from
the drop-down menu you're going to
choose page view then basically you're
going to add your tracking ID so you
could set up the variable and then
basically that's what you need to do
okay you're going to add that tracking
ID and then voila that's your tag with a
variable and then once you've done that
then you're going to click submit so
when you click submit you're basically
saying Hey I want this tag to go live
now this tag and Trigger and once you've
done that then analytics is ready to go
and anytime somebody goes to your
website on any page tag manager is going
to fire Google analytics so the great
thing here is you have something called
Google tag assistant and that's an
extension that works with chrome and so
when you've actually added tag manager
to your site or you have analytics
running in tag manager you can confirm
if those tags are firing properly so
let's take a look at how Google tag
assistant works okay so if you just do a
search for Google tag assistant you're
going to see here that it's basically
just an extension that works in Chrome
and unfortunately it only works in
Chrome browser it doesn't work in any
other browser so go ahead and install
that extension into Chrome and when you
do that you're going to see this nice
icon here in your browser and now if you
go to any website and I click on Google
tag assistant and I click on enable Okay
so basically I'm loading Google tag
assistant and now once I refresh the
page I can see that this particular site
has Google tag manager installed and not
only does it have tag manager installed
I can see that it's also has Google
analytics running I have also Google
optimize running and I have Google ads
remarketing tag running in tag manager
so that's what tag assistant does it
allows you to see if one tag manager is
on the site and if it is great what
other tags are firing on this particular
site so tag assistants telling me I have
these particular tags firing on that
site and they're firing within tag
manager so tag assist is a great way to
confirm if one tag manager on the site
and two what other tags are firing on
the site now another way you could
confirm if tag manager is firing on the
site is you can go into preview mode so
even before you submit and publish your
tag and Trigger you can click on the
preview mode so if I click preview in
tag manager so basically that's going to
put me in preview mode and so what does
that mean well that means that now I'm
free to go to my website and see if
those tags are firing and so let's take
a look at what that looks like so if I
go to the website and just click refresh
then what's going to happen is tag
manager is going to load and preview
mode just as you see here okay so that's
going to take a second couple seconds to
load up and now what can I see in
preview mode I could see that I have GTM
firing but I also have some other tags
firing on on this page remarketing I
have Google analytics I have Google
optimize I have some other tags firing
as well and so the preview mode shows me
what tags are firing on any given page
and I can also see what tags did not
fire okay so here I have a number of
tags already in GTM but they didn't fire
on this particular page so let's just
say I clicked on the Donate Now button
I'm still in preview mode so I'm going
to be able to see what tags fired now I
could see I have a couple of tags that
I've fired on this particular page and
then I can see what tags did not fire on
this page okay so that's the preview
mode you can use the preview mode before
you even submit a tag and Trigger to see
if it fires and that's the great benefit
of tag manager so if you're not sure if
something's going to fire or not then
you can always go into preview mode um
and if you are sure it's going to fire
then you can go ahead and submit it so
you can leave pre preview mode and just
go ahead and submit that particular tag
and Trigger so here I'm going to leave
preview mode and now once I'm done and
I'm sure the tag is going to fire and go
ahead and submit all my changes that
I've worked on in terms of setting up
tags and triggers so that's really GTM
in a nutshell so I have my tags okay my
tags are just Snippets of code that I'm
going to put in whether that be Facebook
or vent tracking or any other Google
product like optimize or page view then
I have my triggers my triggers are there
to tell GTM when to fire that tag and
the variables are there to help those
tags and triggers work together so
remember that particular variable we set
up for Google analytics okay so here it
is right here because we want to tell
GTM what property to specifically fire
in Google analytics so that's why we set
up that variable but there are all sorts
of VAR variables Google tag manager has
built in or variables already created
for you or you can specifically Define a
variable so variables are there to help
the tags and triggers work together so
when you set up a tag you set up a
trigger you use a variable you can
always go into preview mode preview it
by going to the website seeing if it
fires if it fires then voila you can go
ahead and click submit and that will
publish the tag and Trigger and you're
good to go
that's pretty much how tag manager works
and again I can't stress that there's an
unlimited number of tags you can add to
tag manager there's no limit so you got
everything from anything from Google to
non- gooogle to event tracking okay to
Facebook to anything that you want to
track you want to be able to put into
tag manager and again there's versioning
that's one of the great benefits of tag
manager so if I want to go back back to
an older version I can simply do that so
here you can see I'm on version 32
that's how tag manager works and I can't
stress that you know tag manager is
there to help you track interactivity on
the site because if you have a site
that's interactive that has a video that
has a download button let's just say you
know you have all sorts of newsletter
signup Facebook YouTube buttons on your
website just like this website doeses
and you want to be a to track how many
people click on that particular button
well you're going to need tag manager
and when you have tag manager you're
going to be able to track all of these
button clicks and interactivity on your
website without tag manager it's going
to be hard to do that Google analytics
is a web analytics service offered by
Google it was launched back in
2005 it tracks and Reports website
traffic from the information through
Wikipedia Google analytics is the most
used web analytics Service as per the
sources in April
2022 Google analytics was used by
73% of the 10,000 most popular website
across the globe however as per the
reports from built
with.com
281 lakh
52477 live websites use Google
analytics so now this the time to
understand what has been changed in
Google analytics over the years if you
are new to Google analytics it's even
better before moving forward do
subscribe to Simply learn and hit the
Bell icon to never miss any updates from
Simply learn so what makes Google
analytics so important Google analytics
generates various types of reports and
helps to track bounce rates identify the
best content of your website record user
Behavior flow on your site and many
other
metrics thereby allowing you to
understand and build your business
strategies thereby growing your business
now that you have understood why Google
analytics is essential let's check what
we have for you in this
video first we will understand what is
Google analytics for then we will move
forward with identifying Google
analytics version for your website next
we will have a detailed look at
Universal analytics and Google analytics
4 we will continue by understanding
success stories from Google analytics 4
users and finally we will end this
session by understanding the future of
Google analytics for so allow me to
introduce the next generation of Google
analytics Google analytics 4 also known
as ga4 initially Google analytics 4 was
known as app plus web Google analytics 4
is the latest analytics property with
several advantages over the old Google
analytics also known as universal
analytics understanding more clearly
Google analytics 4 can measure and keep
track of website traffic as well as app
usage so now you can imagine that Google
analytics 4 is the One-Stop solution for
all your analytics needs if you're are
still using Universal analytics we
recommend you to get familiar with
Google analytics 4 as
well as this is the new future of
analytics we will understand creating
and setting up Google analytics for
account in detail in the upcoming videos
let's first identify which Google
Analytics property is associated with
your website in order to identify which
Google analytics property you have log
into your Google analytics account now
go to analytics
account and then open properties and
apps here you can see properties for
your
website now below the properties and
apps several properties are listed
where you can see different IDs if the
ID starts with UA and ends with a number
then you have a universal analytics
property however if ID only has
numbers like
here then you have Google analytics for
property we will learn how to switch the
universal analytics account to Google
analytics 4 in the upcoming videos now
that you have understood how to identify
Google analytics property let's take a
detailed look at the comparison of
universal analytics data and Google
analytics for
data the major difference between
Universal analytics and Google analytics
4 is the measurement model Universal
analytics uses sessions and Page views
as the measurement model whereas Google
analytics 4 uses events and parameters
as the measurement model therefore any
hit type from Universal analytics
property say a page view user timing ET
are captured as event in Google
analytics for property let's see the
detail comparison of every aspect of
universal analytics and Google analytics
for first we go with
events in analytics every measurable
action for example page load form
completion Scrolls app installs Etc is
measured as event an event has category
label and action in Universal
analytics moreover it has its own hit
type in case of Google Analytics for
there is no categorization all the hit
types from Universal analytics are
considered as
events now let's find the comparison of
universal analytics and Google analytics
4 in terms of page views page views is a
metric defined that calculates total
number of pages viewed on your website
now let's get a better understanding of
page views for instance when user lands
on a web page of your site the page
loads this is considered to be a page
view now suppose if user reloads the
page Google analytics tracks it as
another page view if the user navigates
to another page of your website and
returns to the same page this adds
another page view to your site now that
you have understood page views let's see
how page views differs in Universal
analytics and Google analytics for from
Universal analytics page view are
translated to Google analytics for
property as page view
event this page view event automatically
gets triggered in Google tag
manager the next metric we have is
sessions session is the time duration
for which user is active on your website
a universal analytics session May
consist of multiple page views events
e-commerce transactions Etc the session
is considered to be ended if the user
has 30 minutes of inactivity or any
other event for which session end is
triggered in Google analytics 4 session
metrics are tracked from session start
event which automatically gets triggered
with the basic interaction on your
website however the session duration
depends on the period between the first
and the last event now let's check our
next metric which is custom
dimension in Universal analytics custom
Dimension add the information to the
collected
data whereas in Google analytics 4
information is added through through the
event
parameters moving ahead the next metric
we have is content grouping content
grouping in Universal analytics allows
to group content into a logical
structure after which one can view and
compare metrics by the group name now
talking about Google analytics 4 it has
predefined event parameter for Content
group this parameter fills the data into
content group moving ahead head the next
metric we have is client ID client ID is
a unique string generated randomly and
acts as a sorous identifier client ID
identifies the browser instance and then
it gets stored in the browser
cookies and therefore subsequent visits
to the same site are associated with
that user in both Universal analytics
and Google Analytics four client ID
serves the same purpose that is the
client ID is responsible for providing
the
identifier now let's move ahead with our
next
metric
parameters parameters are associated
with Google analytics for
properties understanding in detail about
parameters parameters are the chunk of
information that specifies the user
action
for example parameters can be passed to
describe the value of the purchase next
we have is user property user properties
provide information like preferred
language or geographical location of the
users that interact with your website or
app now that we have seen difference
between Universal analytics and Google
analytics for properties the question
definitely arises
can Google analytics really bring
success to your
business well if you have a good
understanding of your audience and have
extraordinary strategies to work on the
Google analytics is your best companion
here are some success stories by Google
analytics for users we all know about
McDonald's the leading fast food
cooperation with huge number of outlets
across the globe recently a case study
has been shared by McDonald's Hong
Kong which suggests that the company has
experience growth in conversions by
550% through the inapp orders and what
made them achieve such a great
growth yes you guessed it right it's
Google analytics 4 let's have a look on
their success story the major goal for
the company was to redesign the strategy
to increase inapp food orders predict
the behavior of inapp audiences and
reach the right customers with
McDonald's mobile order campaigns to
achieve the goals McDonald used a simple
yet smart approach and implemented
Google analytics for properties with the
help of predictive audiences in Google
analytics for properties they tried
converting audience es into
customers moreover with the help of
Google ads they were able to manage the
campaigns as a result of the smart
efforts McDonald was able to gain
increase in conversions by
550% for the users who are likely to
purchase in next 7 days isn't it amazing
moreover for the same audience
McDonald's had noticed a visible
decrease in cost per action by
63% and an increase in Revenue by 560
per. some other companies that have seen
growth in their business through Google
analytics for includes PepsiCo claros
shop Etc with the proven success of top
brands in the world let us know what the
future of Google analytic 4 holds as per
the reports on buil with.com there are
281h
52477 live websites that are using
Google analytics out of which there are
1 21 lak
73,4 live websites from USA and 4 lakh
68538 live websites from India who are
using Google Analytics if you look in
detail we have a list of big names like
Bank of America blogger.com
Cisco
Netflix
corser
Flipkart ICICI Bank Tesla India
IRCTC mintra Etc that are using Google
analytics for their growth however we
are all well aware of the success
stories of all the biges on the list
thus Google analytics will continue to
be an important part of new business
strategies so if you are looking to grab
a successful career in digital marketing
and learn search engine optimization
simply learn has got you covered with a
wide range of topn digital marketing
courses these courses make you skilled
in SEO content marketing PPC social
media marketing and much more with
hands-on experience in the tools like
Google analytics keyword planner Sim
rush and there's a huge lust on the
board however one year of experience is
preferred to enroll in these courses
find the cost Link in the description
box during our childhood we have heard
the fictional stories of robots taking
over various household courses making
the lives of humans easy peasy but if
you're not aware then these fictional
stories are turning into reality though
not in the form of physical robots but
yes in the form of computer programs and
apps with the help of artificial
intelligence and machine learning
Technologies confused let me introduce
to you to chat GPD a pre-trained model
that interacts with user in a
conversational way chat GPD is founded
by open Ai and the model is based on
supervised and reinforcement learning so
are you excited to know more about chat
GPT chat GPT has various applications in
various domains in this video we are
going to see the application of chat GPT
in the SEO domain also we are going to
discuss how chat GPT will play an
important role in search engine
optimization so here is a question for
you chat GPT is based on which of the
following GPT models created by open AI
option one chat GPT one option two chat
GPT 2 option three chat GPT 3 and option
for none of the above let us know your
answer in the comment section below and
if your answer is correct you will get a
heart from Simply learn as we discussed
earlier Chad jpt is the application of
artificial intelligence and machine
learning if you are looking to get
certified into Ai and machine learning
then here at simply learn we have a
certification course for you so before
we move ahead consider subscribing to
our Channel and hit the Bell icon to
never miss any updates from simp simply
learn we know that SEO rankings depends
on various factors like on page
optimization off page optimization and
more while using Chad GPT we will
understand how chat GPT helps in various
Su ranking parameters and reduces the
manual work so without any further delay
let's begin so to begin with let's open
chat
GPT
we need to go to new chat which is
already open
here let's start by we will try to
demonstrate an SE optimized uh blog in
this demonstration so let's get some
keyword ideas for the blog so before
that let's choose what kind of blog we
want to create I really love traveling
so let's try to create a travel blog so
for the travel blog we will find some
good keywords
it's
so here you can see we are getting some
suggestions for the travel destinations
we can choose any of
them okay so here we got around uh seven
of the
results so let's try to get something
for
Japan soest me good keywords to create a
blog on
Japan
okay so what I understand from this is
we are just getting few of the random
keywords okay so it
is it is showing that these keywords
cover a range of topics related to
Japanese culture history food and
more uh out of these I guess we can
start with the places here are few
places like Mount
Fiji Tokyo and everything so let's try
to create a
blog on top 10 places to visit in
Japan
okay so we are getting places to visit
in
Japan
let's try to get keywords related to top
10 places in
Japan
okay so we are getting some of the
keyword
recommendations and it is also
suggesting that by using these keywords
our content will be more dis
discoverable and it will be easy for
rank for for for search for for search
rankings write me a Blog on top 10
places to
visit in
Japan so the idea is we will try to
write a blog and after which we will try
to uh optimize the blog with respect to
the keyword top 10 places to visit in
Japan and we will also uh see whether
all the SEO practices can be easily
applicable or not using chat
gbt
so here you can see we are getting a
Blog with a introduction with top 10
places and probably what I expect is to
get a good conclusion out of
it also like uh uh chat jpt provides you
the facility so that you can reduce the
length of your content the textual
content the blog or article or anything
you want uh to several number of words
like if the this Blog has 2,000 or 5,000
words you can just ask chat GPD to
reduce it to 2,000 or th000 words
also so here you can see that before
when we searched there were only one
liners about these destinations these
places in Japan and now we are getting a
detail about all the 10
places
definitely itely we have targeted this
blog for the uh keyword top 10 places to
visit in Japan however we can ask for
some more keywords to increase its
reach
suggest few more
relevant keywords for my
block okay so we are getting some more
keywords
here
for any blog it is really important to
have a very good title so we will try to
implement a catchy title for this
blog
as a good title helps the user to click
on your content and it uh increases the
possibility to get more and more
traffic so here you can see the title is
completely keyword optimize our keyword
is top 10 places to visit in Japan and
here I can see most of the suggestions
most of the suggested titles have the
keyword top 10 places or top 10
destinations which is somewhat similar
to what we are
expecting add the best
suitable title in my
blog okay so we are getting something
different here The Ultimate Guide to
Japan's in gems 10 places you can't miss
okay so here we got title for a Blog but
here we can see there is a slight
limitation that it is suggesting the
title but it is not adding it to our
blog and representing it again to us
optimize my
blog for the
keyword top
10 places to visit in Japan top 10
places to visit in
Japan with an
optimized
title
for
okay so we have to do it manually it's
not able to add the title in the
blog
optimize blog for
the
keyword top 10 places to visit
and
okay so here it is showing the relevant
suggestions so maybe there is a
slight ambiguity in the query that's why
it's not representing us the correct
results
we are going to optimize our blog using
all these
factors visit in Japan
again these are the
suggestions
let's try to implement these one by
one add headings H1
H2 in the above
blog so yes we are getting the updated
versions having H1 and
H2 and yes you can see easily that the
title of the blog is in H1 and the rest
are maybe in
H2 H1 and H2 tags are some of the
practices in the on page optimization
which uh helps the search engine boards
to understand that this is something
important really important uh for the
page and they pick up these hints for uh
getting your uh page
rank so yes it is
implemented
e
okay so our blog is completed with H1
and H2
implementations
let's try to get some interlinks for
this blog interlinks have their own
importance as interlinking your blog
with other pages of your website or your
blogging Pages this will help you to
gain the traffic from other pages to
your blog and uh uh putting the traffic
from your blog to other pages of your
website also it helps the search engine
boards to understand the crawl structure
understand the website structure also
so suggest me
few
interlinks for the above
blog so yes definitely these are the
relevant and uh expected links we are
getting so if you have any of these uh
blog pages in your uh website or if you
have created any of these blogs earlier
do Interlink
it
which of the
above can I use in my blog so definitely
there are number of suggestions but if
you want to choose one how can you pick
the one let's see if we get the relevant
thing for
this
okay so it is not not only suggesting
that we can use all of the above but it
is also showing the significance of
interlinking okay moving
ahead so till now we have optimized our
blog for a keyword top 10 places we have
try to get some of the keywords relevant
to the uh top 10 places to visit in
Japan we have added headings and we have
tried to get some of the good Interlink
suggestions to add interlinks in our
blogs which are some of the good
practices of the on page optimizations
so next moving ahead in another onpage
optimization technique is let's try to
get a cover image for this
blog so by by getting a cover image
suggestions we will try to implement the
image optimization technique for our
blog
page
okay so it is showing uh some of the
suggestions related to the diversity of
the country theoric view of Tokyo
Skyline the beautiful image of koto's
traditional Temple Mount Fuji
hiroshima's peace Memorial
Park so we will try to pick one and uh
see if we are getting any image
idea let's take for Mount
Fuji suggest me the email
idea for
Mount so let's see we have seen in
generic for all now let's see for this
uh image suggestion specific to Mount
Fuji okay definitely it is showing a
number of suggestions for the specific
Mount Fuji
image so if you are looking to create
another block for Mount Fuji then these
ideas are easy to take
up
optimize the
mount
Fugi image for my
blog here are some tips to optimize the
image for Mount Fuji for my blog which
are they're showing that the image
should be high
resolution then a clear
subject definitely if you have a large
image a large file size it really get
gets difficult to load and the page load
speed will increase so if you have a
large file size the image should be
compressed without reducing its quality
image
quality we should have descriptive file
names and all
tags
okay so let's try to get a very good
file name and all tag also we'll try to
implement a good caption because adding
a caption is very good in the uh when
considered as a
user
so get me
good
image title
and ALT tag
for Mount Fugi
image so there is importance for tag as
search engines are the Bots uh they
won't able to identify the image
directly so Al tags helps the search
engines to understand what the image is
about so yes it is showing not one but
number of suggestions for all the Mount
Fuji recommendations which we got
earlier so we will try to choose one and
get a caption for
it write a
good
caption
for for the
image
Scenic
Fugi five laks
region so yes definitely we're getting
suggestions
here
I guess this caption is quite long so
let's try to reduce it to 40
words reduce the above caption
to not even 40 let's do it in 20 20
words okay this one is
better now let's try to get the image if
there is
any
choose the
mount fui image for my
blog choose image it should not I
repeat
choose the perfect
illustration
for Mount
fui image for
my
blog so you can see here that it is not
choosing any image but it is again
providing us the suggestion what we can
choose
again this is the limitation that it is
not showing us any of the image we will
try to put it in another way to get an
image if it really works we can get
it
okay so it is not possible to download
or get an image representation using
chat
GPT we can only get the recommendations
to choose the image and yes it is
showing some suggestions of un unsplash
pixels or shut shock to download the
image so we can uh really navigate to
these websites and download some of the
required
image for our blog so we we have uh
completed here with the image
optimizations let's try to get some
video ideas because again having a video
is a catchy factor for the users
visiting your
website or your blog
page suggest me suggest video ideas for
the
above
blog okay so if we are getting few of
the video
ideas
which of the above idea is best match
for my blog let's try to extract anyone
from the
above okay so it is completely dependent
on the user's Choice what a user wants
so here I'll
choose
for again we will continue with Mount
Fuji
only provide video optimization
optimization
ideas video
optimizations
for Mount Fuji video for above
blog okay so it is showing us some of
the suggestions which uh which we can
Implement for a video as we do not have
any video here we can just take these
recommendations and optimize whatever
the video of our
choice so let's take the thumbnail
suggestions in our next query uh if it
can suggest us a mount fusy uh thumbnail
uh image suggestion uh and the video tag
suggestion
right suggest
me
good thumbnail idea for Mount
Fuji
video thumbnails have the Major Impact
for any videos it is the only thing uh
I
repeat
thumbnails thumbnails are one of the
important factors which encourages the
user to click on your video and watch
the complete
video so definitely having a good
thumbnail will help your content to
rank so yes we have got around 10 of the
thumbnail ideas from which we can
Implement any one uh
as of the video we are having for our
blog so we are done with the thumbnail
ideas after which we will get we will
try to get video tags so for getting
video tags let's get for all of
them find
me
video tags
for the all of
above
thumbnail
suggestions tags are important to help
the user to get your videos in the
search
list like if someone uh
uh types Mount Fuji in the search box
and if the Mount Fuji keyword is or a
tag is added to your video tag it is
more likely to get searched and appear
in the search results and possibly user
may click on
it
so here we have tried to get uh try to
implement some of the good uh some of
the important um on page optimization
practices now let's try to get back
links which is one of the most famous
off page optimization
technique above
block okay so it is
showing some of the link
suggestions so basically back links are
the
links which points from another website
or another web page to your web page or
your website so getting backlink uh is
one of the trust factors in the search
engine eyes that your content is really
unique and more of more users wants to
read it and share it with another uh
users so the search engines by by by
these search engines understand that
your content is really good and it is
worth of ranking so definitely getting a
good backlink from a very good authority
websites is uh fruitful for your
content so let's try to
get which
pages on web are
suitable to get backlinks for my
blog
so here we are getting some of the ideas
or suggestions that which Pages we can
choose to get a backlink so here is
industry specific websites so if you are
writing a travel blog there should be a
travel trip ad uh Trip Advisor like
websites uh which are showing more of
the trip oriented or bookings related
oriented for travel or uh
destinations there are few of the
directories okay government websites
which are the tourism websit in our case
right
now blogging websites and social media
platforms which can be relevant to the
current scenario which we are using here
so let's check how can we get
backlinks from
the
above recomendation
for my
blog okay guest
posting broken link
building okay these are some of the
backlink building methods which we are
getting so that we can find one and get
one of the black uh I
repeat
so these are some of the backlink
building strategies which we are getting
in the recommendation so we can
Implement any of these to get a backing
for our
block let's choose the specific platform
and try try to get the
recommendations or the ideas to get back
links for the from the blogging
site so we can Implement these ideas and
it it may be possible to get
backlinks
now that we have got some of the ideas
to get backlinks for our blog blog let's
try to add the catch metadata for our
blog metadata like having meta title or
meta description these are the only uh
data which is uh which is appearing in
the search results as you you have seen
that in the search result the link the
Blue Link we get is the meta title of
our blog page or a website page or any
page on the web whereas a few lines
written below that link is the meta
description that we are providing to let
the user know that what the blog is
exactly about so it is considered to be
a good practice to have the targeted
keyword in the title as well as in the
description so let's try to get
one
s
the cre
SE
optimize meta title and
meta description for my
blog so we are getting some suggestions
here top 10 places to visit in Japan
discover the best place to visit in
Japan top 10 destinations definitely we
have your top 10
destinations
see also we are getting some of the
notes
that it is good to have meta title less
than 60 characters so if if it is more
than 60 character you may get the dot
dot part and the title will not be
clearly visible in the search result
page so let's try to again optimize The
Meta title and meta description for top
10 places to visit in
Japan description for the key
word top
10 places to visit in Japan
okay so we can use any of the one the
one we have got the recommendation the
previously and this one also both are
completely relevant to our
content so one of the technical SEO
factor which we are going to see here is
getting the URL
recommendation uh URLs are the important
factor uh it helps the search engine
boards to understand about the page as
the URL is the first thing search
engines may be visiting to come to your
page so uh it is a good practice to have
the keyword in your url rather than
having some of the abrupt characters
like x a r
at the rate these kind of stuffs in the
link so let's
create the URL
suggestions suggest
me SEO
optimized URL for the above
block
see so here we are getting top 10 places
to visit in Japan which is definitely
our blog and as a keyword we are using
it to optimize our content and it is
placed in the URL so this URL is
completely
correct also these kind of suggestions
are very good for the newbies in the
uh search engine domain as they will
definitely understand why and what we
are doing to optimize our
pages so next moving ahead with some of
the non-technical aspects which may
impact which may definitely impact to
bring the traffic so let's try to get
some of the sharing suggestions
like which
platforms should I
I I
repeat which sharing
options should I add in
my
block so out of the mentioned uh sharing
buttons we can add any of them adding at
least three to four sharing buttons is
considered to be really good out of
which there are many common like
Facebook is really common then redit is
really very common watchup Shares are
really common Twitter Shares are really
common so you can choose any of these to
add it in your
blogs D
commenting on
my blog
impact
on traffic source so here we are taking
the suggestion that will this help or
not again this is again linked to the
back links that if we are adding the
comment section someone else may ask for
a backing for their web and this is
again uh going in symbotic way like if
they are asking for a backlink for from
your blog you can even ask from
them so this is a way of or a part of a
communication to get a back links as
well can you find
the
duplicate
content in above blog so duplicate
content is a concept where search
engines you you must be aware that
search engines are really in love with
the unique content so having a duplicate
content may
really uh affect your uh uh web
visibility and it is possible that your
page may get dead after a
time so plagarism is not at all allowed
uh when you're creating a Content it is
not suggested in any
case okay so it is not uh able to uh
Char is not able to identify the
duplicate content however uh it is
suggesting us some of the tools like
copy scape or sideliner to understand if
the content we are creating for our blog
is duplicate or
not and let's get some suggestions how
to
make
content
unique just in case if someone is not
aware to created unique
content we can get some of the tips
here
okay so we have got some of the
suggestions Also let's try to uh see one
of the other aspects of technical Su
that is 404 Pages 44 pages
are really not are not likely to get
searched
because I repeat
let's try to see another aspect of
technical
Su uh try to find some 404 pages on the
website
so from this I can understand that
though we have not posted any blog link
or any uh internal links that leads to
that blog which we are expecting this is
not the clear idea we are providing but
yes uh to find 404
Pages uh it is not possible for the chat
GPT to get one but we can use uh some of
the tools suggested like uh screaming
frog or Google search console where we
get the detailed report of the broken
links or 44 pages that is the dead pages
of our
website so let's wrap up from the uh
view of the technical SEO
perspective let's consider one of the
scenario that we have published this
blog and how can we promote this blog to
reach more of the relevant audience so
okay so we are getting some of the
recommendations that we can share our
blog on social media reach to the
influencer uh add it as a guest
post and Link back to this this blog
email marketing yes it is the most
trending technique to reach more of the
audiences paid advertising
commenting content
syndication yes medium and Linkedin are
the very famous platforms for this
online
communities so you can you can
definitely U try to be the member of the
online communities and forums where you
can just put up the link and the members
of your Niche may definitely visit your
content and share it with others
also so yes we we have seen that uh
search for as as a perspective of search
engine optimization chat GPT is uh
helpful really really helpful to create
the in content Creation in optimizations
and many of the the other things is your
website not ranking as you thought it
would are there too many competitions
out
there is it getting difficult to capture
relevant
audiences are the solutions suggested
too
expensive do not worry in this video you
will get easy solutions to all your
questions as we have come up with the
list of top 10 SEO tools that anyone can
use and the best part is you need not to
spend a single penny on these tools Yes
you heard it right they are free of cost
and are very useful for anyone who wants
to start an online business or
struggling to improve reach so let's
jump right into the list but before we
do kindly subscribe to our Channel
simply learn and hit the Bell icon to
never miss on such interesting and
useful videos
to carry out best SE practices the first
free tool on our list is the Keyword
Planner Keyword Planner is a free
keyword research tool provided by Google
proper keyword research is important as
it increases the possibility to rank
well on the search result Pages the
Keyword Planner will help to disc
discover new keywords estimate monthly
searches a keyword has get the cost of
ads for the keyword you're looking for
and help to organize keywords let's
understand how to use Google Keyword
Planner open your AdWords account now go
to the tools section and select Keyword
Planner now you can either add a keyword
to get new insights or upload a CSV file
to get search volumes of already known
keywords let's see how it
works click on discover new
keywords from here you can change the
location enter the key phrase for which
you need keyword
insights click on get
results
here you can see all the keyword ideas
related to your keyword
phrase now to get the search volumes of
already known keywords go to the Keyword
Planner and click on get search volume
and
forecast now upload your CSV file from
here here you will get search volumes
for all the
keywords
other similar tools with free trials
include keywordtool.io
and keyword generator by
RFS to know trending ideas you can use
Google Trends whereas to get title ideas
you can use the answer the public tool
which is free now let's see the next
tool in the
bucket Google search console Google
search console is a free web master tool
provided by Google it is important to
timely monitor your website and make it
error free this is where Google search
console comes into the picture it helps
businesses to Monitor and maintain their
websites presence in Google search
results some features of Google Search
console in
includes getting confirmation that
Google search engine can crawl your
website fix the problems in page
indexing send Pages for
reindexing can view Google search
traffic data records the number of times
your website appears in the search
results records the search queries for
which website appears in the search
result shows the list of sites linking
to you and many
more let's Now understand how to use
Google search
console here the total Impressions
suggests that number of times your
website appears in the Google search
results whereas the total clicks suggest
that number of times your website is
clicked from the Google search result
page from the coverage section you will
get to know all the errors occur during
The
Crawling we recommend you to try Your
Hands On Tools like Bing web master tool
and RFS which is free for website
owners next up we have the used SEO
plug-in used Su plugin helps in
improving your search results ranking it
has a free as well as a paid version as
a beginner you can quickly check the
free
version it has an inbuilt feature that
automatically carries out SE analysis
and readability analysis and
automatically adds structured data let's
take a quick look at SEO
plugin from here you can add SEO
title from here you can edit the slug
slug is the part of URL you can add the
necessary keyword here in the meta
description section you can add the meta
description which all together looks
like
this where this part is your slug the
keyword you want to add in your page
should be added in the focus keyphrase
section the SEO analysis section shows
the SEO improvements in your content now
moving towards the readability
analysis readability analysis shows
Improvement in the text ual content of
the page if both the indicators are
green then your SEO and readability both
are good to go for used SEO we have
covered the significant features and now
we will understand one of the essential
SEO tools Google
analytics website tracking plays an
important role in SEO it helps in
understanding the user behavior on your
website Google analytics is an Analytics
tool used for tracking a
website the standard version of Google
analytics is free we can integrate
Google analytics with Google
ads the main features of Google
analytics include tracking session
duration of users pages per session and
tracking website traffic and bounce rate
of
users let's take a quick tour of Google
analytics here you can see reports of
users for last 7
days now go to the report section in the
dashboard
you can reset the time span to get the
desired data from
here go to
retention when you can see the number of
new users and the number of returning
users to your
website to know the data on monetization
go to the monetization
section here you can see the
monetization data for the selected time
span we will understand Google analytics
features and how it works in the
upcoming videos in detail moving ahead
with the next tool which is small SEO
tools pism
Checker duplicate content is hated by
search engines if not taken seriously
this could hurt your search rankings the
plagarism Checker detects duplicate data
in your content and shows its
source you need to open this pleasure
arism
Checker here you can add your content
manually
after adding your content manually you
just need to undergo a
verification and click on check
plagarism
and here we get the results the content
is 100% unique in case if we get any
duplicate content we can check the
sources from
here as our content is unique we are not
getting any results
here in case if you don't want to enter
your content manually you can upload the
document file from here
note that this Checker checks for the
top thousand words of your content so in
case of lendy content you can break the
content and then check for its
uniqueness in case you don't want to
purchase the pro version moreover you
can also add a page URL to check the
uniqueness of the content the page has
over here and follow the same process by
clicking on the check plagarism
button the plagarism Checker by gramar
is also one of the free tools used for
checking uniqueness in the content the
next tool that we have in our bucket is
the paid speed
insights for the data provided by go
Google the bounce rate increases to
32% as the page load speed increases
from 1 to 3 seconds page speed insights
is the page speed check tool PID speed
insights is used to test the speed of a
web page and it is a free service
offered by Google developers results of
PID speed insights show what real users
are experiencing about your page on
mobile devices and desktops to
understand how to use it let's go to PID
speed insights and select the URL of the
website for which you want to undergo
the check enter the URL and click on
analyze
button
now choose whether you wish to undergo a
check for mobile or desktop device here
I'll select a desktop
device just in few seconds you will get
the required result
another tool that we can use is tools.
pingdom doccom which has free as well as
paid versions moving forward to the next
magic tool which is sem
rush to grow your business it is
essential to keep an eye on what your
competitors are doing this will help you
to understand their strengths and
Implement similar strategies for your
business as well for this you need to
carry out competitor analysis sem Rush
is the competitor analysis tool that
gives a complete work through the
competitors's data like
keywords back links top performing
content campaigns
Etc it has free as well as paid versions
you can access free trials by simply
signing up on semrush.com
so let's take a quick overview of how it
works
log to your sem Rush
account here enter the URL of your
competitor
here you can choose a geographical
location for which the analysis is to be
performed by adding URL you get all the
competitor data here I have added sem
Rush as a competitor so we are getting
so many details of sem Rush The Organic
keywords the organic track traffic paid
keywords paid traffic referral domains
and Authority
score we can add a competitor as well
from
here now here you can see the data of
both sem rush and
RFS
other than sem rush you can use
spyfu which has some free daily trials
now let me tell you about an excellent
auditing
tool which is screaming
frog dear Learners it is essential to
know how your website is performing and
for this you need to carry out frequent
website
audits screaming frog is a website a
auditing tool that works similar to web
crawlers it has free as well as paid
versions some features of free version
include finding broken links errors and
redirects analyzing page title and
metadata href Lang attributes auditing
finding duplicate content Etc with a
crawl limit of 500
URLs let's know more about it go to
screaming frog
now from here download the tool on your
system check various resources
provided on how to learn the tool from
here another alternative tool you can
use for auditing is suil
where you can enter the URL and get the
audit reports moving further with
another free tool which is rf's backlink
Checker gaining high quality backlinks
is an essential factor for SEO ranking
as it shows the trust of other websites
in your content moreover it helps in
building the authority of your website
with the help of backlink Checker you
get the data of all the websites linking
to your website rf's backlink Checker
shows the data of top 100 backlinks top
five anchors and top five pages
including total number of backlinks and
referring domains in its free version
let's have a quick look at the
tool here let's take example of
wikipedia.com
so here we are checking backlinks for
now click on check
backlink
here we got details of backlinks for
wikipedia.com
alternatives to rf's backlink Checker
are SCM Rush backlink Analytics tool and
Su ability by signing up with these tool
tools you will get some free trials for
your site last but not the least let's
know about the mobile SEO tool which is
mobile friendly test studies show that
in year 2020 60% of traffic was through
mobile devices thus it is essential to
keep your website mobile friendly as
well here is when the mobile friendly
test comes into
action
it helps to check if your website is
mobile friendly or not go to mobile
friendly
test and enter the URL of your
website suppose I enter here
www.wikipedia.com now click on test
URL
here you get the
results we can see that the page is
mobile
friendly to check more details you can
navigate to your search console
account well if you think we are done
for today then then then keep watching
this video as we have two B bonus tools
for
you so here comes the first
one the
serator search results vary with mobile
devices also your brand ranking May
differ from country to Country to get
reports on this serator will be your
alltime companion it shows how search
results May differ for mobile devices or
location a s let's see how it
works go to
serator now let's fill in the required
fields
now let's select the
location let's run the live
test and here we get the
results that's it daily you can run
three free life test isn't this
amazing without taking a minute let's
know about the second bonus tool
which
is the rich results
test you must have seen these kinds of
search results on search
Pages let's dive deep into
it yes these type of results are known
as Rich results
to check whether your site is optimized
for Rich results go to Rich results test
and add the URL of your
website let's add the URL of Simply
learn now click on test
URL
complete the
verification and check the
report so here we can see that simply
learns website is eligible for Google
gole searches Rich
results to monitor Rich results for your
complete website you can easily navigate
to your search console
account with tough competition to rank
on the search engines and app stores
there is a huge demand in industry for
SE
experts there are various types of roles
in SEO some popular ones are
SEO associate SEO analyst SEO executive
SEO manager and SEO
expert let's first talk about SEO
Associates SEO associate is responsible
for performing keyword research and
implementing SE strategies to improve
organic
ranking the average base pay of an SEO
associate in US is between dollar 59,000
to 80,000 perom and in India is 228,000
rupees per
anom next is SEO analyst SEO analyst is
responsible for keyword research
competitor analysis tracking organic
traffic and conversion rate the average
base pay of an SEO analyst in the US is
between1 48,000 to 78,000
perom and in India is 2 lakh 28,000
rupees
perom understanding the responsibilities
of SEO Executives an SEO executive is
responsible for Gathering analytics
reports creating SEO friendly content
and implementing onpage and off-page
techniques the average base pay of an
SEO executive in US is
39,380 per anom and in India is in
between 1ak 192,000 to 3 lakh 62,000
rupees
perom an SEO manager is responsible for
analyzing reports of the campaigns
developing content marketing strategies
managing a team of SEO experts fixing
technical SEO issues and more the
average base pay pay of SE manager in US
is
$172,600
rupees moving towards the job
responsibilities of SEO expert SEO
expert is responsible for creating
keywords and content strategy link
building
strategies competitor analysis and
reports and campaigning the average base
pay of an SEO expert in US is in
between1 53,000 to 78,000 perom and in
India is 276,000 rupees
perom some companies hiring for
significant rols under SEO are
Microsoft Disney seens Udi and deoy
we're going to go through a series of
questions and I'm going to answer those
questions for you okay so the first
question that you might be asking an
interview is differentiate between do
follows and no follows okay so if you've
taken or listen to my SEO courses on
YouTube for SEO we we talked a lot about
do follows and no follows and and simply
put I mean do follows are just signals
to the search engines to follow the link
so there's a link on site a pointing to
site B we're going to basically tell
Google Bing and some of these other
search engines hey go ahead and follow
that link now no follow is just the
opposite so no follow link doesn't allow
the search engine crawlers to follow it
so if we have a link on our site site a
pointing to site B we can put a no
follow tag in there and what that's
going to do it's going to signal to the
Crawlers hey don't follow this link so
in the end if the Crawlers don't follow
the link then there's not going to be
any link juice pass and so Google is not
going to give you credit or give that
site credit for having a link pointing
to it or pointing to another site or
from another site and so it's all about
linking so we can control if there's
links on our site whether we want the
Crawlers to recognize those or not
simply with no follow text so just a
reminder link jues is the reputation or
Equity passed from one website to
another so if you have a link on another
website and that website is of high
quality meaning their page Authority
their domain Authority is high they have
a lot of content you know they're not
spammy they're really rich and they're
relevant then you may want to make sure
that the link pointing from that site to
your site is a no follow so that way
that Google can recognize the link from
that site to your site and basically
that reputation is going to be passed on
to you okay so that's a do follow versus
a no follow and why would we do a no
follow well it depends it really depends
a lot of social media platforms like
Facebook have no follows if you have a
lot of content you may not want to be
pushing out a lot of due follows it
could actually look bad from an external
linking standpoint and so a lot of sites
are really particular about who they
want to pass link juice on to and give
credit for the link so it's a business
decision at the end of the day there's
really no hard fast rule here except
from an SEO perspective if I a site and
I have a lot of external links pointing
outward to other sites I'm going to be
particular about who I allow the search
engine to follow and what links I allow
not to follow okay so here's an example
of what they look like so do follow is
simply just the hre notice the no follow
has the the tag appended to it the hre
tag with a no follow so if the search
engine's crawling your site and they see
that no follow there they're not going
to follow that link and vice versa if
there's a link on another site pointing
to yours and there's a no follow there
you're not going to get credit the
search engines aren't going to pick up
that link okay so question two what is
301 redirect and how is it different
from a 302 redirect so 301 redirects
tell users in the search engine
specifically that an original page has
been moved and this is the keyword here
permanently so permanently moved we're
going to explain that in a minute so
it's just moved from one page to another
and so so if we don't have a page
anymore we have a new page let's just
say you built a new website with new
URLs you want to make sure the old page
is pointing to the new page with a 301
redirect so if a 301 redirect is
permanent then a 302 is temporary so we
want the search engines to recognize
that we have 301 permanent redirects in
place why because if we have temporary
then it might aler alert Google to not
keep that page in its search engine
rankings because it's temporary so why
would Google want to keep a temporary
page or even a page that is pointing to
another page on a temporary basis so
they REM May remove both pages from its
index okay but if we have something
permanent in place Google may say okay
this page is permanently linking to
another page or redirecting to another
page therefore it's stable it's
permanent we're going to keep that new
page p in the index and eventually
remove the old page so really something
permanent is more stable in the eyes of
the search engine something temporary
may not be as stable in the eyes of say
Google and if they don't see it as
stable then they may remove both pages
from the index okay so the idea is we
want to be found in Google search index
and we get it sometimes Pages go away
for a variety reasons and if it does go
away just make sure you have a new page
for it and that new page is a three 301
permanent redirect okay so question
three why are backlinks important in SEO
well we kind of hinted on that a bit
with the no follow because if we have a
link from another website pointing to
ours and that link from that other
website is really relevant and and has a
high page and domain Authority then it's
going to benefit us and so backlinks are
important because if we have backlinks
from high quality sites it's going to
improve the credibility of our site
especially if it's a do follow tag so
the search engines are going to
recognize the relationship between the
site that has a link pointing to us okay
so it's just going to build our
credibility it's going to increase
increase our domain Authority and then
the net effect of that is if we're
credible and we have high domain
Authority then that's going to increase
the rankings of our pages and when the
pages increase in ranking then we're
going to get more of a line and share of
the traffic for certain keywords that
our pages are found for and if our pages
are found and getting traffic then
because we have increased rankings we're
likely going to have increased traffic
and then it's just a snowball effect so
more traffic leads to more engagement
and conversions so the whole idea for
SEO is remember you have an onpage
strategy and an off-page strategy
building external links is part of an
off-page SEO strategy and we want to
make sure that you know we are
relevant in the form of a link or in the
form of content on other high quality
sites being on a high quality site only
benefits us because again increases
their D domain Authority Google sees
this is more relevant therefore pages
are going to benefit by ranking higher
and therefore when we rank higher we get
more traffic so it's a snowball effect
so having backlinks is important because
it snowballs all the way through to
conversions okay so what are the best
practices to rank your videos on YouTube
this is a great question really great
question given the importance of videos
especially with SEO because videos are
found YouTube in itself is a search
engine so if we have a video how are we
going to get it to rank on YouTube well
first things first you never want to put
a video out there and want it to rank if
it's not engaging or informative so make
sure you go ahead and follow the best
practices of having engaging in
informative content in your video now
once you have that video in place you
want to optimize it and then some of the
key factors for optimizing the video are
you want to choose a title that has high
search volume and low difficulty just as
you would keyword for example for a web
page you want to choose a title with a
keyword in it that has high volume and
low difficulty I.E low competition okay
so you want a nice ratio there and you
know when you want to choose a title
it's going to get people to watch the
video too so it's not all about just
choosing a title just for the sake of
high volume you also have to choose
something that's relevant that's going
to be catchy as well and then with that
title goes the description so you want a
description that's very relevant to your
title okay because most people aren't
going to click on a video just for the
sake of the title they're going to want
to probably get a sneak peek via the
description of what it is so again you
want to optimize that description but
make sure the description is is just as
snazzy as the title okay you also want
to use accurate and relevant video tags
just as you would on Twitter or Facebook
tag these videos okay so make sure your
title tag length doesn't exceed 100
characters because it will get chopped
off so again that goes back to just
writing something really short and to
the point that's going to grab
somebody's attention Okay you also want
to upload a captivating thumbnail
something that's relevant then that's
going to grab somebody's attention and
then again we set it similar to the
video tags we want to use relevant
hashtags again just as you would with
Twitter and Facebook go ahead and throw
some hashtags in there that people could
see because people search via
hashtagging and then this goes about
saying you did all the work created a
really great video it's engaging it's
informative you optimized it feel free
to promote your video on other social
media platforms okay don't just stick
with YouTube per se so the benefit here
is if you post it on Facebook LinkedIn
or whatever platform of your choice and
it gets engagement people click on the
link go to YouTube they're going to like
it and then other people are going to
see that engagement they're going to see
how many people liked it or how many
subscribers you have so promote your
videos to help you with the ranking of
the video on YouTube so that does play
into it so go ahead and promote it so
other people can watch it like it
comment Etc and that's going to engage
other people to want to do the same so
what is mobile first indexing this is a
really important and timely question
mobile first indexing means Google's
just using mobile friendly content for
indexing and ranking websites so in
other words Google for example has two
Bots they have the traditional desktop
bot and they have a smartphone bot and
eventually everybody that has a website
is going to be migrated over to the
smartphone bot and so with that
smartphone bot goes to your website and
starts crawling what do you think
they're looking for their smartphone
bought they're looking for mobile
friendly content if it's not mobile
friendly meaning the page isn't designed
for a smartphone browser or let's just
say the images are way too large or you
have to expand the text just to read it
you know a lot of these these issues
that somebody would have just simply
trying to read something on a web page
on their mobile device Google's not
going to grab that that content so you
want to make sure it's mobile friendly
so it gets indexed and so if your
website has a responsive design Google
will rank your website based on its
performance on mobile devices okay so
you want to make sure that your website
is mobile friendly and if you're in an
interview and somebody asked this
question you could even take it a step
further and say look I'm going to
measure how friendly my my website is
for mobile devices in Google search
console because Google search console
has a report that will show you what
pages on your website are not mobile
friendly and it's not a guarantee but I
could tell you if I'm Google and I'm
crawling your site with my smartphone
bot and that page or one of my pages is
not mobile friendly I'm probably not
going to index it or rank it so you want
to leverage that report in Google search
console to see what pages are mobile
friendly so that's a little bonus for
you to really impress the interviewer
who ask you this question because how
you going to know if one of your pages
is mobile friendly or not if you don't
look at a report so keep an eye on
Google search consoles mo mobile
usability report okay number six list
down the most important local SEO
ranking factors okay so organic local
ranking is just as important as anything
else in organic search because if you
have a local business you want to use
the likes of say Google my business to
show up with somebody types in you know
looking for a florist or you looking for
a coffee shop so what you want to do is
you want to create a web page for every
product and service you also want to opt
for your business listings on Google my
business and and there are plenty of
other local business directories out
there like Yelp for example or Bing even
has one so go ahead and also make sure
you have a business listing as well but
since Google in the United States has a
huge Market sh share you want to start
with Google first you want to update
your nap citations on your website
maintain consistency of your nap okay so
nap is name address phone number so you
want to make sure that that's current
and consistent so if you have a number
on your website make sure it's the same
number on Google my business okay you
can embed a Google map on your website
you could certainly optimize the
metatags and content not only on your
web pages but within your Google my
business directory so you can add your
business to other local directories like
I mentioned Yelp and then also just as
important op for reviews and ratings
okay so the more reviews that H you have
the better off you are okay so I always
say this with or with local search three
of the main factors in showing up for
local search on say Google is obviously
the keyword the second is the proximity
of where that person is and then third
is the reviews so you can't really
control the proximity but you can
control the keyword and you can control
the reviews to some degree so work hard
at getting reviews for your business but
at the same time you can certainly work
in some keywords let's just say for your
product and service pages on your
website but also you can translate that
over to Google my business okay so
working in those keywords making sure
your your number your address your name
they're all consistent and and really
just spreading your the the business out
on other directories that's really all
these are really key factors for local
SEO okay so question number seven how to
avoid duplicate content getting
penalized for duplicate content so for
example if you have two different
versions of a web page you may result in
a duplicate content issue so it's just
SEO 101 you never want to have two two
or more pages with the same content so
what do we do well we can avoid this in
having Google penalize us by again
setting up a 301 redirect remember three
ones are permanent we can also use what
they call a canonical tag and a
canonical tag basically alerts the
search engines as to which page is the
original okay so if we have an original
page we want to point to that page with
our canonical tag and then the third
option is op for preferred domain and
Google search console okay so if you
have multiple nor nams make sure you set
up a primary one in search console so
those are ways to work around it of this
three I would always go with the
canonical tags because that's just a tag
that's going to sit on the page it's
going to alert Google as to what the
original is just in case they get their
hands on the duplicate so all the pages
that have the same content are going to
have the same canonical tag pointing to
one page so again three ones are
permanent you can simply just redirect
one to the other if you end up having
duplication or you can just tell the
search engines hey this is the original
page or you can go through search
console okay number eight what are the
tactics to increase a web page speed
okay so what are some of the tactics
well when you build a site especially
for mobile you want to keep it as simple
as possible and what I mean by simple as
possible really I mean hey use a simple
website design don't get overly creative
if you will most websites all websites
have images you're not going to be able
to get around that but just make sure
you optimize your images in other words
don't have such a large image size if
you don't need something very large
don't have it okay you want to improve
server response time and what do we mean
by that well your site's sitting on a
server somewhere you can own that server
or you can be renting it out from say
Amazon web services or let's just say
GoDaddy as your register they also have
web hosting well if you have it on say
GoDaddy server you may be sharing that
server with other businesses and at
certain times of the day other
businesses may get a lot of traffic and
suck up a lot of bandwidth what is that
going to do that's going to reduce the
server response time for your site and
so you want to make sure you have a an
idea of you know what server your web
page your website is on and you want to
be able to can have some control over
that because if your server response is
slow that's going to slow down
everything else in terms of loading in
the browser and that's not going to be
good for SEO okay optimize your code we
mean by optim minifying when we say
minifying we mean get rid of some of the
Redundant code if you have CSS you know
get rid of chop some of the get rid of
the JavaScript you're not using so
that's what we mean by optimizing code
reduce redirects okay ideally you just
want to have one redirect in place you
don't want to create a daisy chain so to
speak of redirecting and redirecting
after that that's never going to bode
well and it's going to slow things down
as well enable browser caching so if you
enable browser caching basically if
somebody comes back to the page they've
been on say two days ago they're
probably going to see a cach version of
that page and then opt for the content
delivery Network as well so these are
some of the ways to reduce page speed
now if you're curious about the page
speed of your website you can always go
to Google's PHP insights tool and all
you have to do is just go Google page
speed insights or even just something
generic like Google page speed and
you're going to get this tool page speed
insights and all you need to do is just
plug in a URL when you plug in the URL
Google is going to analyze the URL for
both mobile and desktop and so here we
could see Google gives a score so we
could see the score for mobile and we
could see the score for desktop just by
clicking on desktop and so here I can
see some of the issues that the site may
be having in terms of P page low time
for their desktop if I flip over to
mobile you know here I could see some
other issues for example they have a
server static assets with efficient cash
policy now if you're not sure what the
heck that means you can always just
click on it and you can see some
specifics here and or you can just
always Google it as well uh here you got
the reduce the impact of third party
code okay so that's another thing uh
reduce JavaScript execution time so
again going back to a lot of some of the
comments we made about coding okay some
sometimes too much code or code not
functioning as well as it should we'll
tend to slow down the site okay so you
can use page speed insights you can
always get a glimpse of how pages are
loading simply by also going to for
example Google analytics under Behavior
okay you can go to sight speed and if
you click on overview okay Google what
Google does is they do a sampling of
pages over time and in this case based
on 89 Page views they have an average
page low time and so you can get a sense
of how quick specific Pages load your
site overall simply by looking at the
site speed overview report in Google
analytics to get a sense of how quick
your pages are loading now there's
certain factors that do affect lad time
so obviously the way the page is built
with the code the images Etc
but also the browser each browser loads
differently okay so you want to take a
look at it by browser also by country
every country has a different network
you can be in the United States and have
worse network service than you do say in
you know co uh Ivory Coast in Africa
okay so it really depends on the network
you're on so and also the page every
page is built differently so you want to
get a sense of what pages are loading
quicker and which Pages or not you can
simply just go to page timings in Google
analytics and you get a sense of what
pages do not load fast which ones do and
maybe hone in on the pages that aren't
loading fast and address those pages
first okay so you have two tools at your
disposal one Google analytics and one
page speed insights okay so let's look
at question number nine here so when
should an individual Target short tail
and longtail keywords okay okay so
remember short tail are usually one to
two keywords very Broad in nature
longtail keywords maybe three four
keywords in a query or maybe an entire
sentence those are considered longtail
keywords so usually short tail keywords
have higher volume but also higher
competition longer tail keywords usually
have lower uh volume but also lower
competition but the great thing about
longtail keywords the conversion rate
will tend to be a little bit higher than
say a short tail because it's less vague
and more specific so you can use short
tail keywords if you're trying to drive
a lot of visitors because those keywords
are going to be vague or Broad in nature
longtail keywords are used for targeted
Pages such as product pages in article
so if you have a specific product with a
long name you can certainly optimize
that page for that product name again
the product name may have low volume but
if somebody types in exactly that
product name you show up the chance of
you them converting are going to be very
high so you don't have to always be that
specific at the product name but try and
be as specific as you possibly can in
order to get somebody to click on your
link in the search engine results and
get them over to your site to convert
okay so those are really the big
differences short tail very broad very
vague a lot of volume but also a lot of
competition but hey if you're ranking
for short tail keyword you're probably
going going to get a lot of traffic the
conversion rates may not be as high as
something say longtail where hey maybe
you're just toned in on a few set number
of products and you're not care you
don't care a lot about the traffic you
just care about getting the relevant
traffic to your site to convert okay
number 10 what are the important
elements to focus while developing a
website so we're talking in terms of SEO
okay so if somebody ask me this question
in an interview what am I going to f
focus on while developing a website well
the answers are right here yes we talked
about mobile mobile is so important
because a lot of websites are going to
be indexed with Google smartphone bot so
mobile usability is very important so we
need to make sure our website is
responsive for mobile just some basic
practices when it comes to site
architecture navigation we want to have
a simple URL structure okay no overly
cumbersome the navigation should simply
be clean and need okay if you have five
products okay maybe you have uh in your
navigation you have something called
products with all five listed or you
have all five products in the main
navigation the key is you just want to
make it clean and neat and easy for
somebody to find the the rule of thumb
is if it's good for the end user
probably going to be good for Google but
if complicated for the end User it's
probably going to be complicated for
Google you always want to create a
sitemap now what is that sitemap a
sitemap is simply just a formatted file
with to that includes all your url and
assets your images and your videos
they're going to be sitting on your
server as well so you want Google or
these these Bots to be able to find your
pages and assets and by the way you want
to take it a step further and make sure
you upload that site map which is
sitting in the root directory meaning
domain.com sitemap.xml okay you want to
take that sitemap and make sure you
input that sitemap location in Google
search console that way Google search
console has a one-way ticket to grab the
elements in the sitemap another
important element to focus on while
developing a website is having a robot's
text file and all A robot's text file is
it's like a lock I always say to a house
so if you lock a door in your house
nobody's going to be able to get in that
door so it's all what robots text file
is you're telling Google and these other
Bots that are coming ACR your site
what's locked and what's not locked
meaning what they have access to what
they don't have access to so you want to
be able to make sure you have a robot's
text file if you're trying to not index
specific pages of your website because
if you tell Google don't crawl these
Pages or this directory they're not
going to get crawled if they don't get
crawled they're not going to get indexed
so robots text file is an important
element to focus on while you're
developing your website and while you're
developing your website it could be on a
you know in a directory just called new
website so you probably want to have new
website as the directory in the robo
text file and just to let Google know
don't go into this directory because
it's my new website I'm not ready to go
live yet so you don't want an indexed so
there are a lot of reasons to have
robots text files that's the main reason
sit map you want Google to get these
pages and assets quickly okay you want
to make sure that your site architecture
navigation is in order you want to make
sure your site is mobile friendly and
you also want to make sure you have
content on your website that's the key
cuz that's what's going to keep people
on the website and engaged and when I
say content I don't necessarily just
mean words I also mean videos I also
mean images you know something
interactive okay you want to keep people
engaged that's the key behind it trust
me if if an end user finds your site
engaging Google is likely going to find
your side engaging okay so those are
good brownie points to bring up if
somebody asked you this question in an
interview so just a recap here it's
important to have a better site
structure so that Bots can easily access
an indx content okay with a responsive
design helps to make your website mobile
friendly and user friendly would also
increase the amount of time a user
spends on your website which may improve
your site's ranking sitemap is simply
just a file that helps search engine
Bots to understand the structure of the
website okay how many pages are on your
website and where they located along
with the videos and images okay and then
the robots text just instructs the
search engine crawlers to understand
what pages should not be indexed okay
this is simply just a text file and it's
added to the root directory again think
like a door think of a lock okay you can
tell you can lock whatever doors you
want in your house then give it that way
so here we wrap up search engine
optimization course if you have any
queries regarding the any Concept in the
video feel free to add it in the comment
section and our experts will be happy to
help you do subscribe to Simply learn to
stay updated with new technology Trends
thanks for watching staying ahead in
your career requires continuous learning
and upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here